[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it has been electric day one we saw
trades day two we saw value day three
we're going to see sleepers i'm connor
rogers joined by michael felder felder
how are we feeling right now man i'm
feeling good you're looking good
feel good look good play good right
that's what we're all about today uh
we're comfortable and i hope you guys
are gonna get comfortable with these
picks that's right and obviously if you
stayed with us for days one and two uh
we had adam lefkow with us we had
richard sherman we had jason kelsey we
had amman ross saint brown and we are
not done yet because we have a special
guest joining us today a true i mean the
definition of this word legend of the
game oh yeah tori holt is on with us
today tori how we feeling day three of
the draft man let's go
day three man i feel good like as as
michael just mentioned i'm comfortable
i'm at home i'm watching the draft you
know day one and two has been fantastic
and i can only imagine what today is
going to be like today is when you build
the meat and potatoes of your football
team there's a lot of good football
players that are available so you're
looking for culture play guys that can
build continue to build on the culture
guys they can play special teams guys
that can serve as the ones and twos
you're looking for everything today and
there's a lot of talent left
my man that is absolutely right this is
where you can get starting level talent
for value for cheap for these kind of
picks and we're going to take a look at
my best players available in just a
minute but before we get to that i want
to talk about felder's favorites these
are these don't have to be the guys of
the premium positions or even just the
best players of all these are guys that
fell their c's talon in that maybe
shouldn't be sitting here anymore yeah i
mean obviously we've got jamari sawyer
georgia probably a guard in the nfl kobe
bryant we've talked about him ad nauseum
when it comes to the reality that this
guy's a really good player opposite
saul's gardener vero mckinley love him
as a safety coming out of oregon kohler
tight in i think today we see a big run
on the what's left of this tied in class
uh two guys from utsa tariq wool in a
super long corner and sincere mccormick
a running back that i think is he's
short but he is not small you're
throwing a bina ize i think as a project
player which is what you want on day
three a guy you can grow into a future
starter uh ridgeway from arkansas lucida
smith i think is one of the most
interesting players in the game first
time i ever saw him he was playing tight
in the tank and listen kelsey talked
about this right over the last two days
he likes tight he likes guys that are
tight ends converted into offensive
lineman and that's what we got there
with smith and then ty chandler uh by
way of unc but a tennessee guy that
ultimately is a running back that i
think can check all your boxes in terms
of running pass bro and then obviously
being able to catch the ball in the
backfield i love it felder you said
short but not small i hope that's what
people say about me let's check in with
tory holt right now tori you're looking
at the board today is there anybody out
there right now that you really really
like that you want to see come off the
board in these first couple picks to
kick things off
yeah well michael just mentioned tai
chandler i had an opportunity to see it
see here being in north carolina at unc
play every single weekend very talented
guy came over from transferred over from
tennessee he could run the football he
can also catch the ball in the backfield
i thought he came on really well late in
the season last year for unc this guy
has a lot of value a lot of potential a
lot of upside and then also his teammate
sam howe who's still out there i mean
where will sam how will another
quarterback go pretty early here in the
next couple of rounds so those are two
guys that are intrigued me right off the
bat i like it all right let's take a
look at my best available what's left of
the big board here a couple guys that i
thought would be day two picks uh that
i'm excited about right here you see
jamari saw you're right at the top there
that's been felder's guy from the
beginning he's just value maybe he's not
the most athletic maybe he's not the
tallest guy with the most length he
could be a 10-year starter at guard no
doubt then you see the opposite godzilla
daniel fellaille yeah right tackle in
the future good pass kind of like where
i am now is this
so and then you see darion canard as
well was probably gonna kick inside
right at the next level he did play
right tackle so we got a nice little
offensive line trio there at the top of
the board i don't think they're going to
be waiting very long you heard tori
bring up sam howell he is the cream of
the crop of what's left of the
quarterbacks and then after that really
a lot of projects we might hear about
bailey zappi but other than that sam
howell is going to be the quarterback
that probably goes early today because
if you don't get him there's not much
left of this class and the story of the
day in my eyes and felder we talked
about this off camera is going to be the
running backs yes how many years do you
see running starting running backs
taking on day three
we know the bucks have already taken one
they're kicking things off today the
jets are early they took brees hall but
you never know here with the texans even
the browns let's not forget i believe
kareem hunt is on the final year of his
deal you have nick chubb there but that
outside zone scheme that they run they
rotate their running backs over and over
again so we're going to see action on
the running backs in the fourth round
this is going to be a really exciting
day as the picks get rolling in so
felder we got the bucks kicking things
off here super bowl contender something
we've talked about days one and two
probably looking for guys that can play
now
anyone we're thinking here for tampa we
saw him say take rashad white uh you see
the board right there logan hall uh
godeki and rashad white is there
anything you like here i think they go
on the other side of the ball right and
i think tariq woolen is a real real
option here a long corner fits well he's
got the opportunity to go out and do
insane things with that length it's very
rare you see a corner that's 6-4 that
runs a 4-3 so for me i'm looking in that
direction because they've gone all
offense so maybe we do see them go to
the defensive side of things to try to
make sure that they've got a guy who can
come play in in your sub packages
i'm with you and you talk about todd
bowles down there he loves his corners
and credit to todd obviously a long time
super bowl safety he's one of the best
in the game at developing defensive
backs and tariq woolen
six foot four one of the craziest
athletic profiles we have ever seen
still kind of figuring it out right
felder i think when you watch him play
corner of those instincts you're looking
for that green light to come on as well
we have the houston texans who uh i
would love to see their picks in the
back when we get a chance i think
they've done a good job felder they kind
of your classic line of steady eddy guys
that this is a roster that's been bare
bones uh they really had to fill it out
they've taken a lot of players and
they've taken a lot of guys that can
start right away and it's not just eric
stingley it's been a board beyond that
so i'm looking forward to seeing what
the texans do today to keep building
that thing and you know i think my one
question with them is they like davis
mills is that a landing spot for sam
howell where you make things interesting
or is that a spot where you go full in
and say davis mills you are absolutely
the guy not even looking to bring in
competition for you i think that's the
question do you want to make him
comfortable which is what
which means you don't draft a
quarterback or do you want to make him
feel like he has to press and i think
that's the question if you want to make
him comfortable you find out weapons you
find guys that can he might be able to
throw two guys that he can grow with but
if you want a competition then yes sam
how's your answer right here yeah i
think so as well so we're going to keep
that
keep that going there and we're going to
have the browns seattle has done a lot
of nice things in this trap they've
invested heavily on building that
offensive line but
back to the offensive lineman as well we
obviously saw tampa take a guard in
godeki
houston is a team that needs offensive
line help as well so i don't think it's
going to be long before we're tapping
into that best available when you're
looking at fellail when you're looking
at canard felder i'll throw this to you
why do you think these guys are here we
saw canard dominated as a run blocker in
kentucky we saw fellaily maybe not play
with that kill streak for his size but
when you're that big and reliable and
pass pro you usually come off the board
early well i think the big thing for me
with fellaily is he's still kind of
young in the football in the world of
football so he's he's he's a project
even though he's a you know an elite
talent he's still a project as with
canard we talked about it last night
when his his center got taken before him
i think the big thing with me is maybe
teams don't know what to do with him
he's a guy that obviously wants to play
tackle is he resistant to the idea of
kicking down the guard you don't know
because we don't know what he's talked
what he's saying in those meetings but i
think that's the big thing the the
interesting thing for me with respect to
kentucky is
they are a hard-nosed football team yeah
so whether he wants to or not if you
want him to if he wants to be in the nfl
and he has to play guard i think he can
do it and they played with serious
energy so i'm looking forward to seeing
what happens with this all right and
speaking of the trenches a lot of good
blocking tight ends on the board
and we saw
last night kind of end with maybe a
preview of what's today the jets took
jeremy rucker yep we saw trey mcbride go
uh we saw greg dolcich go who's the pass
catcher and we're gonna see a charlie
kohler player similar mold gonna go
today but k dotten daniel bellinger jake
ferguson is there a guy you like out of
this group and do you think these guys
are sure-fire fourth-rounders just
because
in my opinion felder these guys can all
start they could at least be your tight
end too today yeah i think jake ferguson
is the one i probably like the most this
is a guy that good athlete not as not
quite the athlete as jeremy rucker but i
think he fits into that a similar mold
he caught a lot of balls at wisconsin he
was a reliable option for them so
ferguson i would put on that list i'm
very curious to see about what what's up
with jalen weidemeyer where folks view
him as a guy that can play in line we've
seen him flex out a little where he fits
into the mix because he's another one
that i do think could come in and be te2
for you and that that creates a really
good option
all right so we have our first pick of
the the pick of the day we talked about
it with the bucks looking for impact
players kade otten comes off the board
to start this tight end run uh i've
heard for a while that the bucks were
all over players like trey mcbride
earlier in this draft they obviously
were not able to get him so now we look
at cade otton a guy with a ton of
experience as both a zone and gap run
blocker that's what he can do and he can
catch the ball in that five to 12 yard
area move the chains get you first downs
but felder i think of one thing with
katon experience he's not a guy that
just played last year he's not a guy
that just played the year before he's
played many many reps of football and
for the bucks that tight end room's
looking a little thin we haven't seen
rob gronkowski come back so i really
like this pick for the bucks this is a
good way to kick off
the third day of the draft here when
you're looking for me my 78th overall
player yes and we are at pick 106. so
this is an a i think he could play right
away and this is the kind of player that
tom brady things aren't working on the
outside that's the guy shore hands
middle of the field what do you think
felder yeah i think he's the guy that's
going to eat up the middle of that field
we saw him on the little the little
swing screen as well someone that's
going to be able to set up because he
blocks so well the idea that he can
feign a block and then get set up for a
screen i think is really makes him
really special you see him there working
through the interior a quarterback
brady's not afraid to throw to the
interior of a defense especially because
it's an easier throw right that's a
straight-line throw he can do those
things so for me i think this is a great
pick again a guy who a lot of folks
viewed through his athletic profile as
one of the top tight ends in this in
this draft even though he didn't get to
be as productive as someone like a trey
mcbride i also go with an a this is a
great pick it's got he's got an
opportunity to have an impact
immediately he's well taught he's
sure-handed and he understands where
he's supposed to be open on the field
that's exactly i'm with you felder all
the way tori holt want to bring you in
here you know a little bit about
catching the football uh and k dotten
has done a good job of that at
washington for a couple of years what do
you think of this selection for the
bucks
no i i like it a lot and we all know if
you know the history of tom brady he
likes to throw the football to his tight
ends and this is a guy that's a
four-year starter
he's very sudden really good hands have
a really good feel for running routes
and as you saw there we saw a clip there
he was working over the middle of the
football field tom brady likes throwing
the ball over the middle of the football
field and it's going to open up things
for the guys out on the perimeter mike
evans when you talk about diggs when you
got a tight end that can fulfill the
middle of the football field and he can
get down in there and block so i like
this pickup by the tampa bay buccaneers
giving tom brady another weapon that he
will use i do too and once again not a
project not a guy that you think is
going to sit for a year and you know for
a bucks team that they're in the luxury
they don't have a lot of needs they went
into this draft already they got a pass
rusher a gap shooter in logan hall they
went and got another interior offensive
lineman which they did need to add to
the board tight end was one of the last
things for them and you got one of these
starting players here for the board so
now we're waiting on the houston texans
they've had a really good draft at some
point let's take a look at what the
texans have done in this draft because
they have had a lot of picks nick
casario has obviously navigated the
board extremely well they took a high
big a big swing for the fences pick
earlier
now felder do you think this is the part
of the draft where you start to tailor
off you see stingley there kenyan green
industry a lot of these guys have played
a lot of football and have played in big
time games including christian harris
and john metchi both from alabama what
do you think of this hall so far i love
it i mean look at this group with this
group of players right obviously sec sec
big 12 sec scc uh pac-12 they went out
and they went got big big players from
big schools
that can get the job done i think jalen
petra is my favorite pick that they've
had because they got him for value uh
but the pick is in conner took one of my
favorite players on the board today
there we go damien pierce to houston
texas they draft damian pierce 107
overall pierce is a running back from
florida this guy can play and i think
the cool thing about watching damien
pierce play is you're gonna get a guy
that was not the leader of the rushing
leader on his football team that was
emery jones but he's someone that
understands how to be tough how to be
strong i look though i look at the way
that he runs the football he wants to
get wide but he's not afraid to run the
ball inside he's not afraid of contact
he's a little bowling ball in there and
i love that about his game this is
someone that i think had a really big
offseason had a great come up once we
got past the season where florida was up
and down once he got into the the that
pre-draft work he really started to show
himself i'm gonna go the b plus here
this is someone that can play right now
and the best thing i love about him is
pass pro conor i want you to talk about
him because i know you got to see him
yeah got to see him at the senior bowl
he was tremendous in one on ones he was
the dude out there absolutely to me
david montgomery that's the player i
think of when i watched damien pierce a
guy that forced a ton of missed tackles
this year did an excellent job running
the football violently when he gets to
the second level he's a guy that car
crasher linebackers but safeties and
corners you don't want to run into him i
saw a scissor kick move against samford
that i have not seen in a long long time
this guy's got a full creative package
as a runner to make guys miss he is an
unbelievable open field guy that just
didn't get the ball enough builder
that's what was a little confusing to me
with damian pierce he gets the senior
bowl he looks like the guy he was my
fourth uh fourth rated running back in
this draft so the value here is great a
top 80 player on the board and for the
texans this is a team that could not run
the football last year yes the offensive
line had its struggles yes the
quarterback probably wasn't respected
all the time but nobody can break a
tackle you need guys that can create on
their own when everything's not right on
the offensive line that group's going to
look a lot better they obviously are
they believe in davis mills i'm going
with an a minus here damien pierce man
he's one of the more underrated players
in this entire running back group
because of that violent running style
and you see the fan reaction here i
would imagine texans fans are pretty
jacked up over this one
yeah this is fantastic obviously you
give it a minus and give it a b plus
this is a guy that can play and the big
thing for me with him is the break the
breaking tackles if you can't break
tackles you can't play in the nfl that's
right you have to every they can they'll
give you 10 but you got to make one guy
miss and i think that's the big key
either you're breaking the tackle you're
shaking him and he can do a little bit
of both that's why the value comes for
damian pierce his ability to do a little
bit of both get you one that gets you
someone that could do both right as they
say that's what this is the guy that can
make you miss but he also has the
ability to um to run through those arms
and to listen he'll put his shoulder
down too and i love him about pass pros
i mentioned before yeah you know it's
hard to find
rookie running backs that can come in
and
stand up blitzing linebackers and damien
pierce is somebody that can do that and
this next pick is going to be one of the
biggest talking points of the day yes
this pit because he's one of the best
players on the board i think he's one of
the most polarizing players in the
entire draft and that is perrian winfrey
from oklahoma going to the cleveland
browns who have been looking for help on
their defensive line
pick 108 here felder for winfrey a guy
that the tape a little hot and cold but
when you let him just shoot gaps be a
pass rushing three tech the athleticism
is high end i'll be honest with you
seeing them down in mobile one-on-ones
against good offensive linemen offensive
linemen that are already off the board
in this draft they couldn't touch him
they couldn't touch him excellent pass
rush moves he can give you a swim move
he can rip and dip that club is
heavy-handed i wonder about the
discipline against the run but you're
taking him in the fourth round you're
putting him in a cleveland brown system
where miles garrett all the attention
can't always be on miles garrett you
need other rushers that draw attention
perrian winfrey can do that here and
once again value value value you're
looking at a player that there's just
not a lot of guys like this in this
class 77th overall player we are in the
hundreds this is an a if you can get him
dialed in you can get him to at least be
capable against the run and contain
sometimes but you unlock that elite pass
rushing ability i love it so here's the
thing and i look at looking at what they
have jordan elliott tell me to guy
you throw in miles garrett obviously
chase vinovich and they got alex wright
already uh earlier in this draft i think
the big key for me with looking at perry
on winfrey is going to be his ability to
be a one gap player and that's the
question and that's what you want you're
looking at a 4-3 scheme he can be a
one-gap player if you ask him to be a
one gap player that means he can get
into that gap and dominate and that's
the key here don't ask him to two gap
don't ask him to be someone that gets
the extension then reads and reacts set
him on a path so he knows i'm in c-gap
this player i'm in b-gap this play
that's where he's going to be successful
i'm going to give it an a minus i think
the value's there the question is the
plan and if we see that plan come to
fruition now we got a guy that's going
to be a dog tory holt one of the best
players on the board going into today it
always felt like there could have been a
little more with perrian winfrey at
oklahoma but he's had an incredible
process what do you think here for
cleveland
yeah i know i think it's a good look
when you think about adding more depth
to this defensive front that's already
pretty formidable in the national
football league leading with with mal
garrett uh mal
miles garrett but when you look at the
strengths appareon explosive uh he's got
a lot of power uh he works through the
whistle is one of the things i think a
lot of teams like about him that effort
that motor and that's what you need in
these rounds these types of players you
need that effort you need that motor and
perion winfrey will provide that and i
think the scheme certainly will fit and
he should be highly highly motivated
playing off playing on the same thing as
the front with miles garrett you're
absolutely right a team that has not
brought back today beyond clowning yet
yeah this was a pick that we've been
waiting on them to address defensive
line i like it a lot in seattle we got
the pick coming in uh they've had a very
interesting start to the draft getting
charles cross at nine yes felder a
offensive line that needed to be
completely retooled we're starting to
see it there abe lucas and now we have
the pick come in here and
the teams are striking right now all the
players that should have went yesterday
are coming off the board rapid fire kobe
bryant uh sauce gardener's running mate
at cincinnati a four-year starter the
ball skills really that green light came
on the last two years zelda that's what
i love about it he's patient i think he
can play off i think he's got the size
to play press and once again
the best corner on the board here my
73rd overall player we saw a lot of
corners in my opinion overdrafted
yesterday for upside with kobe bryant
it's kind of a what you see is what you
get and what you see is really really
good a jalen johnson kind of player he's
got size almost six foot two 190 pounds
i think the length is adequate and once
again the interception started to come
on this year that's what i saw when
sauce gardener nobody wanted to throw
his way everybody knew who sauce gardner
was in 2021 well kobe bryant was on the
other way and say all right we'll attack
him he he loved it he embraced that so
this is an a plus for me i think he's a
starter a starter at a premium position
in round four we know what seattle likes
to do he's got the patient eyes he
doesn't overreact to routes he doesn't
overreact to the football kobe bryant's
a hell of a player oh he's fantastic
this guy can play i love the way what he
brings to the table realistically is
someone that is going to do everything
right he played in a hot a man-dominated
scheme at cincinnati but watching him
slough off his own where he's able to
carry then drop make a tackle he is
always around the ball the ball skills
you mentioned the interceptions come
along but i also look at some of those
forced fumbles look at the way he's
johnny on the spot looking to try to
recover fumbles look at all those things
he brings up a lot of those different uh
traits to the table and the cool thing i
like about him is when you know that
you're gonna be the guy that's targeted
you have to approach the game a little
bit differently it's the same thing as
kylo gordon at washington you know that
you have to bring it to the table every
single day and that's what he does he
does that so that for me i agree with an
a plus this is someone i thought was
going to be a second round pick you get
them in the fourth round that means that
you're going to get the value the
reality for me here again yes a starter
i think he's got the ability to have a
long career and truly blossom into
somebody that people don't want to throw
the football to as he grows into a new
scheme
all right tori you know a thing or two
about the guys trying to lock you down
what'd you see with kobe bryant
well no i i like this kid and what i
like in all these corners actually here
today they're long guys he's six foot
193 pounds and we know that pete carroll
and that defense like long corners that
can get up and compress guys that all co
also they can play the cover 3 zone has
really good instincts will tackle out on
the perimeter good size as i just
mentioned he does a good job of reading
rounds i like this pick for the seattle
seahawks again just reminds me of the
long rich when richard sherman and those
guys were how long they were how
instinctive they were the play-making
ability that this guy would bring to the
club is a good fit for the outfit yeah
scheme fit is the name of the game all
right before we get to the
uh baltimore ravens who have had a
tremendous strap let's take a little
break and remind you of our lovely
sponsor here in rocket mortgage our
draft coverage is brought to you by
rocket mortgage if you're looking for an
edge in the home buying market then
you've got to go with rocket mortgage
their verified approval can help you
compete in a crowded market and give you
the edge you need all right baltimore
ravens on the clock i said it last night
started to feel like they were laughing
everyone felder i mean we're not talking
about just high floor players we're not
talking about plug and play starters
talking about potential all-pros kyle
hamilton
14th overall pick yeah tyler linderbaum
25th overall pick david ajabo draft and
stash he's got the ruptured achilles
from the pro day right 2023 might be
dynamite for him exactly and then travis
jones fell to the third round nobody
knows how 325 pound guy that runs sub
540 uh he can be a two gap player he can
be a pass rusher
belter you got to love this draft class
right yeah i mean this is one of the
best out there right we're talking
the ravens the jets the we're looking at
the the eagles obviously shout out to
lefko gotta give him credit for that one
but there's a couple there's a handful
of teams that had really really
successful drafts and they're using
their picks they're going out and
getting things now we're look at them
and where do you think they go with this
one since with the picks in where do you
think they go man you look at it right
here i still think they can go back to
the offensive line well uh you look at a
gap blocking scheme that values the
biggest human beings on earth one of the
guys on the top of that board you know
obviously and daniel fellaille is
somebody that's interesting to me uh
jamari sawyer you have you have darian
canard there
these guys are they all fit what they
want to do it's north to south it's
move your human being in front of you as
far as you can it's not reaching it's
not getting into space all the time it's
just being the strongest guy i think the
offensive line board has fallen into
their hands and
the pick is daniel so they went
offensively this is baltimore right
baltimore goes out in the offseason they
signed morgan moses to a modest deal
morgan moses gigantic human moves people
in the run game this is what baltimore
likes they obviously got tyler
linderbaum a little bit of an undersized
guy for their interior but how did they
how do they live with that felder they
supplement it by putting uh godzilla
next on the right side so fellaily one
of the best players on the board for me
i'll say this with him gigantic human
look how different he looks than
everybody else right and and he when he
gets those hands going and that's my
question get the hands going he drops
people i'd like to see a little bit more
killer instinct i'd like to see him
finish his blocks a little bit more but
coming from australia
obviously has not been playing football
for the longest time believe img academy
guy peter felder i know you're going to
talk about
he's somebody that with more coaching he
can truly play on the right side he
doesn't have the feet to play left
tackle no but he's so big and strong and
so hard to get around and in the fourth
round
usually tackles this big and that are
that good in pass pro they just don't
hang around this long my 60th overall
player
baltimore is just they're playing the
value game they're saying who is the
best player on the board and we're going
to take them there's no other thinking
for that for baltimore but he also fits
their scheme i'm going to go with an a
here for daniel fellaille i mean this is
a guy that weighed 390 pounds and jumped
the 29.5 at his pro day like it's
unbelievable to see what he's able to do
i'm gonna give it an a-plus as well the
big key here when you watch him play is
this is a guy who's got the all the
tools to be your set up right tackle
forever and that's the big key here he's
obviously gonna he's he's in shape the
crazy thing is that he's in shape at 380
something pounds he moves very well we
saw on the clip that we were just
watching his ability to get that punch
in there knock a guy down he's strong
he's got incredible strength he's got
the ability to get there and go make
plays so for me yeah again that's an a
plus i love what he brings to the table
this guy just really brings it punches
moves and i think when he in the run
game we need to work on his pad level a
little yes a little high a little higher
yeah but when you're that huge but when
you're that big you can still move
people because they there's nothing they
can do with you
yeah and when you look at it for me kind
of a trent brown sort of player
obviously just because of the size
because of the
the ability to move people off the line
of scrimmage but in a phone booth he's
not going to climb he's not going to get
out wide just get him going north to
south here so the ravens continue an
excellent draft speaking of excellent
drafts the new york jets are on the
clock i believe the pick is in they've
had a very very strong draft so far
felder they had a lot of holes and they
are taking
max
mitchell a developmental offensive
tackle that has had a really really nice
run here
so pick one uh player 104 for me in max
mitchell to the jets reminded me of
walker little a little bit and yeah in
the good and bad ways in passpro
something you said before about daniel
fellaille i think leverage has been an
issue at times and when it's a lack of
leverage it can be uh questions with the
anchor but overall with max mitchell he
is a guy that is not coming in to start
you have makai beckton on one side you
have george fan on one side now max
mitchell is your swing tackle i believe
he has experience on both sides of the
line here this is a classic we needed a
big guy we needed somebody with length
that can fill in on our offensive line
and maybe develop into a long-term
starter down the road so for max
mitchell here
going to the jets louisiana product a
long time starter six foot six so kind
of fits that skyscraper mold at tackle
here this is just providing depth i
don't see a long term starter here but i
see a guy that might be able to fill in
a pinch on the left side filling on the
right side i'll go with the b minus for
here the value is here uh he's not he
doesn't have to start i just think that
long-term in terms of traits i don't see
a long-term starter that's okay well i
think he's a developmental starter i
think that's what you want i think
long-term starter i'm gonna go with the
b because the big key for me is i think
he can become a long-term starter if he
learns if he grows he's going to have to
get bigger that's the key get bigger and
understand how to play with leverage if
he can do those things then all of a
sudden we've got a player so that's
going to be interesting to see if he's
able to do it i'm curious to watch how
they raise him up how much bigger can he
get how much more weight can he carry
yes comfortably and still learn how to
play with leverage yeah i think that's
the trick for him right is is gaining a
little bit more lower body mass yes
building that anchor and showing that
because i think he's got the feet to
protect the edge yes but i think once
overall it's the strength it's when
you're facing those nfl bull rushers um
and obviously they're looking at this
guy to be a contributor probably further
down the road or maybe even some
insurance in case of an injury george
famous sometime last year mckay beckton
missed all of the season it's an
insurance pick all right let's go to
tory holt talk about max mitchell going
to the new york jets
you know i i like max mitchell i like
the depth that he'll provide and you
guys just mentioned mckay beckton and he
was missing some time last year but this
dude right here as big as he is
this guy can move
he's got he's got really good body
control pretty flexible uh for a guy of
his size and then he consistently does a
good job of gaining leverage for a guy
his size six six 307 pounds i like the
depth that the new york giants is adding
to that offensive line look they're the
new york giant the new york jets are
saying we're going to be good
offensively with speed and we're going
to have depth and we're going to have
size we're going to look like the big
guy the big guy the big team out there
when we get off the bus when you ask
someone like
max mitchell who's six six three hundred
seven pounds along with makai beckham
and the rest of that offensive line
all right so the jets getting some
offensive line depth over there the new
york giants
are on the clock right now so they've
had uh an interesting draft they came
out swinging on day one and two they
obviously got help on their offensive
line and you look at the board for them
they got help at corner and we're
looking at the latest picks here we saw
kobe bryant and daniel fellaille go back
to back two of my best players on the
board today the jets take max mitchell
and we are catching up here the giants
took daniel bellinger an athletic
blocking tight end from san diego state
then we saw safety percy butler come off
the board of the washington commander so
no movement here guys we're seeing a lot
of static picks i think that's how
sometimes day three can often start
because teams are surprised at the
players that fell so
i think we talk a little daniel
bellinger here because this is a new
york giants team quietly that needed
some tight end help they've had a
transition at a lot of positions
obviously evan ingram leaves in free
agency they cut kyle rudolph the answer
at tight end isn't necessarily on the
roster and something we open the show
with today is that a lot of potential
starting tight ends or tight end twos
are on the board uh bellinger somebody
from me another senior bowl guy pat
friar moves light in a sense and you're
never going to be that level of player
but he could stay in line and block he
could do the dirty work and he can
absolutely run so
daniel bellinger will be the pick for
the giants and the giants are already
back on the clock we are flying today
but let's let's uh let's get into daniel
bellinger here right we're looking at a
player that
has really done it all for the san diego
state program he can he can give help
you help the tackles chip against pass
rushers he's smart enough to take on
blitzers he can run the seam and you see
the tough running after the catch and
for the giants they've had a
moved tight end for a long time in evan
ingram that is not going to give you
much as a blocker i think they're
getting away from that with this new
regime i think they want guys that can
live in line have a big catch radius can
make things happen in the middle of the
field for daniel jones make life a
little easier on him player 113 on the
board value checks out here as the new
york giants were picking 112. sometimes
it's that easy folks so for the giants
they continue to get help in this draft
i'm going to give this a b plus i think
this was a need for them coming into the
day i liked the group of him jake
ferguson charlie kohler it's just a
matter of what you need and the giants
preferred the blocking ability of
bellinger felder what do you think of
him yeah i like i think i think
bellinger's a good player i think that
he played in a system that's going to
translate well to the next level they
did ask him to block they're a run heavy
scheme he had to block and then to get
the ball obviously he's able to work the
seam we see him catch the ball outside
of the frame so for me i'm going to go
ahead i'm going to give him a b as well
i do like i wonder about where
weidemeyer fits into this list where
teams actually like him i think those
two guys are kind of in the same zone so
it'll be interesting to see i think why
do i be maybe a bit more athletic but
bellinger's a good pick a guy that can
come in right now bte2 and he's going to
help you give some good push in the run
game yeah it is one thing that stood out
to me on tape they even used them in the
backfield a little bit as a lead
blocking pullback so this is somebody
that has no problem playing all over the
place tori another pass catcher not in
the wide receiver mold what do you think
of daniel bellinger or the giants
no no real quick fellas i i think this
is good when you think about the new
york giants and wanting to get back to
controlling the line of scrimmage on the
offensive side of the ball with saquon
barkley you got to add some tight ends
and this guy played in a play in pro
style concepts there at uh they're in
college so he understands what it takes
in the run game and he can move people
so i like this i like this draft pick
he'll provide more depth and he'll
provide some usage helping the giants
get back to running the football with
some physicality i love it yeah they
that's what they want to do they want to
get tougher they want to control the
line of scrimmage get back to
some of those teams that obviously
helped them win super bowls and you're
seeing it you saw it they have a neil
pick yeah you know obviously on the
other side of the ball cave on thibodeau
there you go now you see daniel
bellinger like i said tight end has also
played in the backfield obviously you're
seeing some pass catching juice as well
kind of a new identity for this new york
giants team and the clock is flying
right here the washington commanders to
percy butler the giants already back on
the clock again so they are very active
and they took dane belton so felder i'm
going to throw this one to you you want
to talk about percy butler going to
washington or do you want to jump ahead
to belton let's i want to jump at the
belt i do too so i'm glad you said that
belton is a guy i mean listen he's
coming from iowa and we know what they
do right they play traditionally they
play cover two they play cover three uh
they play a little bit of men when they
have to but they use their safeties as
part of as part of their run enforcers
and some of their blitz packages and
that's what you're gonna get with belton
you'll see him here look at him lined up
out there on the goal line understand
what he has to do and he's a shooter
this guy shoots we talked about it with
jalen petry he takes a risk runs the gap
wants to go make a play and he's really
good coming downhill i think that's the
big though he's an enforcer coming
downhill that's what you want that's
what they're after here they're looking
for an identity they're looking for an
attitude don't like that he got pushed
off the point right there by charlie
kohler but the reality of it is he is
someone that is at his best coming
downhill not moving backwards so what
you're getting is a box safety for me
i'm going to go ahead and give this a b
minus i think there are better safeties
on the board but if you're looking for a
box safety this is a good guy to pick up
yeah for me i think the giants are
looking for ball production here and
when you look at belton good ball
production five interceptions eight
passes broken up in 2021 so they like
the ability to find the football
reminded me a little bit of demarius
randall and he played in the slot a
little bit and now you're starting to
see a giants team that they might like
in the short term what they have on the
outside but they're trying to find guys
that can cover on the inside they took
cordell flot on day two a two year
starter at slot for lsu and now you're
taking belton that like felder said he
can play in the box he can kick out to
the slot he can find the football this
might be their tight end matchup player
in a division where there are plenty of
mismatched tight ends as well we know
what the philadelphia eagles have uh so
for me this is a this is a b minus i
agree with felder that the fact that you
know maybe veron mckinley is still on
the board different kinds of safeties
yes but belton absolutely has a very
defined role for wink martindale's
defense so we look at the giants room
right now they've been fired up at
what's going on with this giraffe so far
and how can you not be they're just
getting impact players all over the
place so a good start for joe shane that
new regime brian dable wink martindale
on the defensive side of the ball and
the giants uh now the broncos pick back
to back i'm curious if they're going to
trade one of these picks here they pick
at 115 they pick up 116. guys let's take
a look at what the broncos have done in
a short time i want to get a chance and
you see
quite an off season it's not just the
draft obviously traded a lot of picks
for russell wilson they gave a lot of
money to randy gregory they want to get
after the quarterback there's no doubt
about that they brought back melvin
gordon about uh this last week they even
got some insurance so when you look at
it right here the broncos very active in
felder the most competitive division of
football i'd say right now yeah it's a
good the division is really good and it
keeps getting better and as they add
pieces they're looking to obviously
they've shown up the quarterback spot
they've got it they've got an all-pro at
quarterback they've got a guy that can
get to the quarterback in randy gregory
oh we got it we got to pick in looks
like we got to pick in here we go the
broncos are selecting pick cornerback
damari mathis with the 115th pick her
source from schultz from jordan schultz
uh listen damari mathis is good and as
we run his tape right here the big thing
you're gonna see is the physicality and
that's something that comes from that
head coach pat and arduji a lot of folks
remember him from his time at michigan
state he's instilled that into this pit
football team uh you look at a guy
that's got a lot of that
stick-to-itiveness his ability to
plaster to wide receivers goes a long
way i love them in press coverage a lot
of corners rely on their speed too much
in press they don't get hands on mathis
is consistently getting hands-on and
press coverage and i'm sure tori hall
will tell you if you can get hands-on
impressed you can disrupt the timing of
the route and that's how you win in
press it's not just with your speed you
win by getting hands on and disrupting
the route so for me i'm gonna give this
a b plus i think that uh mathis is you
know i think he's got the skills to be a
starter at corner very soon i love him
on as an outside corner i don't want him
in the slot i want to make an outside
corner i want him body to bodied up on
people and i want him impressed so that
he uses those skills that they they
built in that mini no-fly zone in
pittsburgh yeah this is taking a dynamic
athlete at the position and trying to
mold him into you know tap into some of
that potential the 43 and a half inch
vertical is insane it's one of the best
athletes in the entire draft i want to
make that clear the athleticism is off
the charts i think the instincts in
finding the football are just not there
yet you see him here playing close to
the line of scrimmage mathis is somebody
that you want to use that physicality
like felder said you want him to play on
the boundary and you want him to drive
guys towards the sideline and make it
really difficult for them at the catch
point once again the awareness is still
coming on you see him come downhill the
ability to tackle an incredible athlete
i like some of the developmental corners
on the board a little better right now
yeah jalen armour david zion mccollum uh
tariq woolen is still out there as well
terry castro fields was somebody i was
higher on so i want to be fair here that
there are plenty of corners i liked
better i love the athleticism of mathis
i like that they're going to try to tap
into that potential i think he's a guy
that might need a redshirt year so i'm
going to go to c plus it's not really
about the player in mathis but more so
what else is left here on day three so
torrey holt uh this is one of the best
athletes at his position in the entire
draft we know denver loves adding to
this secondary what do you think
no doubt very explosive i had an
opportunity here's another acc kid that
had an opportunity to watch a lot this
year and he's a conference champion so
he brings a winning attitude to this
denver broncos uh roster which we all
know that they're trying to change they
brought over russell wilson who's
already changed the dynamics and the
thought process of this football team
there in denver and then you bring in
the guy like mathis again with winning
pedigree and nor nordusa we know what
type of players he likes physical
challenging players we saw him up in
press coverage and connor you're right i
would like to see his awareness be a lot
better on the perimeter particularly
when he's pressed up but you talking
about a kid that's going to compete he's
very very physical he's very explosive
with the vertical jump as we as you
mentioned and then the ball and then and
then the ability to come down and press
coverage and man up and you know you got
to do that in the national football
league there's going to be times where
you got to win your one-on-one match-up
i think mathis gives the pittsburgh
stillers a chance to do to be not
pittsburgh but demo broncos an
opportunity to do more press coverage i
like the skill sets of this guy i think
he'll bring some value to the denver
broncos i love it tori torrey knows a
lot about the acc obviously so great to
get insight on mathis going to denver
and the broncos back on the clock here
again pick 116 let's take a little break
here let's talk about felder's faves you
see him right there felder somebody was
watching and saw kobe bryant on there
and said yeah thank you let's talk about
the rest of the guys sitting on the
board yeah mckinley kohler tariq woolen
mccormick obinna z we got a lot of guys
left so we're going to see when these
guys come off but we've seen i'm i'm
really happy with the guys that have
come off the board already though
not off my board but just who've been
drafted so far i can't complain about
most of them the reality of it is i like
i like demario mathis i think he's a
really good corner as you mentioned
developmental but i like the energy that
he brings in press coverage because he's
someone that always wants to get
hands-on and i think that's important
when it comes to being disrupted being
able to play press
all right let's take a look at my big
board the best players available
felder's top fave jamari sawyer my top
player jamari sawyer you could tell i've
worked at felder for a couple months
specifically on the draft he is really
rubbed off on me i love jamari sawyer
darian canard a little bit of a surprise
there and you're going to see a theme of
the running backs isaiah spiller we saw
damian pierce come off the board i think
the most fascinating guy right here and
this is somebody i cannot wait to talk
about with tory holt is calvin austin
yeah it's just sure he's small he's a
track guy whatever sure there's just not
many guys that can run and move like
that and he's a good route runner so i'm
able to get off the line of scrimmage
not take many false steps it's get my
release get into my route get open and
if you give him any space to catch and
run with the ball
goodbye see you later so calvin austin
somebody that we got to be watching on
the board here as well today felder uh
what do you think of the top players on
the board right now i i mean i think
it's i mean the board's good obviously
we've gone through this over time and
time again i'm ready to get to some of
these picks because we got guys coming
up and uh listen we're they're they are
moving today they we are we are we are
pushing through as we get through
everything um look we've got uh what
have we got your zerky from iowa state
has been picked which is the bronco's
second pickup
which is awesome this is a guy that can
go out and make plays he's got the
ability playing in that that that
what he was it a two four two two four
five defense for for iowa state it's
very strange it's a strange defense it's
a unique defense but he's a guy that
essentially played anywhere from a zero
to a two a little bit of a three
technique but he was able to get the job
done i was able to shoot the gap go make
a play and i love his ability to create
space and use that space to create space
by alignment which draws eyeballs from
the center drives all by eyeballs from
the guard and then use that space
against them and create opportunities
for his linebackers to go make plays all
right so uma uwazarike going to the
denver broncos guy that uh reminds me of
chris warmly a little bit he's got that
length he can control blocks you expect
high floor against the run we'll see if
that pass rush green light comes on we
are going to take a little break here uh
felder and i can take a sip of some
water tory hulk can take a breather and
we're gonna remind you a little message
from our friends from rocket mortgage
this crazy suit can give me an edge oh
yeah huge edge
invisibility gives aaron donald an edge
on his game who hit me just like a
verified approval gives you an edge on
your offer i did when you need a
competitive edge in the housing game
rocket cam
all right so the broncos picking back to
back
interesting that they took traits-based
players back-to-back yes mathis
explosive corner um that i really love
you and tori hope pulling out let's
let's see more impressed that might be a
nice transition for the next level um
when you look at the next pick in the
uma uasarike somebody that has
incredible length over 35-inch arms yeah
and he uses that length use it to
control so
a 60 or senior a guy that's played a lot
of football at an iowa state program
for your starter and once again that
size of versatility kick them all along
the line of scrimmage is something we
like sure
all right so the new york jets are on
the clock the pick is in
and it sounds like the browns have made
a trade we'll see if they came up into
that new york jets picked the browns
were picking at 118 behind the jets
so they have made a a trade here for the
vikings pick yep
at 118. okay so i think we'll have that
jets pick
okay so the new york jets at 117 stay
put and take michael clemons from texas
a m okay so we will see if we are going
to break down that pick in depth or we
can keep things moving and see what's
going on with this trade i am good
either way uh do you feel passionately
enough to break down the michael
clements not particularly all right
let's keep this train moving gang let's
keep it moving um all right so the
cleveland browns
yeah let's talk about the vikings here
the vikings have moved all around the
giraffe today obviously with a new draft
in a new gm in quesadilla daffo mensah a
guy with a very interesting background
coming from cleveland very creative with
how they use pix not just analytics but
how they use draft capital to move all
around the board so i think when you
look at it for here
uh somebody that he's trying to get more
darts felder we saw them move back from
12 all the way to the end of the draft
and you've seen the draft here lewis
seen andrew blue juniors they're trying
to beef up that secondary you get some
help at guard and ingram and then brian
asamoah a money backer feller is there a
pick on this board that stands out to
you uh the brian essema because we
talked about him last night like this is
a guy that we see
he brings a lot of
energy to the football field and he he's
you let him run around and i think that
having a big nickel is going to help you
when you go to 12 personnel and teams
still try to run so i want to reiterate
that to folks that he's a linebacker
that is going to still be on the field
as a nickel type guy that
stops you from having to bring in a
smaller corner or a safety when teams go
to what should be a nickel package but
they still have large size pass catchers
in the game that guys that can actually
still block all right
so we got the vikings here uh they have
obviously moved up first for somebody as
we see this board coming up maybe
they're looking for a little tackle help
if they think darren canard can play
tackle that's going to be the question
mark if they want to double up at guard
and throw two darts and say ed ingram
darren kennard you're gonna we're gonna
figure this out we're gonna let you
compete the pick is in and it's a caleb
evans so they're looking at corner more
secondary again more secondary help this
is a team that need a lot of corner help
the vikings give a pick 156 and a future
fourth rounder to come up to 118. so
this is somebody that they obviously
feel strongly about i'm fascinated with
this team right now that they not the
lewis scene pick obviously get safety
help but now they have andrew booth who
we think is going to be a starter felder
a caleb evans in this spot is that the
same thought or are we going back to
damari mathis train of let's get a guy
in here with traits and develop him yeah
i think it's traits and development he's
someone that i mean look i love the fact
that he's got some good recovery speed i
think he placed through the whistle
which i think is important on that play
right there you got to see it he was
beat he was stacked bad throw and then
obviously he's still able to rip the
football out which i think goes a long
way so that trait for me is one of his
lead traits is relentlessness i'm going
to give it a b minus because again i
think there are maybe some other guys
out there that i like a little bit more
headlined by tariq woolen but i think
the big thing with evans is he he did do
it against
elite competition in the sec there's
also the idea that he was able to go out
and make plays this is a guy that he
still has to improve impress if he wants
to play press he's going to have to
improve because he's going to be he's
one of the guys that has to work on
getting hands on if he's going to play
off he's got to work on having patient
feet and getting collisioning the
receiver so that he can collision to
carry that's what he's going to have to
work on so that's going to be an
interesting element to his game uh in
zone i think he is a he's an oh he's an
adequate tackler would love for him to
be more of a sure tackler but that's the
key for me when i watch evans yeah side
speed corner we know he's got length
he's got 32 inch arms he's six foot two
a transfer from tulsa like felder said
got to get a beef up in competition
playing at missouri the four four six
forty thirty six inch vertical uh so
you're betting on traits and measurables
my only question here guys i'm excited
to go to torrey holt in just a moment
missed games in 2018 miss games in 2019
missed games in 2021 so i think with the
caleb evans
some of that lack of development might
be the problem the lack of being on the
field so tori holt what are you seeing
at caleb evans
you know i'm with you connor on the you
know a lot of missed games
so what is minnesota saying here okay we
can bring in a guy who's six 297 pounds
length a guy that can develop we can
develop but a guy that can help us on
special teams too minnesota vikings can
use help on special teams and they're
limped on the perimeter when you think
about what green bay packers are doing
uh with kristen watson six-four kid that
they just drafted you look at the bears
you look at the lions and what they're
doing out on the perimeter you're going
to need corners with some lymph that can
cover but you're also going to need some
young players that can play on special
teams and give you tremendous value
there and i think akila evans can do
that great call tori somebody that can
probably be using kick coverage punt
gunner yeah with that kind of thing yeah
absolutely a gunner a gunner and a
jammer has the ability to do those
things which means you can put them on
your four course uh at least on three of
the four cores because i don't think
he's gonna be a return man so absolutely
how that how he fits is gonna be
interesting
and back to tori's point caleb evans
not a ton of punt coverage experience
while tulsa goes to missouri pretty good
amount of snaps he had 15 snaps of punt
coverage uh a ton of snaps covering
kicks so i think that's the train of
thought
let them play on special teams develop
them as a corner and we see the draft
recap here the giant's getting more
secondary help in dean belton bronco is
going back to back with
athleticism more traits based players
the new york jets taking michael clemons
the big edge from texas a m and then we
had a caleb evans just come off the
board a pick that we broke down
all right let's take a little break here
and we still see
sam howell is on the board so
pretty shocking here guys i mean we're
no disrespect to the guys that went off
the board who we all like but i didn't
know we'd be in a world where we're
saying where do we see him where do we
see sam howell right now looking at
looking at what we've got coming up
where do we see him
washington to play behind carson wentz
would be what i think makes the most
sense carson wentz is a guy that has
been hurt a lot
and he goes through spells of not taking
care of the football now i'm not saying
sam howell's gonna come in and be a
savior for carson wentz but you don't
you always need a fianna fell you need a
number two quarterback i want to go to
tory holt here and go
tory the the importance of having
a dude that people see has physical
ability at the number two quarterback
position rather than just a guy how
important is that to somebody like you
that's the top dog in that wide receiver
room
yeah it's critical i mean once the if
the starter goes out you want to be able
to pick up where you left off as best
you can
and i think
with the talent of a guy like sam howe
who
can throw the football with the best of
them any of the quarterbacks is in this
draft class
but with sam obviously i think what's
made him drop is things got to speed up
a little quicker for sam howell but in
terms of arm talent and physical i mean
inability to compete
he possesses all of that but you want
that second tier quarterback to come in
and just continue to right the ship
don't make mistakes be efficient with
the football get the ball in the
playmaker's hands run the offense
efficiently um and keep them in
favorable downs and that will be sam
howell's
responsibility because he will be a
second screen quarterback he will not be
a first first tier guy he would be a
second tier quarterback but i think he
has the arm talent i think he has up
here i think the mental part of the
toughness i think is there he's just
going to need more development going
forward i'm with you all the way playing
in structure is what i look for in sam
howell not everything needs to be uh you
know break down get out of the pocket
running he's that got the athleticism do
it so baltimore ravens made a pick while
we were talking about sam howell and
this is one of the corners that i've
been complaining about guys going ahead
of him if you're looking to develop a
guy jalen armour davis from alabama
you've heard a theme on this show so far
of a lot of size speed corners that's
exactly what he is and as you see we got
a trade coming in here
washington moving out things are flying
the panthers came up for brandon smith
let's focus on jaylen armor davis i
don't want to get away from this pick
too fast 6-1 197 sub 4-4 wheels you're
talking about a corner that can turn and
run recovery speed even when beat
vertically one year starter still
putting it all together is the first
thing former big time recruit yes big
time expectations you gotta wait at
alabama not a place that you always get
to come in and just play
i wrote every aspect of his game is
still raw awareness playing the football
patience and coverage one-year starter a
guy that good front seven that can get
after the quarterback so when you look
at him once again you're looking at
speed you're looking for him to start to
find the football a little more but it's
all there and i think it's all there for
anything you want to do i would like to
actually see him be a man cover corner
because of the raw talent and the raw
wheels that he has so for jalen armour
davis the ravens keep playing the value
game one of my top corners on the board
i do think he has a long ways to go but
this is a team that has had corner depth
i know he's tested last year a lot of
injuries you have someone like marlon
humphrey there that's going to be
willing to take in armor davis and say
we come from the same program now you're
coming into my scheme follow my lead and
that's going to be great for him so i
give this one a b-plus i like this one
here here's the thing i don't care if he
plays man or zone yeah because watching
a lot of those clips he's playing zone
coverage and his ability to kind of sink
off or slip off and make obviously the
interception there when he's playing in
that cloud in that cloud position
watching his ability to uh reroute guys
if he isn't man i love that about him or
when he's in cover two to reroute and
get guys up the field he's got to play
by his rules all the time but certainly
higher sealing than his teammate josh
job right so that's the big key when you
watch him play right here he's lined up
over a bigger body slow patient but he's
still able to go there and uh look
awareness with the football he's had he
denies one route and then he could look
back and take the ball away there making
the tackle there he's
willing to stick his nose in and i think
that's important his his willingness to
be a player here you're going to see
here take on a block get off the block
go make a tackle he's doing multiple
things in a play that are going to make
him successful player at the next level
he can play man he can play his own i
love him in zone coverage i think he's
just got this length in this um kind of
this cat-like ability to kind of slink
around and keep eyes on the quarterback
and i kind of want his eyes on the
quarterback i'm going to go with an a
minus pick here because i still think
that someone like a turk woolen may be a
better player because of the length they
have uh not quite similar length
woolen's a little bit longer but i think
they've got a similar style and so i
think that that gives it an a minus ring
but the ravens in alabama
they feel like a secretary
yep no doubt about that a player that is
a prospect reminded me of eli apple
coming out yes you know long a little
slender like you said felder just finds
his way around so torrey holt uh one of
the
maybe a raw coin one year starter at
corner but there were big expectations
for this guy and his best ball might be
ahead of him what do you see
no doubt i agree and
down in the dc and baltimore area
these two organizations loves players
from alabama you look at washington look
at washington's lineup defensively all
alabama players you look at the
baltimore ravens and they love their
alabama players but i like
i like this kid um
because of his as you guys have
mentioned he's 6-1 he's a four-four
speed guy he can run and when you look
at the baltimore ravens secondary peters
and and uh and those guys in humphreys
they were hurt last year uh at times and
now you bring in cal hamilton who's
who's oh my goodness uh a a tremendous
talent at the safety position who brings
you size as well an ability to move and
cover ground and then you couple it with
with the kid uh
the kid uh uh davis there from um from
alabama
there's more size and more length more
length to this baltimore ravers defense
particularly in the secondary and you
have to be able to cover and then
playing in the afc north you have to be
able to tackle that's exactly right you
absolutely have to be able to tackle and
that's something i think he's willing to
do so you see the draft recap michael
clemons big edge from texas a m going to
the jets caleb evans we broke him down
jaylen armand davis we've had two picks
come off the board brandon smith one of
the best athletes in this draft no shock
anybody that comes out of penn state
that's usually the name of the game and
then we also had jack jones coming off
the board this uh you know once upon a
time especially when jack jones was a
recruit somebody i thought that would be
drafted in this position or even earlier
i was a little lower on him in this
draft has had an interesting college
road uh but absolutely developed after
leaving usc for arizona state well i
think that's the key the development
after leaving usc for jack jones he got
to usc and he came in as a big-time
recruit he's a big name i remember
following him on the recruiting trail
and he was one of those guys they were
this was going to be part of the class
that usc would be back with this class
and they got there and those guys all in
one way shape or form sort of dissipated
and he ended up at arizona state which
for all the issues that they have off
the field with respect to the ncaa on
the field they have developed quality
ball players and he is one of them this
is someone that understands how to read
his keys plays his rules and he's not
afraid to be physical at the cornerback
spot i love that about him so watching
him play has been real has really been a
treat
without a doubt felder uh it's been a
it's once again it's been a long road
for jack jones but i think he definitely
figured it out at arizona state and
let's talk a little brandon smith here
obviously for me
one of the not for me for everybody one
of the most athletic linebackers in the
entire draft it felt like he never truly
got comfortable at the position at penn
state finding the football using that
athleticism remind me a little bit of
baron browning at ohio state where you
always saw the speed you always saw the
athlete if you kept things simple for
him it looked great being a true
linebacker in the middle field reading
his keys diagnosing things down field
was not always there maybe looking for
more of a coverage backer here that you
could develop yeah i think he had he's
the kind of the reverse of michael
parson in multiple ways right parser's a
guy that came out as a defensive end who
people thought was would have a hard
time transitioning to playing in the
middle of the field he did it no problem
uh for brandon smith he's a guy that
some folks are like he's probably going
to be kind of a big nickel guy and then
ultimately they line him up you see him
there he's lined up wide and he can do
that he can play lined up wide read
react go make a tackle there you go so
that's the big thing they think i think
folks viewed him sort of in that isaiah
simmons role the problem is when you
come down into the box is where he
struggled to find out where he's
supposed to fit and making fits is you
know the job of the linebacker that's
the main part of it so for me with
brandon smith i'm still gonna give it a
b because i do think that he has the
ability to go out there and be a
contributor i think he is uh we talked
about it with asamoah i think he could
fit into that type of role if you give
him that type of role he's going to be
successful yeah i'm with you there a
couple linebackers i like better just
because they are a little bit more pro
ready but you can draft athletes at this
point play them on special teams a 997
relative athletic score something we
talked about last night that
weight in terms of how he can run and
how explosive he is and he's got almost
35-inch arms i do wonder if they even
try to give him a little bit of a look
as a pass rusher as well so brandon
smith obviously an interesting player
and i believe we do have a pick here and
this is an exciting one
zamir white yeah going to the raiders
here a power back that been at georgia
for a long time overcome a lot two acl
tears while there and guess what guys
he's healthy because he ran a 4-4 214
pounds north south running for zamir
white tough running contact balance he's
absolutely got that we know the raiders
are looking to develop a stable of backs
hiring josh mcdaniels that's something
they do at new england this is your
between the tackles power guy behind
hopefully an offensive line that can
bully people a little bit you got a lot
of attention on the outside you got
devonte adams you got darren waller when
you move him outside you got hunter
renfro so samir white not just a change
in pace guy to me but a tackle breaker
that can move the chains one of my
better players available at the running
pack position on the board today i'll
give this a b plus felder it's never
been talent with samir white just about
staying healthy yeah it's about staying
healthy uh for me when i look at him i
see a guy that can get the job done i
want i love him with the lead blocker
i'm gonna give it a b plus as well i
love him with a lead blocker listen this
is a guy from north carolina another one
of the north carolina guys that ends up
at at georgia same thing with todd
gurley uh
same thing so he can he can get the job
done he is so talented as long as he's
healthy he's going to go out there and
make plays he's a great downhill runner
i want him with a lead blocker i want
him with guards pulling in front of him
give him the ball deep so he has a
chance to diagnose and go make plays
yeah a little bit of a throwback comp
for me ryan grant former packers running
back then when you get him rolling down
the tracks he's got the speed he's got
the big body type to take on contact
samir white big time recruit tory big
time expectations at georgia and it was
great to see him go out on a high note
this year national championship and
their leading rusher
absolutely and michael's right you know
he's another north carolina kid that i
had to see
leave the state to go play football
somewhere else but a uh but he was he
was a top 10 national recruitment coming
out of high school this guy can play and
as connor connor as you mentioned health
is going to be a key for him going
forward but he played at jordy played
the best football in one of the better
conferences in all of football so
competition he will not shy away from
and then two
he has jacobs somebody that he can learn
from and i thought this was interesting
with the with the raiders you know they
didn't pick up i don't think they picked
up jacob's option i'm not saying that
they won't resign him back
but this certainly gives them some some
cushion gives them some depth bringing
in samir white who's played in a very
talented competitive conference been in
the sec and he is a national champion so
he can carry the load he understands
what it takes to compete if he stays
healthy he's powerful he's got good
speed got a good base this is a good
pick for las vegas raiders team that's
added devonte adams and other talent on
the defensive side of all this well
inside the ball the raiders are saying
look we can we're going to be able to
throw it and we're also going to be able
to run it with two legit backs tori
here's a follow-up for you here uh
obviously josh mcdaniels finally leaving
new england for the second time we know
new england is a franchise that likes to
draft and sign championship pedigree
kind of players do you think that trend
now follows over to vegas with josh
mcdaniels in the drafting of zamir white
yeah absolutely absolutely i mean we
what's what's better to give your
quarterback stability than having a
legitimate run game and not only that
and not only that i think zamil white as
well as x these guys can stand up and on
third downs and protect derek carr and
give him the ability give him a little
bit more time to look for devante adams
hunter winfrey waller as you mentioned
the talent on the perimeter but these
guys can service these are three down
backs really good bags downhill guys but
they can catch out the backfield they
got some wiggle but they're stout on
third downs as well permanent team
captain of the championship georgia
bulldogs samir white got to love that
pick it does mean a lot i am with you
all right draft recap we are flying here
today we did the zamir white pick and we
are not skipping the next one it is
isaiah spiller off the board here to the
chargers and man this is one of the
better players on the board here today
obviously we're seeing the run on
running backs we saw damien pierce go
now we see isaiah spiller here guys this
is a fun one for a team that kind of
needed this dynamic at this position
when you look at spiller somebody that
good feel as a runner good feet you see
the ability to change direction he has a
lot of experience as an inside runner he
really reminds me as a really inside
zone runner i saw the patience and the
change of direction not in the past game
or past protection but purely as a
runner some le'veon bell to isaiah
spiller's game that upright running
style the choppy feet behind the line of
scrimmage i can make you miss when
traffic is in the backfield and then i
can get outside wide shake a defender or
run through a defender i'm a big fan of
isiah spiller i didn't think he'd be
still be here guys we know austin eckler
what he does in the pass game for the
chargers sure with that type of body
type somebody that can get beat up a lot
isaiah spiller that big frame can carry
the load so for me uh this is an a here
i love the value i love the player and i
like seeing him in this chargers offense
well i i i love isaiah spiller this dude
i was talking to mark dominic the former
tampa bay bucks gm and he said that he
thought isaiah supposed to be the first
running back off the board and
probably would go in the second round so
i got to give this an a plus if we're
talking about the fourth round you get a
guy that some people thought might be a
second round maybe a third early third
round guy he is shifty we talked about
fit right we talked about the kid from
lsu getting picked to go to a zone
scheme
and he's a power runner that needs a
lead blocker spiller is a zone runner
and he's really good at zone runs he's
really good at pressing the hole and
then finding a way to create space i
love what he's able to do there you see
here we're watching him run in zone and
then explode see the crease hit the
crease and go he forces people to over
commit and then he can cut back he does
all those little things again zone run
don't worry give him a little fake
inside and then explode outside and get
up the field for a big game he does that
really well i love the way that he
presses the hole here with the lead he
can still do it with lead he can do a
little bit of both but i love him in his
own scheme he wants to run it inside but
he will get outside wide and use a
little bit of that speed that he brings
to the table yeah one of my favorite
notes on the scouting report wrote form
excellent navigating a line of scrimmage
traffic displays physicality when he
gets the second level of the field elder
i'm with you that patientness behind the
line of scrimmage and knowing where to
be and the feel as a runner tori hall
when you see isaiah spiller
two years of really really high end tape
big expectations great to see him come
off the board here to an explosive
offense no doubt very explosive offense
and justin herbert has got to be saying
thank you i got austin eckler who's a
change of pace back right who can catch
the ball out of the backfield austin
eckler also can run between the tackles
and off tackle
he's really dynamic and then you bring
in isaiah spiller now he's a four six
guy so he's not going to run away from
anybody but what it reads here what i
when i'm looking at the overview of
isaiah spiller it says a volume carry
running back with good size and talent
and can be consistent as a pro and
that's exactly what the la chargers need
they need a solid run game you got
justin herbert who can who can throw the
football you got keenan island those
guys that can get over mike williams i
like this pick of isaiah's spelling
gives them
the their charges are a little more
thicker now they're a little more
tougher now they're more broader at the
running back position when you add in
isaiah spaler i love it tori i'm with
you all the way the charters are
must watch on sundays this year
especially with the young talent they
have let's take a reset here look at the
big board some of the big names have
come off the board and that pushes a
couple guys up kyron williams in there
at 93. you're looking for a third down
guy pass protect catch the football
that's the guy we've talked about
ferguson we've talked about calvin
austin another runner tough north south
runner tyler algiere sitting there
charlie kohler pass catching tight end
productive for a long time at ohio at
iowa state uh malcolm rodriguez i know a
guy i'm a little higher on but tackling
machine i like him yeah tackling machine
that can get downhill yeah felder talk
about malcolm rodriguez a little bit
yeah this is a guy that moves side to
side really well i wouldn't call him a
true chase linebacker because he's not
afraid to bang in the interior i agree
but i do like the fact that he can run
you down he's not afraid though to play
inside he he is absolutely
listen he played for a defense that was
completely revamped this year and a team
that played a lot of cover zero a team
that played a lot of cover one and a
team that asked him to be ready to peel
which he was able to do but also add
yourself to the to the run to not just
to the run fits but to the pass mix and
he was able to do that as well rodriguez
is a good player high quality
high iq guy recognizes the scheme and he
helped other guys get set up
all right felder do i have to ask are we
going to break down the kicker pick of
the draft that is kade york from lsu
coming off the board i literally was um
i literally
was looking at game when gabe was
getting ready to come shoot i was like
we're not doing this pick are we are we
doing the kicker is that what we're
doing no uh my faves we still got a lot
of my phase on the board so we'll see if
these guys get picked here as we click
as we we're past the halfway point of
the fourth round as we get closer to the
all everyone's favorite compensatory
picks that come a little bit later but
no we've got the what do we got the
dolphins on the on the clock right now
yeah we do we are up to the dolphins the
brown city of york i'll give them uh
a little something here kate york the
reason he was drafted this high
long of 56 yards last year long of 57
yards the year before big light kicker
i am not a believer of drafting kickers
in the fourth round uh they have to be
really special to go in the fifth or
sixth i don't think he's that i'm sorry
so we'll see where it goes
i don't know enough about kickers
it's not really in the job description
but you do know enough about some of
these guys behind us rowan mckinley is a
name that i know you're really excited
about an instinctual player on the
backhand i i think it out of all the dbs
that have come off the board it's
probably about veron mckinley's time i
blame for him he i like him a lot
obviously we've got another trade coming
up the raiders seem to have traded their
pick 126. but we got the texas tech wide
receiver off the board as well for to
the dollar con yeah love him yeah he's a
good football player we're doing that
one just let everybody know i will not
allow us not to uh that's an excellent
trade to come up yet and get izu kanma
you know man really the
the bargain shopping
jump ball guy in the class and it's not
his fault and i'll save it for when we
roll the tape for izukanma um but this
is obviously one i'm really excited
about you said the raiders came back up
to get him so that is now the dolphins
the dolphins got he's running right now
the raiders have now moved out of their
pick
i don't know now i don't know what's
happening the raiders raiders vikings
the vikings have traded 126.
the raiders have traded
165 169.
so izukana went to the dolphins at 125.
let's break down that pick guys uh a
jump ball target did not get a lot of
help this year at texas tech and for a
dolphins team we know everything they
traded for tyree kill we're well aware
of that uh you know when you look at
that they have jaylen waddle but
we understand what those guys are their
speed shiftiness they can take the top
off the defense they can play underneath
with izukana you're looking at a jump
ball target that once again did not get
a lot of help at texas tech and can play
above the rim can get vertical and kind
of like drake london he doesn't have to
run a 4-3 but he can create enough space
to go find the football so what did you
see with izukana yeah i love the way
that he plays he can work underneath
which i found to be remarkable for a guy
that we are used to seeing make those
jump ball plays but i also love the way
that he's able to work uh in the
intermediate especially towards the
interior of the field he can do all
those things he's not afraid to kind of
sacrifice his body to make the catch
which i think goes a long way as a
football player that puts more trust
more faith in you from the quarterback
standpoint so when you watch him play he
does all those little things that you
definitely need all right i love it and
i compared him to devante parker there
we go yeah devonte parker obviously long
time miami dolphins yeah you know what
you're getting dolphins fans in izukana
i know there was highs and lows of
parker but he was somebody that went up
and made a lot of plays when he was
healthy he was good i totally agree
all right so the next uh we saw the
raiders trade up into
this election and we're seeing neil
ferrell come off the board as the
defensive line starts to evaporate in
this class talked about perry on winfrey
earlier in the day a bit of a gap
shooter as felder said a a one gapping
kind of player that can rush the passer
gail farrell i would say the opposite
here fell they're a guy that can two gap
a big body player take on blockers stuff
the middle of the defense stop the run
and really just control everything at
the line of scrimmage what do you think
of neil pharr yeah he's a big boy and i
think this is the right spot for him to
go
he is
large and in charge if you will right
this is someone that when i watch him
play he does have the ability to occupy
too and he'll do it willingly so
watching the way that he's able to when
he puts the pause on you as a if you're
an offensive lineman you're not going to
run away from them you're not going to
get anywhere you're not going to be able
to reach that second level which is what
they want which is why they're picking
him here let's keep our linebackers
clean let's keep our linebackers open so
they can go and make plays that's right
uh jonathan hankins was who i came up
nice yes just somebody that he can eat
space he can two gap he could see
everything in front of him and not get
moved off the line of scrimmage the most
important thing so you're seeing a lot
of players with player comparisons to uh
players that were on that team and now
they're trying to replenish that type of
player to the team so we're gonna see
neil farrell here and there it is right
there in the middle of the defense he
can play nose shade nose uh he can play
three tech but i like him right in the
middle there felder that run stuffer
control the guard control the center
redirect the running back to a different
lane is what you want him to do and then
you see the high end effort play breaks
down go get the quarterback and that's
good speed for a guy that carries a lot
of weight i think he's somebody that'll
probably play around 330 335 stacking
[ __ ] get the blocker off of you make a
play in the backfield keep that motor
running hot to rush the passer so neil
farrell uh a good value pick here
there's not a lot of guys in this class
on day three that can control this much
space of the line of scrimmage so you
had to get him early and that's why you
saw the trade here so neil farrell 128th
player on the board i like this rock
solid for the middle of the defense
probably rotational early down player
this is a b for me for farrell yeah and
for me i love him too i think he's a
really good football player i think he
brings a lot to the table and has the
ability to go out and make a big make
big plays he's someone that i'd give
probably a b plus he's a guy that goes
out and makes plays like he shows up and
is able uh the effort is what stands out
to me the effort in the way that he
carries his weight and we're i know
we're all enamored by the two guys that
weighed 330 340 pounds that ran sub five
but he ran a 5-4-1 and you see the burst
that he brings to the table when he's
actually on the field so i think he's
probably plays faster than that 40 time
and he gives you effort consistently and
i think that's why he's going to be able
to be on the field a little more often
than some people expect all right
all right keep in mind the patriots i
believe have finally uh made a pick a
draft edition and now one i really like
here pierre strong small school running
back uh you see their draft call
strangely athletic he's gonna kick
inside to center at the next level tycon
thornton the burner marcus jones slot
corner dynamic returner and now pierre
strong so you're seeing a theme of this
new england draft guys speed that's what
it is cole strange one of the most
athletic centers to ever test now the
guy running behind him in pierre strong
jr somebody that
really has been super productive for
multiple years reminds me of joseph and
dye he's got the vision he's got the
burst to get outside he's got the four
three wheels he can cut he can make you
miss and he can get down the field in a
hurry for the breakaway speed and i
think that he can do it at the next
level and he's somebody that might they
can get creative with we've seen them
use james white in the passing game in
the past he's somebody that you can use
on the wheel route so you can get them
working in the middle of the field texas
routes so pierre strong a small school
player but that four three seven forty
on the track and indy shows hey i can
run away from nfl defenders i'm not just
running away from small school guys so
you're seeing it with new england
they've gone small school a couple times
in the strap but more importantly
they've valued high-end athleticism so
strong one of my favorite day three
running backs player 129 the value
checks out for here uh for me this is
the first pick from the patriots that
i'm really really high on i would go
with an a minus here for them uh phil
they're going to get to you in a second
on strong throw to torrey holt torrey
holt you gotta love adding wheels to the
offense
yes i think this brings speed to speed
to this new new england patriots offense
you mentioned 437 speed but i like the
production too it was a thousand yard
running back in 2019 it was a thousand
years it was 1694 yards and 20 21
7.1 yards a carry had 18 touchdowns so
he has a nose for the end zone had 22
receptions
for 151 yards so he can catch the ball
out of the backfield so you'll see new
england do different things with him as
they typically do with their running
backs they ask a lot of those guys and i
think they'll do the same thing with
pierre strong jr and i think he has the
ford the mental fortitude and the
physical capability to handle some of
the load that he'll be asked to do like
this pick like the versatility that he
provides to this new england pages
offense all right i like it as well
they're just getting speed at every
position possible felder fear strong
what do you think i like he reminds me
you said joseph he reminds me of travis
atn um
it's a lot less of a juke and a lot more
of a weave with what he does
and it's the speed it's the speed to the
weave it's not this hard one cut and go
it's this weaving style
that gets into the end zone i go with
the b plus here for him and the big key
for me is his ability to weave his
ability to catch the ball in the
backfield but i still don't know what he
is in pass pro and that's going to be
that's going to be a big question mark
with the pats because you can't play you
can't play if you can't protect the
quarterback which also leads me back to
my travis at com comparison because
travis it couldn't block either
oh man felder all over it it's going to
be very curious to see and new england
has no problem taking a running back and
saying you'll we'll see in 2023. yeah
enjoy learning in our running back room
so
moving on the baltimore ravens continue
their trend of us loving every single
pick they take charlie kohler they got
mark andrews
this is a guy that played a similar role
in college a pass catcher he could run
the scene he could do a lot of different
things as a pass catcher he was a long
time player there
kohler man he's somebody that my 80th
overall player so i think he fell too
far tyler higbee is who i see in kohler
nice not a lot of six foot six guys can
run and catch in that way is he an elite
blocker no can he get you by yeah six
foot six and a half 252 pounds six nine
eight three cone shows that change of
direction at that size that's rare i
want to emphasize that and that plays in
his route running the ability to win in
the short area the ability to win in the
intermediate era big fan of this pick
and you're going to see a little kohler
buzz here felder take it away yeah i
love this guy he's on my faves list and
look at look at him fight through guys
all over him doesn't matter
concentration make the catch i can get
the job i'm here again guys on him i can
make the catch he always believes that
he's got the opportunity to make the
catch gets his hands right all the time
makes the catches away from his body
makes the catches with his hands
consistently he look boom there we go
right in the back of the end zone he can
sneak out he can block in line a little
bit he's not the best blocker in line
but he can block in line a little bit
i'm gonna go with an a-plus this is a
guy he's one of my favorite titans out
of this group i love his ability to
help you stretch the field his ability
to work in the intermediate and occupy
people because this is a guy whether you
run him on a spacing route or you run
him on a sort of a little a dig he has
the ability to create space to occupy
that vision of the safety and then guess
what you get when that safety's busy
looking at charlie kohler now we get
something behind him and i think that's
the key this is an a plus pick for the
ravens especially you talking about
putting him with mark andrews now we've
got a real problem there yeah i'm with
you as well this is an a plus for me
there's no doubt about that when you
just look at the catch radius 34 and a
half inch arms he plays to it some guys
have long arms and they kind of
alligator on things so kohler
everything's super wide uh he sees the
ball really well tracks the ball really
well and as felder said he knows how to
run so big hands you saw the one-handed
catch he's very physical at the catch
point can be a seam monster and for the
ravens offense we saw them trade
hollywood brown night one and everybody
kind of goes what are they gonna do
their roots are 12 personnel
sometimes 22 personnel they'll throw a
big fullback back out there two tight
ends run north to south make life a
little easier on lamar jackson i think
this is a really nice pick if you want
to pair them with mark andrews that's a
problem for linebackers trying to cover
oh yeah
all right let's take a little break to
thank our friends at rocket mortgage our
draft coverage is brought to you by
rocket mortgage if you're looking for an
edge in the home buying market then
you've got to go with rocket mortgage
their verified approval can help you
compete in a crowded market and give you
the edge you need
you like that feller i like dude that
was smooth that's the it's a girl that's
the uh that's the goal here all right
let's keep this moving we got picks
rolling in the dallas cowboys are on the
clock i heard the cowboys room on the
bleach report app was flying last night
dallas fans they are very passionate
about the jones family and will mcclay's
draft picks year after year so very
curious to see where they go here guys
when we get a chance let's take a look
at what dallas has done in the draft it
was very great to see them at a wide
receiver and jalen tolbert last night i
thought that was one of the value picks
of the draft
and they got offensive line help as you
see the last couple picks come in here
and they are going with jake ferguson so
the tight end run continues yeah and
felder another trend continues because
my comparison for jake ferguson dalton
schultz so dallas gets another version
of dalton schultz the guy they're paying
franchise tag money this to me makes a
lot of sense when you look at dalton
schultz if you decide not to extend him
long term and you like what you saw year
one from jake ferguson you said you know
what we got a guy on a rookie contract
as well uh this is a great pick for us
to break down here guys and let's get
into it jake ferguson to dallas dalton
schultz 2.0 one number that stands out
for me hands went from good to great he
caught at least 30 passes all four
seasons michael felder productive but
guess what that's not where it was fun
watching him it's fun watching him in
the trenches as a blocker move people
off the line of scrimmage get him moving
out wide to take on safeties coming
downhill even outside linebackers coming
downhill ferguson extremely reliable
hands uh he has build up speed if you
want to run him down the seam he is a
three down player at the tight end
position in the sense that you could
play him in line you could play him off
the line i think you could get them
working in the backfield this is great
insurance for dalton schultz this is an
a plus pick a top 100 player on my big
board i love him i i didn't think there
was a huge gap between rucker and
ferguson i agree and rucker for me felt
like a guy that's
top of the second round ferguson felt
like a middle of the second round and
now you're getting them here that's
great value it's an a plus for me as
well i think the big key for me with
ferguson is
under undervalued athleticism this guy
always found a way to get open he
understands route running really well
he's a quarterback's best friend they're
going to absolutely dax uh dax dak is
absolutely going to love this guy and
he's going to be someone that
consistently is open consistently
catches the football that's the big key
right he's not going to be someone
that's open and then he can't catch he's
going to be someone that's open catches
the football makes a play and then moves
on from there he can block in line he
will move bodies for you whether you
line him up as an inline tight end as a
wing or you move him into the backfield
you motion him across to help in
overload to create push at the goal line
he's going to make sure you get into the
end zone all right tori holt the tight
end run continues here how are we
feeling for dallas as they get a little
dalton schultz insurance
no you know baltimore added kohler so
they they're obviously going to keep
stay with their 12-13 uh personnel and
then you look at the cowboys add jake
ferguson as um and and which they will
uh try to get back to establishing more
of a run game with ezekiel elliott and
the way that you do that is add some
more tight ends if you can't add office
alignment then you add some tight ends
that are good in-line blockers but also
can give you some value in the passing
game so look for the type look for the
dallas cowboys and say look we'll go
with schultz and ferguson we'll go
double tikes and we'll put both of those
guys down the seams and we'll put both
of those guys on some corner outs or
we'll use them in the red zone try to
stop that package because both of these
guys can get open and they can catch and
they're pretty solid particularly
ferguson in-line blocking which gives
you some stoutness in the red zone let's
get ezekiel elliott back going and the
way to do that is add more alignment and
add some tight ends guys that can move
the line of scrimmage i love it tori i'm
absolutely with you on that one let's
take a look at what dallas has done in
the draft so far you see the board right
there they get some offensive line
helping the bully tyler smith pass rush
helping sam williams and then they're
looking at the pass catchers jalen
tolbert goes last night i think he's got
number two wide receiver upside they
obviously traded mari cooper they're
looking for some help for cd lamb and
michael gallup and now you get jake
ferguson two tight end sets baby listen
the cowboys pick where's where's the
next cowboys pick at least right now
they don't pick until
they figure out wait a full round yeah
yeah so but vero mckinley may still be
five
155 they need a safety i think there's a
chance felder i think they're they need
a safety mckinley could still be there
that's going to be interesting because
if they don't get a safety what do they
do
they could still keep taking swings at
offensive line it's a unit that's been
hurt it's been getting a little shallow
over the years i know they took tyler
smith sure um but that's another crack
they can take but
i'm with you feller and i'll say this
the the punt god is still on the board
as well matter isis said do not sleep on
the punk but another punter's already
come off the board i hear jordan stout
how does that how does how how does that
happen that seems a little insane to me
um if you're gonna take a punter in the
fourth round
would you not take the punter that was
the punk god yeah the all-world punt god
matt matarisa
i'm a little shocked by this one now as
much as i am not the biggest stack the
board with specialists they were both on
my top 300 players but you're talking
about almost a hundred player difference
right stop being a guy i expected to be
and we have punter
oh so do we have punter b-roll of that
we do that is insane i don't expect that
so let's get into stout a little bit
here
felder for me
it's got to be something mechanical
related that's what a lot of teams look
at it could be hang time sure it could
be and you're seeing it come in nicole
auerbach says right there wow jordan
stout ahead of matt ariza i'll say this
maybe the concern is that coffin corner
pinning the touchbacks rather than leg
strength sure
i think we could keep it rolling yeah we
could key let's go what's next
all right moving on let's keep
here we go the we got yeah the ravens
room are they jumping off right now
the ravens room jumping i mean they've
had a draft where they could have taken
a long snapper and everybody would have
been like cool very true we already got
four first-round players we do not care
all right
man so now i believe and i'm trying to
catch up to speed here we have the
tennessee titans on the clock if i am
wrong guys you can correct me in my ear
i will not be offended i believe the
titans are on the clock we saw them get
malik willis last night i actually want
to kick things back to torrey hull here
in a minute ryan tannehill in place and
with that money we know that's not
changing anywhere
um obviously with the titans
malik willis in waiting in the wings now
it's gonna be interesting to see that
dynamic a guy that has a little bit more
traits than ryan tannehill but needs
seasoning what do you think of that
felder just is there any pressure there
that if things start to falter with
tannehill i'm not saying week one i'm
saying maybe by the end of the year you
start to look at the guy sitting on the
bench you go we know he needs time but
he's more explosive of a playmaker i
think you you wait as long as you can
uh that's the goal and obviously that
also boils down to
in
the problem connors these decisions
don't get made in a vacuum no that's
that's the biggest issue if it was up to
them they're like listen okay we're
gonna we might lose a game or we might
win this game closer than we wanted to
win it by but
if we put the new guy in maybe it'll
work but the reality of it is it's not
made in a vacuum because you've got fans
calling into sports radio you got people
you got news media asking questions when
are we going to see them when are we
going to see them when are we going to
see them so that's the part where
you just hope that things with tane hill
keep going well so that you can wait it
out like that's the ultimate goal is
just waiting it out because if you get
forced into forcing the plane him before
he's ready you can really ruin things
before you before it even gets started
and that's the big issue for me i do see
our guy romeo dubs is off the board to
the green bay packers as well yeah so
we're going to get to dubs in a second
the titans have made their pick at 131
it is hassan haskins felder this is a
team that they love their downhill
physical running backs we know what they
have in derek henry do we know who they
signed when derek henry got hurt uh
hassan haskins here from michigan a
downhill north south runner tackle
breaker yeah he's good this guy's really
good obviously
um we'll see what happens when he's
playing against a team teams that have a
bunch of guys like georgia
but the reality of it is is with the
hassan haskins we are dealing with the
guy that was pretty dominant over the
course of the season in the big ten
showed that he could get downhill showed
that he can make plays another punters
off the board apparently so did the punt
god go no another a different partner no
no punk has got to be in jake carmada
from georgia goes to tampa bay but now
to go back to hassan haskins he is a
downhill runner that's what he's good at
that's what harbaugh built him to be and
so i like that ability to come in and
supplement what you're going to get out
of the big guy derek henry
all right jacob harder ran a 456 which
is faster than
nine running backs and nine wide
receivers at the combine
wow uh i'll say that i don't think he's
going to be running down the field and
making a lot of tackles with that four
five six speed but maybe a position
switch for jake marta i'm just kidding
guys it's not happening and you know
what else is not happening more punter
talk from me and felder so we're gonna
move on to romeo dubs coming off the
board and that is a pick that we are not
only excited to talk about going to
green bay as they look for more vertical
threats they got christian watson
working downfield they traded up for him
in the second round now they get romeo
dubs from nevada played with a big arm
quarterback in college from carson
strong this is something to me a tall
slender kind of guy and you're going to
see it right here he knows how to get
over the top of the defense find the
football make a play vertically when i
look at him darius slade came out of
auburn a couple years ago he had
straight gas quarterback couldn't get
him the ball good thing for dubs is
carson strong could get him the ball
where you see a lot of these downfield
throws beat the corner run over the top
of the safety i really like this pick
for green bay i think this will actually
be one of the better value picks on the
board we see today because it fits the
offense when things break down for aaron
rodgers this is the kind of guy he looks
for we've seen over the years with
marquez valdez scantling they got a
similar player in christian watson but
hey double up on the vertical threats
the rest of the wide receiver room is
old this is an a for me dubs in green
bay slam dunk felder where we at yeah i
love him he this guy with romeo dubs
what you're getting is got this 6-2 210.
and they're cool there are two things
that stood out to me three things three
i'm gonna go through three things that
stood out to me about him one of those
being this is a guy that will play
through the kansas state plays my
favorite play because he is past
interfered with but he's not begging for
a flag he's just going through to catch
make the catch and he does that i love
that about him number two he's a big
receiver that can work in the slot game
he's not afraid that can work in the
slot game work in the screen game he's
not just a vertical threat he's got good
run after catch and the reason i know
he's got that good run out for catching
and working the screen game is because
he's also an excellent return man his
ability to be a return guy helped him
out i mean we don't often see guys that
are 6'2 210 be your primary returner on
punts so that's another special trait
for me i'm going with an a as well one
of those guys that we thought might go a
little earlier but he ends up here and
finally they're getting aaron rodgers a
little bit of help tori holt you got to
love a wide receiver that can win down
the field with speed if dubs was not
banged up during this process i think he
would have ran well and i think it would
have pushed his draft stock up what do
you see here
michael summed it up perfect i mean
a return guy you get him in the fourth
round at 132 that's tremendous value
because he can change he can flip the
field position for you in the return
game and then this is another guy
thousand yard rest thousand yards in
2021 a thousand in 2020 uh he played it
had 116 slot snaps michael mentioned his
ability to play inside in the slot and
he can play outside but what i like
though about him he is and i wrote it
here on my notes let me make sure that i
get to it real
deep threat guy you added with christian
watson and you talked about he had a
quarterback in college that can get into
football he has a quarterback in green
bay that certainly could get get him the
football and what does green bay like to
do they like to throw that deep post
those balls down the field you got a guy
in romeo who can flat out run and who
can flat out go get it i love it he's
gonna find himself a nice home there in
green bay all right as we see jordan
schultz saying the new wide receivers
for aaron rodgers and the packers
offense sammy watkins christian watson
romeo dubs so things are looking grim
after night one thing's talking a little
better well sammy watkins is a pro
so he's gonna get help get those guys up
to speed and he's gonna probably do it
in a way that's a little bit less
demonstrative than aaron rodgers so i
think that's a big asset as well
something that we haven't discussed
nearly enough but having a guy that's a
little more gentle a little bit more of
a that's still a professional but is a
little more gentle than aaron rodgers
it's probably gonna help these guys get
up to speed because they're gonna have
to contribute this year yeah i think so
as well there's no doubt about that all
right let's take a look a little recap
of the draft here we've had picks flying
in i know the niners just took spencer
bureford we're looking at green bay's
recap quake walker surprise first round
picked devonte wide on the defensive
line two wide receivers there in
christian watson and romeo dubs and then
the uh ucla tackle sean ryan that's
gonna kick inside the guard kind of a
nasty run blocker prototypical green bay
day two pick for the offensive line so
back to the draft here at the 49ers
after jake marta second punter the draft
goes off the board of the bucks we have
a punter run folks and the punk god is
still sitting there the niners take
spencer bureford from utsa their highest
recruit they've ever gotten a guy that
came in there with big expectations
played football right away a two-year
starter at guard and then a two-year
starter tackle felder i like him at
guard better at the next level he's
somebody when you get him as an
explosive puller
you're going to want to not be in the
line of sight yeah that's the thing i
like about his ability to pull and his
ability to move laterally
when they run zone he was always out in
front and he was as a tackle when they
ran zone to his side he pushed out in
front found a way to work around found a
way to not just reach that defensive end
but hold that with one hand and then
he's going to look for a linebacker or
safety with the other hand which is why
sincere mccormick was on my list of guys
that i like because he's always there
he's good in pass pro obviously right
there but if you want to go down on the
ground he'll he'll let you go down on
the ground uh you see him here again
more and pass pro his ability to go out
there and set the get set up get
everything ready to rock and roll it's a
lot of pass pro he they threw the ball
plenty well but i love his work in the
um
draw game screen game he gets out in
front of screens which is really good
which you love to see so this is a good
pick this is a guy utsa they're gonna
have three guys picked in this draft oh
yeah tariq one spencer burford sierra
mccormick good group over there fella
what do you think of the grade on this
one oh for a great i'm gonna go with the
b plus i think he's certainly someone
that we're gonna see play in the nfl for
a decent amount of time he is he's a
player he's gonna be a contributor again
you mentioned he's utsa's highest rank
recruit had chances to go play somewhere
else found a place where he could play
basically day one and he never got off
the field yeah feller i'm gonna trail
you there i mean this is pick 134 for
the niners he's player 122 for me
reminds me a little bit of dakota dozier
who has played in the nfl for a long
time get him downhill as an explosive
run blocker he's got good length he's
got really good length maybe in a pinch
he plays tackle but i think his
long-term home and that zone scheme is
going to be guard i'm gonna go with an
a-minus i like the niners getting some
value on the offensive line in the strap
the highest recruit ever for that utsa
program and he lived up to expectations
playing guard and then tackle he'll go
back to guard all right let's keep the
giraffe moving i believe the chiefs are
back on the clock they've done some
really really nice things in this draft
so far
and the pick is in and this is one of my
favorite picks of the day joshua
williams the corner from fayetteville
state
feller he is long he can run he can
press and he does not care that he
played at a small school he got down to
the field of mobile alabama in the
senior bowl and he got hands on guys the
line of scrimmage and said you are not
going anywhere you're not getting to the
phase of your route he could stay in the
hip pocket and that length is going to
help with ball skills at the next level
so we're talking about developmental
corners and the chiefs like these long
outside corners that can press that can
turn and run joshua williams is a guy
for me that
i'm pretty excited about here i think at
this spot i think this is really good
value once again my 94th overall player
on the board yeah this i mean it's great
value he's someone i know that you
really like from fayetteville state
fayetteville is where i was born so you
know i gotta rep him represent uh
he is
long and the length is something that's
really critical uh we're seeing it right
now richard sherman talked about it and
everybody that's long doesn't mean
you're gonna be a great corner so he's
developmental so that means he's gonna
have to get good coaching and take good
coaching i think that's going to be the
key for him so that he doesn't get off
balance doesn't get overextended so i'm
looking forward to watching his
development and because they pick him
here
instead of picking him in that top 100
the pressure's a little bit lessened
and he can develop into a guy that they
really like while he gets work done on
special teams as a gunner or jammer yeah
33-inch arms you talked about the length
there felder that is in the 91st
percentile in the nfl so
everything is there for this guy to be
an outside corner tory holt what do you
think
yes man i i love i love
length at corner and joshua williams
certainly provides that vietnam i know
mike that's your hometown so he's got
plenty of dog in him
anybody from fayetteville that i know
has plenty of dogs michael felder right
here
i heard him in an interview earlier as
they was getting ready for the draft and
he was so professional the things that
he said how in tune he was with the
running back with the with the
cornerback position the wide receiver
position he and christian watson who the
green bay packers ended up drafting were
competing against each other leading up
to the draft so just imagine what those
one-on-one one-on-one sessions were 6-4
and 6-3 going at it i like it he's a
he's a small school kid so he has a chip
on his shoulder and kansas city needs to
continue to improve being more physical
had his having some size and some lymph
on the perimeter i like this pick 36
vertical jump you guys admit he's long
he can get up and press your butt with
those long arms doesn't mind competing i
like this kid four or five forty yard
dash for someone that's six three 195
pounds he can run kansas city just
elevated themselves on the corn on the
perimeter on the corner with a guy like
joshua williams i like it all right you
see kansas city's draft early on they
take the exact opposite of joshua
williams and trent mcduffie short arm
corner great instincts can come down and
tackle down they get a little bit more i
wouldn't say a project because i was
truly impressed with joshua williams of
the senior bowl against wide receivers
that have already come off the board
george carr loftus in the trenches skye
moore he can win vertically for pat
mahomes brian this is a dang good draft
michael felder brian cook and leo chanel
on the defense ooh buddy i would say
kansas city got multiple starters right
yeah they got guys that could come in
and contribute little chanel that's a
great pick i'm so excited for williams
to be there to get to to get to work
into a space that one for a contender
two for a team that's going to allow him
to develop and grow into his role at the
next level really should be a a play
maker for them using that length to
bother the rest of that division which
obviously is getting better and better
no doubt all right so the bengals on the
clock we've heard offensive line about
this team for a long time they take
cordell wilson player 229 on the board
felder you got something for me
i got a question for you
is he going to play tackle no okay
that's what cause i i keep seeing him
loose at his tackle i i i saw that too
six six three fifteen not a lot of
guards that are six foot six sure
i just honestly felt her i just don't
think he has the feet to protect the
outside and that was the big concern for
me was his feat which is probably why
he's lasted this long but i don't think
he can play tackle at the next level do
i but at 6 6 to play guard now you have
to talk about his leverage against guys
like a grady jarrod you have to worry
about him playing against guys that are
a little bit lower lower center of
gravity how does he handle that if he is
going to kick inside to guard how does
he handle those guys and that's going to
be the big question mark because if he
doesn't have the feet to play tackle
then you better have you better have the
hips the knee flex the ankle flexion to
play lower and handle it to root people
out of the way so you can go make plays
and create space for your running game
yeah and i think my problem here with
the spicfelder is you took a a guy
that's going from tackle and kicking
inside the guard right sure you took a
guy because of the athletic limitations
that's why he's doing that
why would you not take jamari sawyer or
darren canard who wore this same story
but played at a higher level and were
significantly better players on tape
bingo yeah that's a tough part for me
with the bengals here maybe they see
something different
with cordell volson in terms of a scheme
fit
let's take a little breather here i
could have a sip of water and get a
little message from our friends at
rocket mortgage
this crazy suit can give me an edge oh
yeah huge edge
invisibility gives aaron donald an edge
on his game who hit me just like a
verified approval gives you an edge on
your offer i did when you need a
competitive edge in the housing game
rocket cam
all right so see the big board here we
just talked about jamari sawyer and
darion canard
i think they're starting level players
and i think somebody's gonna be getting
a steal when those guys come before sam
howell still waiting uh one of the more
this is a player that if you
are insane like me and had to write or
read a mock draft the week after last
year's draft he was in the first round
in all of them yes he was and he had not
just in the first round he was in like a
lot of teams top top 10 top 15s and here
we are now i know we had a down year i
know the time michael felder talk about
unc situation from 2000 well can we
bring torian on this too because i know
he watched a lot of unc as well
sam howell did more this year than he's
done in his entire career i agree and
that's the big key for me sam you lose
michael carter you lose javonte williams
you lose dad's news annie brown you lose
all your you lose diamond brown as i was
thinking of yeah you lose all these
players sam howell went from a guy that
ran for a handful of yards to run for
800 yards this season and everybody's
looking at his passing output but the
guy had no running game until the back
what four four games of the year five
games of the year with ty chandler came
on pretty strong he did more this year
than he did before i don't know why he's
being i unders
his concerns are the same as they were
going into the season which he doesn't
throw well between the hashes and has
some accuracy issues in the intermediate
but that didn't change that was he was
still a top 15 projected guy with all
those issues so tori when you watch sam
howell when you see people talk about
sam howe what's different from
a year ago or even in from september
until now
yeah you know what you know when he was
his
when carter and williams and all those
guys
were all there i mean they were
fantastic he had backs that could run
the football then he obviously had
talent on the perimeter when all those
guys left and went to the draft he was
asked to do a lot more and you saw him
with the rpo stuff uh he's uh he's a
he's a tough competitor um at the at the
quarterback position and the ability to
throw to me i think he throws one of the
better deep balls in all of college ball
out of all the dr all of all the guys
that are being considered to be draft
drafted this year but what i want to see
with sam howell going forward is
speeding up the clock inside of the
pocket right michael for me is what i
want to see him be better at and then
minimizing the turnovers minimizing some
of the some of the some of the plays
that kills drives when they're in
situations where they're moving down the
field to score so that's why i want to
see sam howe improve certainly is
speeding up the clock and then you
mentioned being more accurate in the
intermediate passes because we know in
the national football league that part
of football is critical in between the
hashes over the middle or where a lot of
throws are made quarterbacks are asked
to fit it in there in the tight windows
sam howell will be asked to do that he
has to continue to improve there but in
terms of competitiveness
in terms of the deep ball throw uh a guy
that's going to go out there and give
you everything that he's got uh sam
howell has certainly got that but those
it's those other issues i think that he
has to continue to improve on to really
help himself all right so speaking of
quarterbacks guys
uh we do have one off the board and it
is not sam howell
it is bailly zappy here going to the new
england patriots who we know they are
confident in their quarterback situation
this to me
it's shocking number one i'll say that
but knowing it's new england
it's not the craziest thing no because
you're talking about two totally
different players you know sitting here
listening to you guys and i agree with
you sam howell not always playing
between uh in structure you see belly
zappy middle of the field thrower a guy
that went to houston baptist set a ton
of records him and his wide receiver won
jared stearns they transferred to
western kentucky and they light it up as
well a dominant player there and it
carried over when he transferred to
western kentucky obviously running the
same offense very past happy offense arm
strength below average but accuracy it's
there decisiveness it's there one two
get the ball out that's what it is he
goes through his reads
i'll be honest with you guys but
watching this happy film about 700 of
the throws are in the zero to 10 yard
range yeah just drop back it is get the
ball in playmaker's hands hopefully
there's space catch and run uh long-term
backup he can take care of the ball he
can play in structure with quick short
passes that's what billboard wants he's
backing up mac jones
so
you don't i know a lot of people are
sitting here and and i agree they're
saying how is this not sam howell that's
not the guy they wanted right they want
the guy do what we tell you to do uh so
do the same thing that the other guy
already does
this is a one to one for me
mac jones stronger arm sure but mac
jones doesn't have the strongest arm
this is a one to one this is a one this
is where this is where you see a team
picking a backup a guy that they know is
not going to he doesn't put any fear
into mack jones mike joe's not worried
about his job bailey zappy coming in put
fairness into the fourth round no what
do you know what he's doing this is a
guy that they know is going to learn the
playbook he's going to know what to do
he's going to understand how to help and
he's going to help matt he's going to
help back jones out hey i saw this hey i
know this hey what about this and he's
going to be inquisitive he's going to
learn so when i look at bailey's zappy i
see a guy again he can throw into the
interior he he throws a nice layered
deep ball i love this ability to drop it
in the bucket i love the fact that he's
not afraid of the middle i love the fact
that he understands when the ball has to
come out that it's going to come out he
does not waste time he doesn't buy time
he wait he knows when it hits and when
it hits it's gone if it's not there he's
going to hit the check down and get the
ball out of his hand so they don't take
a sack i think that's the beauty of his
game and it is again it's a one to one
for mac jones you're getting a guy that
can do all the same things that he does
it's it's one of those things where it's
it's crazy when you see a team that has
like um
what was it michael vick and then they
had like matt shaw as like a backup or
something right like it's i was like
this doesn't that you have completely
different systems you can't do that but
this is a good one to one that bring you
bring in a guy that can do the same
things that the starter can do just not
quite as well and you see we saw the
b-roll everything's the same drop back
mechanically every throw looks the same
yes there's not a lot of plays breaking
down there's not a lot out of structure
torrey holt billy zappy goes before sam
howell he goes to a place that has had a
system in place for a long long time
what do we think about this selection
yeah i i think it fits right what what
michael was saying with what new england
wants to do and what you guys kind of
you were saying as well i mean he's
going to do exactly what he's asked to
do and what i like what sticks out to me
68.7 completion percentage he completes
a lot of passes what does what does new
england want to do when they when tom
brady was there what did they do really
well they completed the ball at a very
efficient rate where they was able to
move the ball matriculate the ball down
the football field coupled with that run
game and the play action pass and high
percentage throws i think zappy fits
exactly what the new england patriots
want to continue to do obviously matt
jones is there now i don't see him being
moved off of the first off of the uh
being the the starting quarterback but
you have a solid backup and bayla zappy
that can come in and give you high
percentage throws and he's the third
round this this this is where this guy
felt and what i want to say too
what it was a lot of talk about the
quarterbacks not being the strength of
the draft it was they were absolutely
right this is what the national football
league thinks of these players these are
back up quarterbacks that are coming off
of the board but bayley zappi has a lot
of potential and he throws the ball very
efficient 68.7 percent completion
presented i like it
all right and i like the next pick that
came off the board here the pittsburgh
steelers were on the clock as you see
new england's trap to recap here
a very interesting draft a lot of small
school players from new england but good
athletes ship on your shoulder yeah yeah
yeah very belichick uh esque players the
steelers were on the clock and they took
calvin austin one of the best players
available in this draft a third round
grade from me let's dive into calvin
austin who reminds me of uh and you see
the tweet right there from jason
lochenfora this is part of the draft
where the steelers steal a future impact
wide receiver that is exactly right and
that's exactly what calvin austin is
coming off the board reminds me of
marquis goodwin that 432 speed 665
three cone electric player with the ball
in his hands electric player without the
ball in his hands dual sport athlete ran
track in college state champion sprinter
in high school returns punts brought
back two for a touchdown during his
career at memphis played out wide on
over 70 of his snaps guys just because
he's five foot eight don't mistaken him
for strictly a slot receiver good
releases off the line of scrimmage a
little fun fact here graduated with two
degrees so this guy is extremely smart
he can handle anything you throw at him
at the wide receiver position he could
play inside he could play outside he's
one of the best athletes in the entire
draft he has special teams experience
this is highway robbery for the
pittsburgh steelers an a plus phenomenal
pick kenny pickett's going to be happy
when he walks into pittsburgh and sees
the guy getting off the flight behind
him yeah well here's the thing kitty
pig's gonna have to keep up with it
that's a big question you know what i
mean like he's gonna have to keep up
with his his arm he's gonna have to get
the ball out early so that calvin also
does it out right now waiting i'm gonna
give him an a i i think that austin is a
guy especially getting him here at the
end of the fourth in the comp picks he's
someone that you're you're getting high
value high production the ability to
work in the return game which is going
to be fun because obviously they
pittsburgh hasn't been electric in the
return game since what antonio brown so
you get that electricity added back into
the return game that helps kenny pick it
i think the key here is stealing yards
in return game what are they called
quote unquote hidden yardage you find
those those hidden yardage plays and
that's going to help make fields shorter
keep the field flipped keep it on your
side and then all of a sudden you got
big guy big boy wide receivers on either
side you can run him run him up through
the middle let him stick the post those
guys both run run your sevens let him
run that inside that little seam let's
go make the safety make a decision and
i'll tell you what that team thinks
they're going to get away with playing
tampa 2 and that mike linebacker is
going to try to carry him up the middle
of the field you're about to screw
yourself to the floor
i mean you got chase claypool george
pickens on the outside deontay johnson
one of the best possession receivers in
the game right now with that uh target
machine calvin austin the wrinkle thrown
in torrey holt this guy can fly what do
we see
yes he can you know what and i went to i
went to a hall of fame source on this
one oh
i hit up my i hit up my my my my partner
isaac bruce who played at the university
of memphis hall of famer and i said
isaac
tell me a little bit about this calvin
austin iii he said what's up t-hope
he said he ain't scared
a worker from walk on to a scholarship
player
team mvp
plays bigger than his size
and has legitimate
track
speed that's coming from the gold isaac
bruce hall of famer isaac bruce about
kevin austin iii i happen to be at the
combine
watching all of these wide receivers and
they're all fast and calvin also in the
third 4-3 speed he can play inside he
can play outside and he can give you
some some some value in the return game
and you'll hear me as we continue to go
out throughout the day special teams and
how critical they are can you find
returners that can flip the field for
you put you in favor positions
offensively calvin austin iii can do
that and you can do some tall sweeps
with him you can do some jet sweeps with
him you can do some screens you can do a
lot with cavanaugh's in the third
because he's burning and he ain't scared
great stuff from tory holt and great
stuff from isaac bruce uh that is big
time praise for calvin austin and man
those steelers that's serious serious
value so the baltimore ravens picking
after them they might be a little
disappointed that calvin austin went off
the board after trading hollywood brown
i was going to say because they could
use him
so you could absolutely use them yeah so
the ravens took another tight end a
different kind of tight end obviously
and isaiah likely a little bit more of a
high cut guy a catch and run tight end
in my eyes and more of a move blocker
zac tom one of the best athletes on the
offensive line in this year where does
he play center he's going to play center
he's going to kick from tackle to center
and there and that's played center yep
did play some center they moved him out
the tackle at wake fours he's going to
move back into center okay yep so zach
tom will be a center for green bay they
love the athleticism there i would be
surprised if they gave him a run attack
i know they drafted josh myers last year
i think josh myers has guard flexibility
and let's not forget we are a couple
picks away from the fifth round we are
also thinking depth is part of the draft
here so not everything has to be a
starting player uh
depth developmental talent and then
demarion williams from houston went to
the ravens as well another corner as
they load up on their secondary
i think we
uh kick back to the isaiah likely pick
for a second and get away from the
offensive line for a second with isaiah
likely felder big time production at
coastal carolina one of the more
dynamic players at the tight end
position with the ball in his hands
what is the transition for him walking
into a room that has mark andrews and
charlie kohler and being the third guy
i don't think he views himself as the
third guy he never has been listen what
is he 139 verse 129 or 120 whatever it
is what's the difference
realistically what's the difference
between us right compete he's going to
come in there to compete mark andrews
might be the guy he may defer to mark
andrews but he's not deferring to
charlie kohler and he's going to walk in
a small school or not coastal played
their behinds off and when you watch him
play here look at this this is a guy
that finds a way to get open
consistently he recognizes where he is
going to come open you see him there
burning up the seam that's beating a
safety that is not a linebacker that is
a safety that he's beating you see him
there he's coming across the field as a
crosser he's too big for one guy to take
down he's still got some nice scoot in
his game a different game than charlie
coleman a different game but a guy that
still can make plays i love him in the
semen look at how many long plays this
guy has that's the thing he's run away
run away yeah he can run away from you
he's not just a possession guy and his
floor his 40 time may not reflect that
but the reality of it is when you watch
him play you see his ability to run away
from guys that are supposed to be he's
these some of these are supposed to be
four four guys they should be able to
catch him somehow they can he's got what
you call connor build up speed i go with
an a right here man listen you go down
to coastal out of conway south carolina
you get yourself isaiah likely this
guy's going to be a player for them and
now this gives the ravens three options
at the tight end spot and that makes
them even more dangerous because now
what are we talking about 13 personnel
13 personnel but with three pass
catchers
what do you think because if you go 13
personnel usually that means you put
your big boys in your big package you
throw in a bear front you put a
barefront in on these three guys you're
gonna get your behind burn that's what i
like about this the unpredictable nature
of the raven's run offense that turns
into the passing offense you're 13
personnel you might have guys that are
leaking out isaiah likely is the perfect
leak out player can you hide him on the
line of scrimmage can you have him chip
and edge pass rusher and drag across the
middle on the play-action boot and then
he's wide open over there on the shallow
cross yeah that's what you want to do
you want to get the ball in his hands
and allow him to run they've done that
with mark andrews secret's out mark
andrews one of the best pass catching
tight ends in the entire league charlie
kohler can come in and do that isaiah
likely can come in and do that that's
what the ravens do they retool they
don't spend a ton of money in free
agency they get a million compensatory
picks and then they draft players like
this that are next man up over and over
again torrey hall what are we thinking
here for baltimore another tight end off
the board
yeah
as michael mentioned a lot of 12 and 13
personnel for sure and that's where
that's where lamar jackson and his
offense is very comfortable
um and and you're seeing that now with
isaiah likely i think he uh you guys
mentioned how many long plays he had
there in coastal carolina i think he'll
have those opportunities there with the
baltimore ravens it just brings them a
different level of athleticism there at
the title musician but when i think
about the baltimore ravens yes i like
the tight ends with that that they have
and that they're drafting which is cool
but
who's going to press the issue out on
the perimeter i know they got rashad
babe they took the first round draft
pick last year
they got durvano and then they have
james porsche that's the second but
who's really legitimately going to press
the issue out on the perimeter
ronald lamar jackson can make those
throws to the outside of the numbers can
make those deep post throws because we
know the middle of the field is going to
be occupied because he has three
legitimate tight ends i want to see the
baltimore ravens push the ball down the
field out on the perimeter is it richard
bateman and lamar jackson hooking up
we'll see but tight end wise they are
set they don't need any more tight ends
let's get some more perimeter players
that can force the issue on the
perimeter i'm with you tori it makes you
wonder if they got jumped a little bit
by their rival the steelers for calvin
austin there and i know they did yeah
right i think i think their writing is
on the wall there we'll see what kind of
speed they search for at the end of the
draft is this wide receiver class is
very very deep let's take a look at the
baltimore ravens draft uh felder and i
have been very high on this draft from
the beginning i think they have remade
or retooled i should say a defense they
signed marcus williams they get him
running mate and kyle hamilton that's an
absolute stud they got the best center
in the draft top five player and tyler
linderbaum i love what they've done as a
whole because
drafting and stashing david jabo you
will reap those rewards in 2023. troy
anderson uh you see the speed there i
believe he actually went to the falcons
correct me if i'm wrong a lot going on
things are moving fast today travis
jones round one player for me yeah they
get him in the third round skyscraper
godzilla tackle and daniel fellaily the
ravens have done a great job felder i
look at this draft guys and i'm ready to
say it they might be the winner of the
draft for me as it stands we have a lot
of picks left to do uh i won't put the
official end-all stamp on it until round
seven concludes we'll do that on monday
we'll do that on monday you could tune
in felder and i will be holding that
down in the bleacher report app you
cannot get rid of us just because the
draft is over but i look at the
baltimore ravens through here and right
now as it stands this is an a for me
guys this is absolutely a no doubter
eric decosta learning under ozzie how to
retool a roster
what do you think felder no they did a
great job and listen
they're doing what they want they know
that they're they're a running football
team their bread is buttered with the
run game i do agree with tory they've
got to find a way to stretch the field
and create a vertical threat because
otherwise teams are going to make the
field small shrink everything which
makes it a little bit harder for guys to
get open so you have to have that over
the top that wide threat to stretch the
perimeter you got to make people cover
the field 53 and a half 53 and a third
yards wide but you also got to make them
cover 45 50 yards down the field on
every on any given play and i think
that's the next step for the ravens to
get back to where they want to be
i'm with you felder it's been a really
really good draft for them all right
let's keep them moving we have some
picks come in uh the ravens obviously
made a pick when we were talking about
isaiah likely demario williams a player
from
houston that has played outside in the
slot in the box as a little bit as a
safety um kind of an interesting guy and
we don't want to fall behind too much
here but uh quick hitter on demario on
williams if you have any both houston
corners getting picked yep let's go
earlier
early not even around five years we're
not in round five yeah he's the other
guy right we talk so much about marcus
jones but what'd you get with williams
did you get a guy that's i think he's a
stud like a steadfast guy not as fast as
jones but he is someone that understands
his responsibilities he plays a lot of
denial football which i really like and
that's where you see a guy who
recognizes okay what i have to do is
shut this play down before the
quarterback puts the ball in the air and
he does that really really well all
right after that
the rams you have to cherish these
moments because they don't happen often
the rams were on the clock and made a
selection they didn't they didn't trade
it for a veteran player they actually
made a draft pick so they went to kobe
durant from south carolina state who i
do want to pause here and break down
quickly i don't want to fall behind two
bar shrine game guy
senior 510
a little bit of a you know not a length
guy but four three eight wheels he can
absolutely fly here's the thing to know
12 career interceptions the athleticism
to survive in the slot and make a play
on the football
he is a he's a baiter right like this
guy likes to bait you and take the ball
away and i think that obviously that he
can do that playing in the conference he
played in but he also had a couple
interceptions against clemson he made
life hard for them he's someone that
wants to
he he trusts his recovery speed
tremendously and he understands when the
ball is going to come out so that he
understands when to accelerate we talk
all the time about wide receivers
playing with tempo in dbs kind of just
having to be victims of having to react
to that i think that jacoby duran is one
of those few the rare defensive back
that understands that tempo wouldn't be
any surprise to me if he played wide
receiver he understands where the ball
is going to come out when he's going to
come out and when he can accelerate to
go make a play all right keeping the
draft moving here we had uh chiga konkwo
from maryland come off the board and
that will close out round four so the
titans
we know
yeah we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna stay right here on round
four uh let's talk a little bit about
chig okonkwo from maryland
i don't want to call him delaney walker
because that's just very cliche but you
get the idea of the undersized tight end
that you can move around in the
backfield that you can move off the line
of scrimmage four five two wheels is an
elite number four tight end a smaller
tight end he's a fascinating player to
me felder i think this is a classic
tennessee that you see what they've had
over the year delaney walker right they
lost the tight end to new england in
free agency they're a type of team that
values athleticism at this position i
like him i liked him coming out of high
school right i was excited that he stuck
stuck around at home and went to
maryland this is a guy that uh plays
fast is able to make plays can and run
runs down uh really he's tough to run
down if he's getting moving side to side
that linebacker that's in the middle not
gonna be able to track him across the
field uh i think he's at his best
probably
i want him to be better in the red zone
but i think he's at his best work
getting work done in that
cross the field area and working in the
interior in that green zone right the
20s to the 20s that's where he's at his
best because the field is way bigger i
think he's still going to find a way to
be more of a threat in the red zone
where the field gets choked down all
right guys we finally we've been waiting
for this one for a while washington
commanders are on the clock to kick off
round five today
and sam howell is off the board and what
did i say earlier in the show about
carson wentz yeah a guy that has had
been banged up um a guy that can play
out of structure like sam howell does
yes and
you have you are paying him for one year
of guaranteed money sam howell i know
it's the fifth round he's not coming in
to be a hero he's not coming in
necessarily to be a star but when you
look at it overall for sam
this is a situation that
he's got a chance here he's not going to
play this year unless carson wentz does
get hurt but he's a dynamic athlete we
know what he could do out of the pocket
he's got a big arm don't be mistaken
that he's not six foot five 230 pounds
right big arm can push the ball down the
field a lot of running almost forced to
run at times with the the way unc's
offense fell off if he could dial it
down and i don't need him to play in
structure like tom brady i don't need
everything to be a drop back pass we saw
bailey zappy go earlier that's exactly
what he is can you get it to where
you're capable in structure that would
be a big time win for sam howell the
value here is phenomenal as much as we
all didn't really love this quarterback
class we're glad they're not overdrafted
when you look at sam howell for me i
think he's one of the best players on
the board player67 you get him at 144 to
kick off round five this is an a there's
nothing to lose here taking sam howell
on this spot totally agree i when i look
at this and i look at sam howell again
we talked about him already on this show
i will kind of reiterate hit the big
point this is a guy can throw the ball
stretch the ball down the field so you
get you add john dodson you have terry
mclaren you have dearmi brown his former
teammate he can stretch the ball down
the field he can push it vertically very
very well the things we have to work on
working between the hashes he's got to
figure out how to throw the ball between
the hatches and in the intermediate
areas everything that he does to the
sideline outside the numbers is
beautiful you see it right there love to
see that he's got to work better at
getting the ball in between the hashes
and getting into that intermediate area
so that he can go out and make plays i
think that's going to be the key for him
is getting all that done so that he can
make plays i think the legs are going to
be an asset yes legs are something that
allow him to go ahead and make a play
the legs are going to be a thing that
put him in position
to roll out that put him in a position
to
once the play breaks down find something
else i'm going to give it an a plus
listen like i'm going to add the little
tar heel bump on there i like it but the
real key for me is they're getting a
player that is going to be able to go
out there if pressed you know third
quarter they feel like they're in the
football game wince goes down let's
bring in sam off the bench he's going to
try and chuck it up there and we'll see
what happens you know what i like to
call it with young quarterbacks that can
run that are underdeveloped it buys them
time to develop yes because when all
else fails you can run you can force the
linebackers up you can get creative with
you have the right offensive coordinator
torrey holt sam howell finally off the
board what do we think here
well i'll say this as soon as sam gets
in the camp he's going to find the army
brown and in 101 they're going to go
deep cause he's throwing to a guy that
he threw to a college that he's very
comfortable with and they connected on a
lot of deep balls but i like sam howe's
athleticism i think
now you have him in your in the fold you
can do something you can do things
differently offensive you can move the
pocket you can do more boots he's really
athletic and agile with his feet and his
michael mentioned too the ball down the
field he's the best and he's the best in
this draft class to me as you see him
there hooking up with josh downs who's
one of the elite wide receivers in the
acc he's coming back next year for unc
but i like sam house moxie he completed
62 percent of 62
of his passes he's a confident kid he
doesn't have to go to washington and be
the guy he can learn behind carson wentz
and carson wentz has a lot to share with
him he's had a journey himself in the
national football league that he can
share with sam howe sam howe is a very
competitive very competent quarterback
that doesn't again doesn't have to come
in and save washington can learn but he
does bring some different elements to
that offense because of his wills and
his deep ball accuracy i like torrey
bringing up the deep ball accuracy
you're talking about a team that has
diamie brown yeah they have terry
mclaurin who are they drafting around
one this year johan dodson this is a guy
that this seems like a plan to me and
i'm not saying they're throwing all
their chips on a fifth round quarterback
but you can see a vertical
stretch-to-field play-action offense
developing and that's with carson wentz
but now if carson wentz gets hurt which
i can't emphasize enough it's happened
many times can your backup come in and
execute the offenses you have the arm
talent to do so same house you can do a
lot of the same things yes all right
let's take a look at where we are in
this draft right now as you see
up next on the clock giants giants bears
washington bears getting a lot of double
runs here day three the draft gets a
little nuts you have the compensatory
picks you have a lot of traded picks
you're going to see a lot of movement
giants have done a lot of nice things in
this draft to kick things off here and
we have the quarterback picture has kind
of come full circle here michael felder
we saw kenny pickett go night one we saw
about 54 picks until the next one was
taken desmond ritter comes off the board
malik willis to tennessee bailly zappy
going off the board before sam howell
goes to the washington commanders we
still have carson strong on the board
which is a little bit of an interesting
scenario so a lot of excitement ahead
let's check in on where we are with
these draft picks and we have the chiefs
at the top of round five right after sam
hall taking one of the best players
available in darion canard yeah darien
canard guy that we expect to kick inside
to guard he's gonna he's providing depth
for them right now right this is a guy
that they expect to come in at depth be
a guy that they can develop into a guard
place tackle in kentucky we thought he
was going to end up being a second round
guy ends up in the fifth round top of
the fifth good ball player a fighter
someone that you see here as you go into
it darren kanar goes to the chiefs and
is someone they can kind of stash and
develop but you look at him playing that
offensive tackle in the scc and look at
the way he puts the clamps on look at
that drive the ability to drive someone
down the field to create space for that
that violent kentucky rushing attack you
see him here in pass protection a little
high but he still has the base to get an
anchor he can do those things again at
the tackle spot we expect him to move to
guard but he's able to pick up pick up
the spin move push them down inside and
they end up with a touchdown i really
like darian canard for me i give this an
a plus i mean you're getting a guy you
don't have to play him early but you
have the ability to play him early if
you if you need to if guys go down and
we know injuries happen along the
offensive line all the time he's going
to be a contender to get some early
playing time if there's an injury yeah
61st overall player for me in this draft
mike iu potty kind of player yes yes
just to build the way redirects um
for me i look at this felder and i think
one thing besides value which i love
here for darion canard they took trey
smith in the sixth round last year he
got into camp he was better than
everybody earned a starting job bingo we
know trey smith had some medical
situations at tennessee when he's on the
field he's amazing this gives you a
scheme insurance that if trey smith gets
banged up darian canard can come in and
fill that role as the tough guy at right
guard going in from right tackle this is
an a for me canard's great value like
once again 61st overall player uh the
chiefs i think are going to be a little
bit more of a physical running team this
year they're always going to be a
throwing team but sure can you develop
the run element when you get in trouble
in the postseason tory holt a big-time
offensive lineman to one of the
most consistent contenders and i see
that thumbs up thumbs up yeah full send
it i i i i like the fact that this guy
and shouts out to kentucky too i mean
they've had a draft haven't they put
some guys in the drafting chair so shout
out to kentucky but what i do like here
he's playing tackle but you guys
mentioned you can move him down inside
if you want to he's got long arms he's
got a punch he's got 35 inch arms 11 1 4
hands so he's packing a punch but he can
play tackle he can move inside and he
can play guard one of the things that
kansas city chiefs wants to do is they
want to be physical running the football
this year with hilaire which i think is
going to be his breakout year and then
they want to protect patrick mahomes so
he can throw the football to all the
speed and talent that he has on the
perimeter and canard provides them the
depth again on the perimeter on the
outside of the tackle position and if
you want to kick him inside and bring
some more physicality because you want
to run the football and set a tone you
can kick him inside as well along with
orlando brown and the rest of this
offensive line and thuny joe dooney
who's a champion i like this pick for
kansas city and as you mentioned kind of
the value in where they get me but the
versatility that he provides he's a
two-time first-team all-sec player in 20
and 21. he's played in the sec which is
we you know what the sec has when
georgia and alabama they have premier
defensive tackles that can get after you
this guy has seen them all um i think
there's darren canard can fill in very
well with the kansas city chiefs and
andy reid and what they do offensively
and how they develop their players let
them know tory i like to pick as well
this is big time all right we got a
little bit of trade action here chicago
has traded up to 148. uh they traded 148
to buffalo before we get there the
giants are picking back to back i do not
want to skip the new york giants while
we wait for the giants fix to roll in
and we got the first one which is micah
mcfadden indiana linebacker it's that
money backer mold yeah three set here
and take a look at the big board here
jamar you saw you're still up there
malcolm rodriguez still up there uh
kingsley barry tyler algier the running
back from byu kyren williams the running
back from notre dame carson's strong the
last of the quarterbacks beau melton
from rutgers player that i would like to
see come off the board real soon
and let's let's uh let's take a look at
felder's faves here see where we're at
with felder's top players i don't think
mary sawyer is going to make a
reappearance look at that we got kohler
on there so we got a lot of guys still
on the board for me
might not be my day here
but we got a lot of guys that are still
quality ball players up there there's
we're just still finding like the crazy
thing is is we look at the sheet right
now and listen pierre strong he goes off
right before kohler pierre strong i like
him a lot i mentioned i compared to
travis 18. guy's a ball player uh you're
throwing romeo dubs i didn't put him on
the list but we've talked a lot about
him over the course of draft over the
course of draft crash course that's
that's not a mouthful held it um uh but
you throw in um bailey zappy another guy
that i watched a lot of a lot of him
play because they were such a dynamic
experiment in bringing over a
quarterback his best receiver and the
coaching staff from houston baptist
which was a really cool thing to watch
over the course of the season so this
has been really interesting to see how
things have shaken over the course of
this draft very curious to hear once
this dust settles what's up with jamari
sawyer we heard yesterday what was going
on with nicole dean behind the scenes in
terms of the pack
the shoulder the medicals maybe jamari
sawyers dealing with some of those
things as well all right so the giants
go uh back-to-back picks to kind of
toughen up the defense here you got
micah mcfadden the linebacker and then
you get dj davidson the big defensive
lineman from arizona state i would like
to focus on davidson here sure uh who i
think is one of the last of the
defensive lineman in the draft of the
space eating big guys 327 pounds
obviously
somebody that can hold blocks contain
read and react against the run and this
is this draft was not deep in that area
right we saw neil farrell go today well
there's only a handful of people like
that on the planet yes that's exactly
right and one comes off the board here
for the giants i think we're seeing a
little bit of an identity from the
giants here with wink martindale wanting
to get a little beefier right in the
middle of the defense listen
here's this is the reality of football
everything plays through the middle the
quickest way to get to the end zone is a
straight line so what you try to do is
force everything to bounce that's why we
see teams play with that pinch front
that's why we see teams squeeze the
middle block the interior and want
everything to bounce wide that's what
happens that's the way you football
works and i think the beauty of it all
is we're so obsessed with this
horizontal football but the reality is
if you can make people run sideways that
means they're not gaining ground and
that's exactly what we're looking at
with wink martindale all right let's
bring back torrey holton here i know
he's got some thoughts on the latest
giants defensive picks as you see the
giants offset off off season moves tori
what are we thinking here
yeah i mean again just the giants when
you when you think about how bad they
were at times last year offensively and
at times defensively but with dexter
lawrence and now you know and leonard
williams and now uh thibodeaux and you
bring in dj beefy gives you some some
depth there the difference the tackle
makai mcfadden the linebacker from
indiana they certainly can use more
depth at the linebacker position of a
crowder and blake martinez uh i like to
i like the vision and the thoughts of
don martindale with this defense saying
look we're going to be thick and
physical up front to stop any run of
anybody who's coming at us and then we
got some linebackers that could move
around fly around sideline the sideline
that can get downhill and make some
plays for us the giants saying we're
going to be better defensively and we
want to run the football on offense to
wear you down all right we are going to
bring back torrey holt in just a moment
because the bills traded up and they
take one of the best wide receivers on
the board and khalil shakur and this is
a pick that we were excited to talk
about as soon as it came in i told
everybody in the back we're doing this
one we're doing the khalil shakira pick
we've had a ton of run on defense we had
a couple punters go off the board and it
was not the punt god
this is an exciting pick for a bill's
team that cole beasley showing the door
right now you're looking for and khalil
shakur he's played all over the place
you see him even motioning out from the
backfield there to get a manufacturer
touch tough guy with the ball in his
hands i think he's a slot at the next
level reminding me of sterling shepherd
right a player that he's not going to
wow you with size he's not going to wow
you with speed he just gets the job done
there's polishing the routes he plays
bigger at the catch point than his size
as you see here right on the back pylon
go up and win the football i don't care
that i'm not six feet tall i'm gonna
find a way to win the football i think
if you scheme touches to him guys he's a
good tackle breaker as well so this is
really this is a really really good idea
for the bills to get depth at the wide
receiver position you gave stephon diggs
a much earned uh contract extension gabe
davis is broken out on the other side
you have talon at tight end now you get
a guy that fits on the inside and they
need they want more uh gadget plays to
protect josh allen they don't want josh
allen taking all these hits taking on a
that kind of you know contact over and
over again during the regular season how
do you do that scheme pitch passes
scheme sweeps khalil shakir can do that
this is one of the better value picks of
the day uh he was in
near the top of my board one of my top
wide receivers i give this an a for
buffalo they know how to find skill town
on day three of the draft yeah for me i
give this thing i'm gonna go ahead and
give this drop drop an a plus on this
bad boy because i love what he brings to
the table this is someone who is a
football player that plays wide receiver
he understands exactly when he's
supposed to be open he's willing to do
everything he mentions some of that
gadget work he'll play out of the
backfield he'll cross the backfield
he'll take a jet sweep he'll take the
pitch pass he'll take all those little
things but when you ask him to get down
the field when you ask him to to
stem inside to get outside the thing i
love it i want to hear tory's thoughts
about this uh so tori jump in here but
the thing i love about him is his
ability to leave himself room you see it
right there a lot of too many wide
receivers fade hard
to the sideline don't buy themselves
space he leaves himself room so the
quarterback can make a successful pass
and this is the guy let's not forget
played with a freshman quarterback
and a sophomore quarterback the last two
seasons and still found a way to be
incredibly productive and incredibly
successful this is a guy that just gets
the job done he knows when he's supposed
to be open he's a tough runner after the
catch
tori tell us your thoughts on khalil
shakir
i gave my grade i told you it's a hey
plus
and how he plays the position giving
himself enough room along the sideline
to be able to make the make the catch
and he makes
from what i'm understanding he's really
good with the circus the circus catches
he's like the circus catch king is what
as how some people describe in my
highlight reel waiting to happen when
you think about uh khalil shakur against
six foot 196 pounds four four speed
and when you couple him out there with
what they got going on in buffalo and
the guy in josh allen that can throw the
football to anybody anywhere on the
football field
shakur has got to be excited and another
thing that i like you talk about
production you know he's a he was a
thousand yard receiver uh last year he
uh had 529
slot snaps so he could play inside he
can play play outside he had seven
touchdowns i like what the buffalo bills
are doing we know that they need to
improve their run game but we also know
that they want to throw the football
they add another weapon in calista court
yeah they certainly do he doesn't have
to come in and be a hero there but you
could find ways to get him the football
let's look at the bill's draft right now
cair elam a corner
obviously evaluated really highly by
that bill's staff james cook a pass
catching running back with a lot of
juice i know he's a felder fave yeah
terrell bernard a bit of a money backer
that you can get on dime packages nickel
packages khalil shakur so this is what
good teams do guys the buffalo bills
right brandon bean great team builder
they've laid the floor they put the roof
on the thing now they're just putting
the plants around the house they're
getting little pieces here right they're
making it look nice they're getting now
kyrie elmo is going to be starting
outside corner that's what i'm talking
about but sub package player and terrell
bernard that can play
special teams as well you look at it
with khalil shakir is he going to be in
the base set as a wide receiver no but
can you find manufactured touches for
him same with james cook and then maybe
by year two motor singletary free agency
we'll see if he leaves or not this is
what smart teams do they re-haul and
they're kind of just adding the cherry
and the sprinkles on top right now it's
great it's beautiful to watch they do
they have a plan they came in with a
plan and they're executing the plan
which is what you want to see it's not
them just picking all over the board
tour i want to hear from you one more
time closing thoughts on khalil shakira
and buffalo yeah i was going to say one
last thing about about khalid shakur and
i think he's going to play in his favor
he's a high character guy yes and that
and that matters when you're coming in
in the fifth round and you're battling
and working your butt off to make the
make the team you have to have you need
good character and this guy's a high
character football player uh as you all
mentioned i think that's going to play
over very very well for him in buffalo
all right so moving on from the bills
who continue to do good things the
washington commanders were back on the
clock and they took nevada tight end
cole turner a really interesting player
in this draft guys 249 pounds six foot
six and a half so you're looking at the
charlie kohler kind of build charlie
kohler-ish kind of role at a nevada
high-octane passing attack they did greg
dolcich kind of role as well yeah we're
not afraid to give him the catch-and-run
throws work him up the scene even throw
the ball down the field to him so for
cole turner
kind of a strange process for me here
guys somebody that did look like a good
pass catching threat on film did not
test like a prototypical tight end i
looked him at as as a move tight end i
think if he ran better i think we would
have saw him come off the board and
maybe round three or four yeah i think
obviously the numbers are the numbers
are what the numbers are and he can't
change that about himself but when you
put the tape in
he doesn't catch the ball smoothly all
the time
but he does catch the football he does
like a lot that that that's an amazing
catch but it's a double catch and then
you see him here that's a great catch so
it's it's up and down up and down you
don't want the double catch but you like
the fact that he's willing to go up and
get it and look right there he secures
it it's not pretty all the time but he's
able he's got strong hands and he hangs
on he's snow cone yeah he's hanging on
to the football like he's stronger and i
think that's why he fits in as a tight
end right he's strong this is a strong
guy i'm gonna give this a b plus i look
at him play and for me he is someone
that listen i don't need he's not gonna
be blocking in line for you very often
what he is going to be able to do though
is be a mismatch guy when it comes to
him up against the safety you get him
against a guy like uh kirby joseph who
we saw come off the board yesterday and
guess what kirby got a problem because
he he he can't do anything with six foot
six uh that's gonna be a real big deal
so i think b plus here because he is
someone with really strong hands catches
don't always look the most beautiful all
the time but he hangs on to the football
and i love the fact that he's got those
strong hands to secure yeah this one the
only reason it's a c-plus for me i've no
problem with cole turner i would have
gone with grant calcutta if you were you
were looking for this kind of player in
that kind of role maybe the medical we
know grant calcutta had to step away
medical retirement came back rebuilt
himself at smu cole turner a really
productive player at nevada i think he
plays faster than the testing numbers
like felder said once again getting
comfortable securing the football maybe
put on a little bit more weight can you
get anything out of him i don't need to
be in line blocking defensive ends can
you get him on the move on outside zone
climb to linebackers and long lines of
that so for me it's a c-plus here just
because i liked a certain player much
better but i have no problem with the
pick tight ends are going fast and
furious guys 10th tight end off the
board tory holt this is a guy that plays
a little bit more like a wide receiver
though what do we think here with cole
turner yeah i was just saying uh i was
just sitting there thinking kind of i
was saying well okay well what can
washington do i mean they have they got
johan dotson they got terry mclaren they
got curtis samuels when he's healthy and
how good he can really be
where is the other mitch matt
where can they find some value somewhere
else uh with their tight ends or with
their running back and i think they can
do some of that with cole turner as as
as you all as michael mentioned the
strong hands he's six foot six you
telling me you can't line up in the red
zone and split him out and say okay
we're going to throw a 50-50 ball up to
you or fade and see if you can go up at
6-6 with strong hands and get it i think
you can do that so i think he provides a
little more versatility some maybe some
match-up problems for the washington
commanders as they go forward and as he
continues to develop all right uh good
stuff tori hall i do like that this was
the kind of player they needed right the
wider receiver room is very very crowded
now so now you look at the tight end uh
somebody that can run the scene against
linebackers pick 150 the houston texans
back on the clock we're gonna hit that
really quick they took uh thomas booker
and then we're gonna get to the falcons
taking tyler algiere we'll grade that
pick before we do
light hit on thomas booker here big time
recruit yes he was really good athlete
felder for me hot and cold film times
where he got washed down again washed
out against the run there is pass rush
juice uh he when you hear he's another
tory said this earlier high character
player a really bright guy coming out of
stanford a hard worker
why didn't it all come together to be a
dominant player why are we talking about
thomas booker in round five instead of
day two i i don't i don't know i think
stanford has some issues in general okay
foundational issues uh from a stanford
problem remember this is a team that
lived in a mountain on high back in the
solomon thomas the andrew trenches the
trenches were great the tight ends were
great obviously andrew luck was great
all those things they seem to as a
program there's been some some erosion
from their intellectual brutality
element of their game so what i look at
is overall nobody in that program
essentially has developed the way that
we thought they would
over the course of the last probably
three four years and he's a victim of
that and so with watching them
especially as they struggle to win
football games uh
davis mills another one a guy that i
thought was going to be a first-round
draft pick for sure so when i look at
booker i think the big key for me is
going to be he's going to have to grow
into what role he wants to be does he
lose a little bit of weight and he
really sticks as a five tech and uses
some of those passers things that you
discussed or does he bulk up and he just
he lives as a six foot three three
technique play a little bit of a two
does he live as that i think he's got to
figure out what position he's going to
play at the next level and that's what
the job of the texans all right so after
thomas booker went off the board
we did have the atlanta falcons take
tyler algier the bruising north south
running back from byu let's dive into
tyler algae our player that i did not
expect to be here a top 100 player on
the board for me he is rb5 for me in
this class so the value phenomenal what
i like about tyler algiere you can trust
him right away excellent in pass bro you
see the violent contact balance as a
runner he could he could dip that
shoulder down truck stick you but also a
little bit of juice a little bit of
wiggle north south speed i really like
the 10-yard split with him was a number
that stood out for me guys i don't care
that he ran a four six forty the one
five six ten yard split is the number of
acceleration he accelerates from the
line of scrimmage into that 10 to 20
yard range and that creates explosive
plays for him and i just love that you
can trust him on the field and they're
gonna need to do that and pass
protection for marcus mariota they're
gonna need help there this is a team
that they're trying to find it with
playmakers they have kyle pitts now they
took drake london but and they got
cordero patterson who's kind of this
wide receiver running back tyler algiere
there's no secret about him north south
runner i like the value here a lot this
is an a for me atlanta for atlanta
they've done a really really really nice
job here there it is i was not allowing
this one to not sneak onto the screen
great pick by atlanta felder what do you
see in algiers this dude's a bruiser
like for real he's an old school running
back like he this field watching him
play it feels like you're watching
football in the 90s like this is a guy
that's going to come downhill he's going
to bang on somebody he's going to make
he's not going to make anybody miss
really he's going to make you pay and
he's going to dare you to tackle him and
by the end of the game folks are going
to get tired uh he's got a lot of that
that that anger that violent running
style to his game so i love to watch and
play uh this is an a for me as well he
is someone that is going to add some
toughness to a falcons team that we've
discussed their ability to play
mismatches a lot now you bring a little
toughness into that backfield and
hopefully that helps them uh in pass pro
obviously with mariota moot to hit those
mismatches but in the run game helps
them be a little tougher downhill all
right tori obviously this is a falcon
team that is just matt ryan air is over
the julio jones era is long over calvin
ridley will not be playing this year
they got kyle pitts they got drake
london now they get a workhorse runner
what do you see in tyler algiere to this
offense
yeah i like it in a way to stabilize the
backfield and a way to stabilize and
help that quarterback marcus mariota is
to get you someone like algiere
not he's not he's probably not going to
wow a lot of people
but there is a lot not to i mean there
is there is also
not much to dislike about this guy i
mean he
46 yard 40 obviously
224 pounds he's 5 11. i had a 10 broad
jump so he's very explosive and i like
what michael said too and you too as
well connor connor thank you he can help
them in pass pro he can help them a lot
in the past pro but he brings a physical
run style to the atlanta falcons and you
want and atlanta wants to establish a
line of scrimmage and the way you do
that is you run the ball consistently
with a bruiser i think algier provides
that all right i'm with you all the way
obviously all three of us
big fans of the pick draft recap here
tyler algiere we just talked about
dalaran turner yell goes to denver and
then we had tariq woolen go to seattle
for some reason weezer is playing on the
tv at the nfl [ __ ] instead we're gonna
actually talk about the players being
picked so
let's go to tariq woolen yes because you
have to break down one of the most
fascinating athletes in the entire draft
diving into tariq woolen guys
i don't want to be mr numbers over here
but when you see a guy that everything
is in
a rare group you have to break it down
he is a
corner taller than six foot four yeah
he's 205 pounds michael felder he ran a
four to six 40 at that size he jumped 42
inches in the vertical this is a
different kind of guy with tentacles for
arms now what i will say about tariq
olin i love the athlete i love what he
can be he's still figuring out how to
play he's still figuring out when to
throw his hands how to press opening up
his hips running downfield and finding
the football when you're that big and
that fast i think the ball production
can be special it's not there yet now in
terms of the fifth round this kind of
athlete these are the athletes that you
draft player 134 on the board we are at
pick 153 this is an a minus for me for
seattle or maybe they can simplify
things for him michael felder maybe play
cover three press bail we know he's got
the length to press we know he's got the
speed to run former defensive back talk
to me listen i'm gonna tell you this
guy's on my he was all my favorites of
the day
so he is a quality ball player i love
what he brings six foot four four two
forty come on man you can't do nothing
with that that's an a plus this guy is
going to continue to improve he's gonna
continue to get better those long arms
you've got those long arms he's got the
ability to be destructive in pass
coverage zone or man he's learning how
to sync in that in that cloud coverage
to be a problem underneath for his
safety to get those hands up he wants to
tackle he's still going to learn the
right way to approach him tackling but
he wants to tackle we've seen the way he
can take the ball away on a break he can
come down so for me tariq warren that's
an a plus this guy is i thought he would
come off the board a little earlier than
this a plus that's a great pick for the
seahawks i love it too uh felder it
sounds like there was some rumblings
that he could have gone in the second
round with those kind of measurables
i like when these things happen i'd
rather see the guy get paid of course
but i like that now he can come in and
settle into it sure and not be a
superhero where you could burn him out
let them develop for sure i'm developing
a place that
this is a team that has had brandon
browner on the outside the only other
six four corner i can think of off top
my head they love big db yes they do so
here we go you've seen it right there
from eric at home does a great job
covering the draft for yahoo sports uh
one is a seattle cornerback as you heard
here except there are like nine guys on
the earth built like him not a lot of
six foot four corners no there's not
there's not a lot so all right let's
jump back here because i do want to try
to give the love to all of the picks
when we catch up here uh everybody
tuning in to the show this is what we do
it's day three of the draft me and
michael felder have watched these guys
not for a year not for two i've watched
them for three elders watching for about
eight so going back to when they were
babies in high school yeah woman's of
faith so we got three faves gone still
got still gotta have question marks
about sawyer verone mckinley i expect
he's got to come off here relatively
soon a lot of teams need safety help
mccormick would be our third utsa guy
off the board today which would be
amazing for them easy a guy who went
from memphis to tcu a developmental
tackle but i think he's got a really
high ceiling as a guy who's still new to
football looking to see what he can do
and then obviously uh ridgeway uh the
kid out of arkansas we're gonna see what
he does okay so let's backtrack here and
go delairan turner yell safety out of
oklahoma
five foot ten sub 200 pounds ran really
well um
for me on on filmfelder a guy that you
can move around ask a lot of in coverage
and he kind of likes to fly around like
a rocket i saw a lot of carl joseph in
his play uh so when you look at de lair
and turner yell we're not going to grade
this pick but a quick breakdown for the
broncos that this franchise is
constantly adding secondary pieces he's
not coming in there and asks to start
but maybe when you do go three safety
looks is there a place for him on the
field
um yeah i think say it again give me
give me give me for the broncos if they
go three safety looks is there a
projectable role for him right away when
you look at cause he's not a guy that's
gonna go in their start they're
comfortable with safety they're
comfortable at corner but just the type
of role i saw him as a coverage piece
yeah i think coverage piece is critical
and i and listen does that mean that you
play him in the slot or does that mean
that you play him or does that mean you
take one safety move him down and put
him in the back and i think that's going
to be the key with delaira turner yell
he's a guy that i saw vast improvement
from uh at oklahoma right uh year one
under grinch he seemed lost you're too
under grinch he started to figure things
out i think that he's better in the back
end so what i would do is move another
safety down and then let him stay in the
back instead and let him come down to
make plays instead of having him up in
the box where he can't see can't
diagnose he's only 5 10. so he's got to
be back a little bit have some
perspective you see where all of his
players are him coming down from depth
to go make plays not him playing up near
the line of scrimmage he's a he's a
better tackler in 2021 than he was in
2020 that's what you want you want to
see that improvement so for dty i love
the fact that he's improved consistently
and it's it's been it's shown me that he
could take coaching he could take the
criticism he can get better effort was
better this year as well you want me to
give this one a grade you can if you'd
like we didn't have to but yeah i'm
gonna go i'm gonna give this one a b man
i love the fact that he's gotten better
and he's really improved so i got to
give him some props for that and i'll
roll with michael felder that's a b for
me the value checks out i think he's got
a role here for denver i'm a big fan of
that spot we'll flash that one more time
before we throw it off the screen so
when you look at it here uh we had
another pick coming after it's required
jacksonville jaguars take snoop connor a
early declaration player out of ole miss
you heard us talk about hassan at
haskins earlier that downhill running
goal line runner super connor to me is
your next man up in that kind of version
that's interesting that it's him versus
a guy like jaren ealy
yes that that that's the part that stood
out the most to me was uh watching
someone who i thought was a little more
um what sword i'm looking for explosive
explosive polished um and and so conor's
a guy he was he was there he was there
really basically the number two guy he
had some breakout games but he's a good
running back i think he can develop at
the next level he's someone that is a
downhill runner so you watch him here
and you're gonna see you're gonna see
that tight end come across and he's
gonna find a way to make find a way
through the hole and that offensive
lineman just bodied somebody so i like
that i think that the key for him is
recognizing where the space is there's a
nice hold right there to give him the
edge so it's going to be interesting to
see how this all shakes out for him but
i i think that at 222 clearly what they
want for him they want him to do is play
more downhill and he looks like a guy
that does like to get side to side i
wanted to play more downhill i was
thinking that as well feller i think
this is a player that i'd like to see
the buy-in of being north south because
of they're drafting him to handle that
role when you look at this team uh in
the backfield you have james robinson
coming off of injury i think they want
snoop connor maybe to be a insurance
piece of that role you have travis
etienne who we think they're going to
use as you know your wide runner your
pass catcher as well so
yeah so for snoop connor power back in
this uh part of the draft and one of the
more value power backs in early
declaration once again so torrey holt
jacksonville adds a goal line power
runner to the offense what do you see
here
yeah that's exactly what i see when you
talk about robinson
and dealing with the injuries that he
dealt with last year and then travis and
tien as well uh coming off some injuries
you gotta have multiple backs
in today's nfl and the jacksonville jack
jaguars did that with snoop connor and
they i i would assume they envisioned
themselves being in red zone situations
a lot this year with the talent that
they've acquired in free agency
particularly on the perimeter and then
they got a guy in trevor lawrence who is
really really good y'all when he's
protected and he's comfortable in the
pocket he can throw it he can run it now
you bring in snoop connor to bring an
addition to the red zone value as well
as some short yard third down uh be a
short yard third down type of a back as
well uh snoop connor will have an
opportunity to go to jacksonville to
compete all right i like it plugging in
snoop connor into a getting a little
busy backfield in jacksonville but
there's a place for him right now as we
keep the picks moving right here the
dallas cowboys are back on the clock set
earlier on the show think they'd dive
back into that offensive line well for
depth and development they'll take matt
well let's go uh from north dakota so
dallas
kind of going the project route tackle a
couple times i think tyler smith might
play guard for them here now
a north dakota player i think with his
height felder i look at him and
being six foot eight 312 pounds a great
athlete one of the best testers we've
had at the tackle position
36-inch arms the arms are down to the
ground all the length is there we talked
about with um cordell volson earlier
he's going to kick inside this guy seems
to me like a long-term tackle project
he's going to stay outside yeah the
length is what is going to keep him out
there now the question is does he
develop into that and that's going to be
the key he has to develop into it to
make those plays and that's what you're
looking forward to watching can he do
that can he develop into the guy that
has
uses that length to his own advantage
that's going to be the key it reminds me
of what stone forsythe was going through
that's exactly what we that's uh yes
yeah 68307
you love the size you love the length
but when rushers get under you are they
gonna be able to push you because you're
really tall and light a little light in
the pants exactly and that's the part
getting bigger in your lower half is
gonna be really important all right so
keeping this moving here we've had
another pick roll in and it's a fun one
talked about how the browns might be
looking running back earlier in this
draft because kareem hunt is a free
agent after the year
nick chubb obviously the standout player
there and they do take a running back
they take jerome ford from cincinnati
alabama transfer and i say we dive into
the jerome ford tape a little bit on
this one yeah jerome ford obviously a
transfer from alabama goes to a
cincinnati program that was on the rise
michael felder what i love about this
guy is he's got the home run hitting
ability in this draft not a lot of
running backs have the breakaway speed
there's plenty of runs where he can
break away you see the ability to take
on contact and keep the legs churning
down the field whether it was high
contact whether it was low contact plays
with an edge i think he's got some juice
as a pass catcher as well but that's
straight line breakaway speed for
cleveland this is a team that we know
what they are they are outside zone
there do you have the juice to get
outside plant your foot in the ground
find the hole and get downhill that's
what jerome ford does really really good
value in this situation he was one of my
favorite running backs in this class he
was a top 10 back for me uh this is an a
minus for cleveland this is a roster
that understands how to find value in
the backfield and they've done it again
yeah i i look jerome ford can play this
dude is a beast like he is someone that
he we talk so much about desmond ritter
we talk so much about alec pierce we
talked so much about cincinnati's
defense ford kind of get lost scott lost
in the wash but he was a big part of the
reason that engine went he is someone
again he's a downhill runner and he
looks for space so that he can turn on
those jets he's got great speed i'm
going to go a-plus here because what you
get is a guy that can step in and
contribute immediately you don't need
him to do a lot he can help you in the
backfield he can help you out of the
backfield excuse me as a pass catcher
which means he can get on the field more
than just as a running back don't know
that he's great in pass pro but he's
very good at catching out of the
backfield which means hey guess what
you're gonna have to cover him with your
linebacker which means you can't add him
to your pass rush that's a positive for
him and then when you watch him run
through tackles and then the balance
that he brings we talk so much about
vision we talk so much about breakaway
speed we talk so much about burst we
need to talk more about balance with
running backs his balance his contact
balance is amazing guys when guys start
pecking at your legs and get a little
chip on you a lot of guys have the
tendency to kick their own heels a lot
of guys have a tendency to stick their
foot in the ground and fall he's able to
find a way dance around spin himself
around and stay on track and continue to
pick up yardage all right tori holt this
was a guy that i outlined as he can hit
the home runs for you if you give him
the space what'd you see with jerome
ford on film i i have the same thing
written down right here as well home run
speed for sure he's a pass catcher and
what he can do too he can provide some
more versatility in the offense you just
sprayed him out wide now you take a
linebacker out of the box it's a more
favorable box for for uh for deshaun
watson to operate under and then when
you look at nick chubb and kareem hunt
that he'll be behind he'll be able to
learn how to play the running back
position in that football league at a
very high level behind these two really
good running backs but i love the speed
and i love the pass catching versatility
that he brings to the browns great stuff
yeah we're excited to watch him in that
cleveland offense just seems like a
tailor-made fit uh player comp for me
guys lamar miller uh that's who i see in
him yeah i think that similar guys that
have breakaway speed so the clock is
rolling on and we are going to break
down the very next pick it is zion
mccallum from sam houston state going to
the bucks we've talked about it on the
show a lot todd bowles one of the best
at developing defensive packs in the
trap
this is a guy with all of the traits in
the world you want to talk about a
bigger corner he's taller than six foot
he's
about six foot two and an eighth 200
pounds he's got incredible speed guys
four three three wheels 40 inch vertical
it's all there the three cone in the
98th percentile you see that change of
direction you see the ability he can
open up his hips he can run laterally he
can run down the field i think it's the
green light's still coming on playing at
sam houston state i know he started a
lot of football games he's not coming in
to play right away tampa's loaded at
corner but when you look at the roster
they have a lot of free agents after
2023 so this is somebody that's going to
be on your kick coverage team he's going
to be on your punt coverage team because
he could fly down the field he's got the
size and strength to win down the
sideline but maybe in 2023 you actually
see some cornerback reps for me so this
is the kind of player that i value on
day three sure an elite athlete an
important position but he can give you
something right now because a special
team so i go with an a here for the
bucks i love this kind of selection yeah
no i love the selection too when i look
at him play i see a guy with the same
length listen he's kind of fits into
that tariq woolen camp yes where he's
someone with great length good size he's
a little more sturdy than woolen coming
in right at 200 pounds i think he's
someone that wants to fire off and make
plays he's a good tackler i love that
about his game so the big the big key
for me is going to be how does he fix
the next thing how does he handle
oh how does he handle the next
how does he handle things at the next
level when does he transition into
playing at that quarterback spot i'm
also going to go with an a look the
bucks are in win now mode so if you can
get good special teams play out of him
and ultimately the reality of it is if
you can get him to not have to worry
about everything else because we've got
our the rest of our defense set what i
need you to worry about is getting uh
getting our special teams right being a
star on our four cores if you can do
that we can take you far and we'll work
during practice off season on getting
you ready to take over at a cornerback
position yeah and it's all there on tape
plenty of reps on field goal block team
punt cover team he's got legitimate reps
there at college and once again type of
athlete you could develop tory holt
there's no way around this guy's a freak
show on the track and if you can tap
into some of those traits he could be
something else
absolutely six 299 pounds and what i
like when you look at the tape very
impressive as a gunner on the punt team
very yeah very impressive i play with a
guy by the name of tony horn played at
clemson university he was a wide
receiver he was a fantastic guy in a
slot run after catch ability tough as
nails but we put him out there the
gunner position tony horn we put him out
there at the gunner position he wrecked
havoc that's where zion mccullum can
provide value for the bet for the tampa
bay buccaneers is being really special
on special teams and really really
dialing into developing as a corner at
the next level but his special teams
right away should take notice
i like it yeah i'm a big fan of this one
of the better value ones as well so
let's reset here
and let's take a look at the big board
for some reason jamari sawyer's still
there felder and i think that's really
stupid we'll see how long it takes here
malcolm rodriguez i'm not surprised
short-armed linebackers just there's
certain
thresholds that the league does not like
i value the player as a starting caliber
player in round three we sit here in the
middle around five he's still on the
board king's landing neck barre kyran
williams we've talked about talking
about some of the guys that are starting
to sneak in on the back end there felder
uh jeffrey gunter a good athlete from
coastal carolina sneaking into the
graphic now we're still waiting on
verona mckinley as well rasheed walker a
little bit of a developmental tackle but
he's also got some nasty tape against
the run oh yeah a lot of good players
there on the board obviously we've got a
couple of pixels that have just come in
uh we've got seattle taken tyreke smith
which is an interesting one he's listen
not as productive as some of the other
defensive ends from ohio state but
certainly someone that was a leader on
that football team someone that can make
plays so we'll see where he shakes out
and how they get him used uh there's a
lot of good players still in this
drought that's the scary part if we look
at the big board and you look at
felder's favorites by the way shout out
to arkansas fans i got it fixed now john
ridgeway baby i was early this morning
when i wrote jason we got it john don't
worry about it baby lucita smith ty
chandler sincere mccormick we'll see if
we can get some of these guys off the
board here soon uh because but remember
we're doing the fifth round we've still
got six and seven to get these guys off
the board too yeah plenty of time for
these guys uh and just because we're
higher on them doesn't mean that they're
not gonna make it in the league so look
at it loving this draft day coverage in
the palm of your hand our show is
sponsored by
rocket mortgage they've also made it
possible for you to get a home loan
right here on your phone with a process
built around your needs when you need a
home loan that fits you
rocket cap
all right let's keep this thing moving
we got to catch up on some picks right
here because this thing starts the fly
we did zion mcclellan talked briefly
about tyrique smith going to seattle
getting some edge pass rush help a place
they have double dipped into this draft
eric johnson from missouri state i'm
glad to see him come off the fifth round
here i thought it was one of my dark
horse players that might not get drafted
he goes to the colts he can rush the
passer what's he gonna play i think he's
gonna play three tech
on third and fourth downs okay okay
there we go rush from the interior let's
talk about eric johnson um then because
he's a player that i think a lot of the
audience might not be familiar with and
when you look at him
he's somebody in this draft that maybe
people weren't ready to hear his name
called uh today and i'm trying to bring
up the notes here as we get into some
b-roll you're going to see some missouri
state b-roll redshirt senior about 300
pounds 48640 guys i mean this is a big
man that can fly and when you look at
the tape sure there's not a ton of sacks
there on film uh to me one of the
biggest nfl combine snubs very very
athletic and he gets off the ball and
when you're 300 pounds and you can get
off the ball and you can run you're
going to wreak havoc against guards and
centers that strictly can't keep up with
you so i was very impressed felder his
ability to rip through double teams and
shout out to our bleacher report edit
team for having highlight package for
eric johnson from missouri state
excellent job this was one of my
sleepers in the draft this is what ed
dodds and chris ballard do over there in
indianapolis they go find these guys
that people don't value the same way so
you're looking at a third down pass rush
specialist on the inside i think you're
asking to play the run earlier you're
saying keep it simple pin your ears back
get up field beat the guard or center in
front of you we think you're going to
get those one-on-one options so i like
eric johnson a lot this is a b for me
and it's cool to see him go in the fifth
round oh he's a good player and i think
the key for me is the the idea of him
being just a pastor specialist but also
being asked to penetrate penetrate
penetrate penetrate don't try to lock
out and wrestle around with the guard
they're going to beat you every time
find ways to get penetration i i'm going
to go ahead and throw my grade up on
this too i think it's a b minus i think
he's someone that certainly has the
ability we just got to watch him watch
him might be a red shirt you're a two
bingo watch him watching him grow and
develop into a player
all right um so keeping things moving we
saw the colts take eric johnson the
chargers back on the clock and i believe
they have made the pick here as we go to
otito
obonya is who they took from ucla
another defensive tackle off the board a
little bit different of a player than
eric johnson fell there i think this guy
to me he's going to live in the inside
like eric johnson but i think you could
play him over the nose think you'll play
shade nose and you're going to say stuff
the run keep it real simple for him so
you're going to see the package here
tito ebonya right here playing nose
tackle and you see him get up field
there and that's an impressive rep you
see the light feet to get up field but
his ability to to gap his ability to
take on blockers open up rush lanes for
the linebackers behind him is what is
going to be his nfl role at the next
level and there's just we've talked
about it in this draft over and over
again there's not a lot of guys that
carry that kind of weight can move the
way they can but also have the strength
to contain the blockers in front of them
not get washed out against the run and
that is the play right there that you
you're talking about eat the space drive
the garter center back make the running
back redirect and let somebody else get
the stat sheet he's okay with that so
for this one for me uh this is pretty
good value here this is a class overall
that we've seen evaporate for the most
part a very
base down roll first and second down run
defender for me so this is where they go
in the draft i'm gonna go with the b
minus in this spot yeah i listen the
thing with artito is you're watching a
guy who i don't think he there's that
much difference between him and neil
farrell that's what i think i totally
agree that's the reality for me i'm
gonna go with a b plus because there's
value here he is someone that you just
want first out one first and second down
again and we're talking about this the
athleticism is there for him he's shown
the athleticism the ability to move same
thing with neil farrell the big key here
is because we have these monsters jones
and davis run sub five now all of a
sudden people don't think that what he's
doing at five at 3 25 5 running 531 is
special and it is it's remarkable to see
a guy carry the weight that well look at
him push the pocket push the bat push
the center back into the backfield he
can push the pocket in the pass game he
can do all those things this guy's a
fighter and he sticks to the interior he
is a true nose he can play that shade he
might be able to play a three if you if
you are in a heavy package but he can
get the job done i think that this is
one of those guys that just he reminds
me he reminds me of my old teammate
cam thomas i believe from unc played for
the played for the steelers for a little
while and he's just the guy that could
get good push in the interior could
anchor well and wouldn't get pushed out
of the way when it came time to
submarine he was able to clog things up
he got all that stuff done
all right i like it michael felder all
right keep it moving we have another
defensive pick before we do that let's
take a look at the chargers and what
they have done
in this nfl draft so far it's been
exciting then we've heard staley talk
about it a lot they're looking to retool
on defense they got guard help early on
with zion johnson and then you see the
jt woods pick a guy with ball skills for
the back end isaiah spiller give them a
little more power in the run game and
then otito obonya the defensive tackle
that's going to play early downs for
them maybe help out joey bosa maybe help
out khalil mack get them in those
one-on-one situations take up a lot of
space in the middle who which team are
we talking about right now
chargers defense the chargers defense oh
they're draft as a whole well they
picked up they picked up a safety in jt
woods isaiah spiller they've they went
and got otto obaniya so if we're looking
at the charges and what they need i mean
can we pull up their we pulled up their
draft needs already this is a team that
what are they going to do do they go get
more edge do they go get what can they
do to get help yeah i mean you could
take a developmental pass rusher right
now and they made they they obviously
they're going to be back on the clock
eventually but obonya i think helps the
middle of them let's move on right
they've done they've done interior
defensive line they've done they've
addressed some of the offensive line and
this they're not going to get real
offensive line help right now anyways no
and they've got zion johnson and this is
a team that wants to win right now so do
you go get weapons or do you get more
position or schematic players
defensively that can help out derwin
james and the rest of that team and
we're going to go to tory holt for that
exact question uh tito obonya tori ho
coming off the board beefing up the
chargers defensive line
oh obonya i like it and when i look in
and the reason why i like it when i look
at the la charges and i look at their
depth chart with joey bolson
austin johnson joe sebastian joseph day
jerry tillery uh khalil mack then you
look then you think about chris rump the
second fourth round draft pick in last
year's draft i mean this is now you add
a bonus now you you we're talking about
adding depth here in these later rounds
the los angeles chargers certainly did
that with avonya bringing him in and his
in his ability to get up the field from
the interior quarterbacks don't like
defensive tackles that can get to them
really quick quickly and this guy has
the opportunity this guy has the skill
set to be able to do that all right so
another good pick for the chargers in
that spot um let's keep things moving
here we have a couple picks rolling
let's go to demarco jackson from saints
an app state linebacker we've talked
about it a lot on this show um that
they're lighter lighter linebackers is
where the nfl is going guys they play
around 230 pounds built in the mold
almost of strong safeties i think
demarco jackson what i think of right
away michael felder is a dude that can
run and chase for days four five five
wheels he can get to the sideline
against uh running backs he can cover
them out in the flats i think he can run
the scene with tight ends and i think
that's how he stays on the field i like
him a lot listen shout out to north
carolina app state quality football
program you know that he's well taught
and the big king the big key for me is
the way that he runs he runs silent to
silent exceptionally well he chases guys
down he makes plays he does all those
things that you ask a guy to do and he's
going to consistently do it i love the
fact that he is a rel he's relentless in
pursuit and that's something that gets
guys down on the ground but it's also
something that gets your football team
off the field so maybe you have him as
your third down backer he can be that
but i also think that he's going to grow
into someone that you can't take off the
field once you get him on the field i
think he stays on the field and starts
out helping you on your four course
becomes a third down backer and then
he's going to grow into a role as an
every down back as he sizes up into the
nfl all right tori holt i know you have
some thoughts on demarco jackson app
state standout linebacker with speed
what do you think here
yeah you just heard michael mention the
the the job that that they're doing
at app state and developing these
players shouts out to coach head coach
sean clark and the job that they're
doing uh but i i like uh this this this
pic of demarcus demarco jackson he's a
team captain
he shines on special teams and again
yeah we're talking about players being
drafted at these spots and what they
have to provide
special teams is one of them he's a guy
that shined on special teams and then
connor you mention it the sideline the
sideline speed and anticipation is there
so new orleans
they uh
they defensively they got some talent on
the deep inside the ball they bring in
more with the marco jackson and then
they bring in a guy that can shine on
special teams all right i like it
keeping things the board is flying right
now guys we had two picks back to back
we're gonna break down i think the
second one the first one was the broncos
at 162 taking montreal washington wide
receiver from samford a bit of a
surprise yeah for me to not make my top
300 he does have returner experience
he adds some return versatility and some
good speed yeah to me that's a
particular selection looking to help
your special teams at late in the fifth
round the broncos are a team that can
afford to do that and then kyle phillips
the slot ride receiver from ucla comes
off the board he's had a pretty nice
process and we know tennessee uh was
looking to add to the back end of the
wide receiver room there so kyle
phillips
the classic case of he's not big
he's not fast nope and he finds a way to
get open always he's always open that's
the big thing with kyle phillips he's
always open this guy is
i mean it's between him and dulcetch
they found a way to get open so kyle
phillips headed to the tennessee titans
and what you're seeing is a guy that
just finds ways to get open after this
is against lsu remember an lsu team that
had multiple defensive backs taken in
this draft and he's just able to get the
job done here there's a chuck and duck
from uh from his quarterback and he's
still gonna concentrate make a play see
him there kept fielding the punt going
the other way with it he's a weaver he's
not going to set you up with a juke like
a devin hester but he sees daylight runs
to where his jerseys are and finds ways
to generate big plays i like kyle
phillips a lot i think he's someone that
finds space on the football field i
think that at this point in the draft
you've got to call this at least a solid
b at minimum because he's someone that's
going to be open someone's going to be
consistent he has low expectations but
he
people will have low expectations for
him but he has high expectations for
himself does that make sense totally it
absolutely does it's somebody that i
know he had a good shrine week so he's
had a good process throughout i think my
only question here is guys if you were
looking for a slot kind of player i lean
towards the more dynamic athlete in beau
melton that's my that's the one thing
here i'm a little disappointed beau
melton is still on the board he's a
better tester i thought he was a better
player on tape ruckers was an abysmal
offense and could not find a way to get
him for football and that's not his
fault uh but kyle phillips i do like
what felder's talking about where you
know he's gonna come in he's gonna make
the catches and he can work the slots so
for me right here this is a c-plus just
because i'm a big bull melton fan i
always go to bat for my guys that are
higher i gotta be honest with the board
tori ho kyle phillips from ucla nice
player what do we think here
yeah nice player man and you know i i
think he'll he'll have a role being
being able to play over the middle of
the football field you heard michael
mention how he just finds a way uh to
contin to consistently get open uh he'll
be asked of that and then two what value
can he bring uh to special teams as well
that'd be that'll be something uh for
him but he understands leverage he knows
how to gain separation does a good job
of that consistently doing that and then
return ability special teams ability
also will be a big factor for him going
forward awesome all right i think we're
going to see a lot of wide receivers
come off the board here uh before we are
off the clock in the fifth round you see
the titans draft here
listen i know titans fans are probably
down and out that they traded aj brown
this is still a fun future mize trailing
burks obviously on offense malik willis
down the road asana askins the power
back
tennessee
tennessee this draft tells you
everything that tennessee wants to be
they want to be physical yes they want a
bully roger mccreary even yeah
it's the mike rabel identity yeah that's
that's the big key and i love that and
you're gonna love this pick that the the
chargers looks like i guess the chargers
traded up for this pick you're gonna
love this pick so let's go ahead and
let's let's get it ready to rock and
roll let's get the ram excuse me the
rams the why did i write charges oh la
yeah rams rams okay they need to change
the logos change some colors um we're
doing this pick just so everybody knows
because this pick is freaking awesome
there we go i'm ready to rock and roll
whenever you are all right let's take it
away uh for some reason one of the more
overlooked players in this draft maybe
it's because he didn't test well i'm not
sure when you look at kyron williams
running back from notre dame going to
the rams the rams who traditionally
trade all their picks well one of the
ones they kept very very late in the
draft pick 164. this guy as michael
felder says is a football player that's
what he does i don't care that he didn't
run fast in the track i don't care that
he's small he has excellent contact
balance he has excellent vision he's a
team leader he is despite his size the
best pass protecting running back in the
entire draft he's got natural hands he's
a safety outlet look at him right here
get out in the flat make a move get into
the end zone i'll bully you to the pylon
that's fine he's a tough guy he's a
tough guy it's he's he is a fool he
fools people in a sense of you look at
him and you expect nothing and he's so
much better than all of that because
he's so smart he's so strong the low to
the ground running style is excellent uh
this is incredible value i cannot
emphasize this enough and i throw up the
a-plus now to not waste any one more
time before michael felder jumps in here
93rd overall player it's just the
classic case we saw this with michael
carter last year he made to the fourth
round because he didn't test very well
and he's small guess what he gets on the
field nobody cares about any of that
he's not small he's short but he is not
small
he's someone that once he gets that full
head of steam he's tough to tackle i
give it an a plus as well uh this is
someone that watching him play he's a
little uh he's a little he's a little uh
pinball this is someone that bounces off
people again he's got great play balance
great contact balance bounces off people
good vision to see in zone schemes he's
going to press in lead lead runs he's
going to get up on those guys right on
right up on their butts and then he's
going to be able to cut off with him
once the blocker once the defenders
overcommit and his blockers can get it
get out of his way he's going to do
those things can catch it in the
backfield but i love him in pass pro
this guy will stick his nose in there he
will anchor he will collis he will he
will take two steps in collision the
linebackers got eight steps on him and
he will make that linebacker wear it i
love that that's why it's an a plus all
right a plus for me a plus from felder
torrey holt kyron williams to the super
bowl champion rams here
pretty dang good man what do we think
yeah it is man really really good pick
for the for the rams when you think
about uh the style of runners uh that
they have with cam acres and and uh and
henderson and then sony michelle of last
year and
natural hands as michael mentioned good
at pass pro you need to do that because
you gotta you gotta protect matthew
stafford because we know what he can do
with the football when he's protected
and have time to throw it
and then he's been a team captain yeah i
know he's five nine but this dude man
is a workload like he loves carrying the
load he did it when he was there in
notre dame as you can see here the
patience and the speed and the ability
to finish runs um he's a willing uh as
as you guys mentioned he's willing
blocker uh very talented and what i love
mostly
he's a saint louis kid i played 10 years
in st louis so i know how tough those
kids are in st louis the relay rams are
getting a tough
really good football player a team
captain a guy that i think will fit the
culture very well awesome can't wait to
see kyron williams on the rams and he's
gonna have a roll right away don't mix
it up folks just because he was drafted
this way in the draft he could be on the
field from third down from the second he
walks into mini camp not training camp
so let's reset here let's take a look at
the big board right you see it right
here jamari cellular we've been talking
about it kyron williams was uh right
there on the the fifth player on the
left he's gone he's gone now over there
carson's strong obviously the last
quarterback on the board that we think
will get drafted today dominique
robinson the edge from miami ohio from
mckinley one of felder's favorites beau
melton i'll keep saying it best slot
safety on the board right available here
jeffrey gunter bring some pass rush
juice
all right let's reset here
felder
i think we should kick back to felder's
faves uh one more time as well because i
do think before we get out of the fifth
round we'll have one of those guys come
off the board we've talked about sawyer
you talk about verone mckinley a lot
getting away from those two guys felder
is there somebody we waited on the kobe
dean a lot who's the guy besides
mckinley and sawyer on the right side
over here that you're looking to come
off the board i think ty chandler i like
that yeah i think i'm gonna go ty
chandler because we just saw karen
williams come off the board i think
chandler is uh kind of little not as not
quite as skilled in pass pro but
somebody that is a little more that is
skilled in catching the ball in the
backfield and he's a quality runner of
the football so i think chandler's
probably might be the next guy off the
board if for out of that felder faves
all right we've had another pick come in
the minnesota vikings were on the clock
and they took minnesota defensive
lineman assaisee odamawo so asezi mota
omego comes off the board richard senior
six foot five 285 pounds good length off
the board here kind of a depth pick for
a minnesota team that has invested a lot
of uh capital into the defensive line i
mean danielle hunter zadaria smith i
believe they've had a pretty deep uh
draft class as well and the bengals will
be on the clock right now
yeah bengals traded to get this pick so
their picks in i'm very curious to see
where odama will what would he play me
too because he we've had this
conversation many times in this league
when you're 280 pounds you're a tweeter
you're a twinner there's no way around
de marvin liao yes uh the guy we thought
about in that regard so he's kind of in
that next mold of that so be curious do
you see do you bulk them up should you
try to get into 295
give them as a traditional three tech or
even a base three four defensive end or
is he guy that's gonna slim down and be
a prototypical edge rusher and develop
behind a denial hunter kind of player
where he's granted that time to do so
yeah well we got a guy we got your guy
the bengals pick tyson anderson awesome
pick safety from toledo yeah we're
definitely going to break this one down
one of the most versatile players in and
they're moving up for him so and as our
guys said there hold on to your butts
jordan schultz says they're taking tyson
anderson
this is somebody to me that had been
overlooked throughout the process for a
long time we are going to break down
this pick tyson anderson strong safety
kind of a slot corner as well from
toledo and man big time football player
right here okay six foot two 209 pounds
33 inch arms ran in the four threes that
six six four three cone three time
captain three-time captain he has been
the dude at toledo for a long time you
look at this special teams experience
over 800 snaps on special teams they've
used them at both safety spots felder
slot corner in the box they'll put them
right on the line of scrimmage yeah and
say
nose to nose with the big boys we trust
you he's the guy he's everything he's
got the alpha mentality he plays every
single position on defense he wanted to
play linebacker he can gain 10 pounds
and play linebacker you wanted to play
safety he could be a big slot to me he's
a match-up player against tight ends
that is going to be a superstar on
special teams i love what the bengals
got here they got one of the most
valuable players for me left on this
draft board player 133 we are at the end
of the fifth round in the 160s this is
an a plus this is the kind of guy that
you get on day three small school highly
productive three-time three-year team
captain yeah i love the three-year team
captain i love the fact like even
watching the clips you see him playing
down in the box i love that i'm gonna
give it a b-plus i think that he is a
quality guy i think he is a scheme fit
guy specifically because i do think he's
at his best coming down not going
backwards and that is a very specific
safety that you're looking for he's
someone that can line up as a linebacker
i think he would be great if the team
plays anything especially early on if
you're play if you're in goal line if
you're playing cover zero it's very easy
to get him in there you're locked up on
the titan and once the titan blocks you
come in and add to the run fit so he can
do all those things the big thing i'm
looking for out of him is what he looks
like in coverage against some of these
super athletic tight ends that's what i
want to see because charlie kohler or
isaiah likely or any of those guys when
they get the chance to leak out and go
make a play and he's red run and then
has to redirect what does that look like
on the field and how does he handle that
because these guys they're not just big
they're all so fast yeah you know what
felder i like the chess matchup right
we're seeing in the afc north and i know
tori's going to jump in here in a second
a ton of tight ends in this division you
have to deal with pat friarmouth do you
have to deal with all the guys on the
ravens right now tyson anderson can
probably handle that role tori what do
you think here when you see a chess
piece defender on the back end like
tyson
yeah and what you just mentioned connor
when you think about all of the tight
ends that has been added to this
conference and you got to be able to
somebody's got to be able to couple a
couple of those guys yeah um and i think
tyson anderson certainly can do that he
can play as you all have mentioned he
can play every position on the defensive
side of the ball and you pair him up
with jesse bates and then they took
jackson hill in the first round you got
eli apple and he got mike hilton hilton
as well back there so he's got some guys
that he can learn from and contribute to
this defense um because he can do so
much he adds so much to to what you can
do uh defensively so i like it i'm
looking forward to watching him battle
with these tight ends in this division
all right you heard it from tory holt
you heard it from felder tyson anderson
one of the one of our favorite picks of
the entire fifth round so far with that
being said we'll take a mini break and a
little reminder from our friends at
rocket mortgage
this crazy suit can give me an edge oh
yeah huge edge
invisibility gives aaron donald an edge
on his game who hit me just like a
verified approval gives you an edge on
your offer i did when you need a
competitive edge in a housing game
rocket cam there you go let's
yeah let's take a look here duron bland
comes in to the dallas cowboys the
corner from fresno state uh we're not
going to grade this pick but i will give
a quick low down and i'll toss the
felder feller to me size he's got speed
found the football yes that excites me
in the fifth round when you have a guy
that has size speed maybe
you know you don't see the tape size
against the highest level of competition
playing at fresno all the time but i
think it's going to translate because he
found a way to make plays on the ball
yeah i like i like the size the size and
the length are very important the big
key for me is that he also was he's a
guy that transferred into fresno state
so he played a lot of a lot he's played
a lot of football um he play so the big
thing that he does is he's been around
multiple schemes been around different
types of players been around been around
basically just he's been around so the
big key for me is a guy that starts out
in the fcs and then transfers up to fbs
going to fresno state fresno state's
defense was nasty those guys really got
the job done made big plays found ways
to be disruptive
yes played very fast and he's got long
arms the long arms obviously are what
led him to get into the pass lane he is
so capable and i think he's someone that
is going to be a surprise when you get
into camp he's going to surprise some of
the vets at wow okay this is what
they're teaching you out there in the
valley
all right so matt eberflus obviously um
uh back on the clock here for the bears
as the bears might look to shore up more
of that defense but we're gonna look at
the cowboys right here the cowboys have
had a really interesting draft starting
with tyler smith offensive lineman from
tulsa sam williams pass rusher jalen
tolbert i think can play right away at
wide receiver jake ferguson called
dalton schultz 2.0 matt well let's go a
developmental offensive lineman and now
duron bland the corner out of fresno
state so for dallas right now they've
lost some guys in free agency they've
had to make some cap cuts now they're
looking to replace them with the deep
draft here felder feller what you look
at the board right there for dallas what
stands out to you
i like sam williams tyler smith is going
to be an interesting prospect because
they developed offensive linemen
exceptionally well and then obviously
deron bland is someone that i think
they've got an opportunity to give him a
give him a little bit of time but i
wouldn't be surprised to see him playing
obviously special teams but some
significant actual snaps this year
because of the length and because of the
ability to get three corners four
corners out there on the field because
of the way that teams things if you get
five wide why not have him in the game
as part of your dime package
i'm with you all the way um it
definitely space for him in that
secondary
to find a way to get on the field so the
bears are on the clock right now we are
waiting for the pick to come in you see
the draft recap here we had kyron
williams finally come off the board and
the bears take a developmental offensive
lineman in braxton jones from southern
utah so
we've talked about the bears in the
offensive line for a long time here
felder i think this is to me a more
developmental purely um he is probably
not ready to play right away here in
braxton jones he was a senior bowling
fight there have been eyes on this guy
for a long time he's got long arms and
he can move that's the two things that
stand out to me now the refinement and
pass protection and we're gonna take a
look at braxton jones right here you see
him playing a left tackle southern utah
the notable thing for me right there
guys out of the stands how quickly can
you shoot out of the stance when you're
over 300 pounds can you get yourself
into position where you're a step ahead
of the defensive end and you seem to be
able to wash somebody down i mean his
ability i think to move felder is what
stands out to me sure hand placement
probably needs a little work i think you
get a little stronger in that lower half
he's kind of got that dancing bear
mentality for me so with the bears here
they needed offensive line help i would
have liked them to address this early
but the value checks out player 172 for
me fifth round grade we are at a pick
right in that 170 range so this is a b
for me the bears needed offensive line
help he needs time i don't want to see
him thrown into the fire he's not ready
to be out on the field right yet but
it's a 2023 uh developmental pick he can
work in pass pro i think that's the big
thing for him is he's very good in
passport and i think
i want to see him get stronger through
the bottom when you pull as a guy in his
position you're supposed to knock the
guy down you're supposed to push the guy
back not have the guy shock you and yes
there's still a hole there it's a
positive run play but you are supposed
to make him go backwards that's the
whole goal here so i want to see him get
stronger in the bottom half to be able
to move these bodies because it's going
to be nfl bodies that you're trying to
move and that's not easy to do so that's
the big key for me with him i think that
watching him play you mentioned
developmental i think the bears
obviously are going to put try to keep
him at tackle and grow him into a
developmental position
grow him into the position so he can be
a replacement long term the big key is
going to be how he takes the coaching
and how he takes to the nfl strength
program so that he can grow as a player
i think this is a b i think the big key
is going to be
the only reason i'm not going to give it
a higher grade because i do like the
player is i don't know if they're in a
position to be building depth although
the reality of it is they are in the
position to be building death because
it's not like they're going to win right
now all right i want to get into the
next pick because it's an exciting one
and the minnesota vikings
got a little bit of a depth piece that
we're excited about behind alvin cook
michael felder ty chandler comes off the
board
faves
list felder break it down minnesota
vikings outside zone scheme welcome in
ty chandler here we go man this is great
this is a great pick for them this is a
guy both at tennessee and at unc we saw
him be explosive look at him here
pushing wide push wide and then see the
hole and explode through it he can get
the job done he is someone that is
patient and explosive he is willing to
get to the sideline you see him there
punishing guy by finishing off the run
against the u look at this little speed
on the flip outside to get to the to the
pylon before anybody else he's also
someone that can catch the ball out of
the backfield he is a little hide and
seek running back and that's one of the
things i like about him right you see
him he looks like he's sprinting far
wide and then you over pursue he's got a
foot in the ground and he's getting back
inside of you so for me lawson what am i
going to do i got to give this one right
here
yeah he's a felder fave i got to give it
an a he's going to fit into what they do
he's gonna be he's gonna be welcome
addition to that to that um running back
room so i'm gonna go three quick things
from uh because we wanna hear from tory
holt three quick things from me here
with ty chandler the four three eight
wheels pass catching with gas catch the
ball get up field not catch the ball
look around what am i going to do catch
the ball get up field and make plays
special teams contributor yes this is
what you need in the fifth round you
want to stick on a roster you got to
play special teams uh this is a b plus
for me a player that maybe is it a
little early a smidge early for me but i
love the fit i love him in a wide zone i
love what he can do on special teams
from minnesota i love the straight gas
speed tory holt hearing a lot of praise
for me and michael felder i heard a lot
of praise from you about this guy before
we even went on what do you got for us
yeah again i was fortunate i live here
in acc country so i was fortunate enough
to see ty chandler play over unc with
sam sam howell and i thought they could
have given the ball to him more yeah he
is he has that kind of ability to be uh
be productive 4-3 speed as you mentioned
patient good hands look the minnesota
vikings are trying they're adding more
offensive weapons for kirk cousins
they're going to be very dynamic out on
the perimeter obviously with justin
jefferson now you got tight chandler you
got cook in the backfield you got two
good backs that can play off of each
other but a lot of talent look at him
right there going up with the one hand
catch the concentration the ability to
play outside of the backfield tight
challenge then the patience down in the
red zone he can give you value there i
like the pick again i thought carolina
could have given it to him more
but minnesota says hey you know what
he's fairly fresh we're going to use him
as much as we can to try to help elevate
what we want to do offensively i like it
so ty chandler a felder fave a tory hope
phase here we go coming off the board to
the minnesota vikings that is a scheme
guys
that's built for his skill set yes
exactly i mean
he's not dalvin cook but they they've
run in a very similar style
yes i mean and when other guys have to
come in and play for dalvin cook they've
had success because they know how to
develop the run rush lane exactly and ty
chandler can find those so
keeping things moving the houston texans
we're back on the clock and right here
we have another tight end pick it's been
a tight end run day all day teagan
i need to really nail this last
quite a reno quitoriano quite toriano
elder
a massive tight end coming out of oregon
state a shrine bowl guy six foot five
and a half about 260 pounds
for me fell there's somebody that i do
like i think he can survive in line and
i think he can give you a little bit as
a pass catcher as well here we're late
in the draft the tight end class there's
been a significant run on it here uh for
teagan right here on the big board let's
take a look at where he's stacked up
player 220. so seventh round grade gets
a little bit of a boost because
everybody loves the tight end class here
i don't think we're going to grade this
one but what do you think of him as a
player coming out of oregon state 19
catches this season yeah but listen they
got they had other other options other
guys that were able to not a lot of
targets not a lot of targets the big
thing for me is this is a guy that you
get to move bodies he's your heavy
package tied in he's the guy when he
comes in the game the other team knows
we're meant to run the football or
if we're going to throw it it's going to
be a max protect throw and so it does
they're they're letting people know
they're signaling out the gate that this
is what this guy's going to be he's
going to be our heavy tight end and he
can do that he's a big guy 260 probably
plays even closer to 265 at the next
level so i'm looking forward to what he
brings to the table all right keeping
things moving here we have the clock
flying the denver broncos take center
luke wattenberg from washington felder
uh did not make my top centers in this
class and i did not expect him to get
drafted what did you think of juan burke
he's a watching him play this was a guy
that
played a little bit played a lot of
football excuse me and also was someone
who you watch him play he knew what he
was doing like obviously i know you
didn't have him on the board but look as
you can see this guy started started the
majority of the games i think he only
didn't start i want to say six games out
of like 54 only started only didn't
start six games played a ton of football
he is someone that he's not remarkable
from an athletic standpoint but what he
is is cons remarkably consistent
impatient he's got a great anchor you're
not going to get middle pressure on him
unless you bring an extra linebacker and
that's one of the things that i liked
about him is
if you if he can play with you
one-on-one he's gonna win that battle
enough for the quarterback to get the
ball off yeah a guy that started a
tackle started guard and then pandemic
short in season you're a center and he
took that and rode with it 2020 2021
like felder said he's played a lot of
football so the denver broncos looking
for interior help he's not going to
start for them there's more backup in it
builder maybe they like his flexibility
i know he's sub 300 pounds so usually
when you're 700 pounds the nfl level you
stick it center maybe they say hey put
the weight back on we think you could
flex guard center as well sure
all right the niners are back on the
clock at 172 here we've seen them let's
pull up the niners picks when we get a
chance here guys we'll recap their draft
it's been fascinating they are all over
here's the trap recap braxton jones ty
chandler um we've had a little mini
tight end run get a little crazy here
luke wattenberg and we have the next
pick from did the bears oh the niners
are staying there samuel womack is
coming into the picture here so
we are ahead of the tv we are ahead of
the picks that i'm following as well
here the niners
they go off the board all the time man
samuel womack toledo defensive back who
was not a combine invite uh was not a
player that was probably expected to go
early on day three a corner a little bit
of a smaller corner here but explosive
athlete my my first thought here is
felder they're looking for to develop a
long-term slot yes that's that's got to
be the only answer here he's a smaller
guy but he is quick and the big key for
me with him is how he's able to
work that but to work that inner that
that small space that bubble that exists
between the outside wide receiver and
the end on the line of scrimmage we're
operating in that small space he's a guy
that's got great short area quickness
and how womack's able to
grow into that role is going to be
critical whether it's operating from a
tough technique playing off or pushing
up to the line of scrimmage with a guy
off the line of scrimmage and finding a
way to either jump jamming or be patient
enough to mirror and then get reroutes
so that he can make that field small and
cut off those easy passes all right so
samuel womack cornerback owner toledo
the niners it's usually around that time
they take corners they're very popular
in taking day three corners developing
them the new york giants are back on the
clock at some point let's take a full
look at what the new york giants have
done because they've made a lot of picks
they came into the day they got they had
evan neal early they had came on
thibodeau early they made three picks on
day two and now michael felder we sit
here on day three and they have been
pretty busy so the new york giants you
see it right there great job guys all
over it
michael mcfadden beefing up the middle
of the defensive linebacker dj davidson
beefing up the middle of the defense at
defensive tackle cordell fla slot guy uh
wandell robinson a slot wide receiver at
gadget guy so michael felder when you
look at this board are you seeing any
kind of identity theme here with the new
york giants
pressure yep came on thibodeau
um
stout in the middle reliability of neil
with evan neal and just being stout with
neil but also dj davidson uh you also
see they're working they want to work
options
and that's what flot is a defensive
option he's a guy that can play in the
slot wandel robinson slot that's a guy
that's a gadget player now you can
create mismatches or you can create
plays that you can create misdirection
misdirection leads to both mismatches
and blown coverages and that's what
they're looking to do so looking for
areas of opportunity to make life easier
for daniel jones so that they can create
bigger plays so that he doesn't have to
go five yards five yards five yards five
years five yards all the way down the
field they want to try to create some
bigger plays and evan neal is going to
give them time
to hit those bigger plays down the field
theme of the day continues beef marcus
mckeithen is the pick for the new york
giants at guard and we are going to take
a look at this pick because this is
somebody who
made my top 300 michael felder is very
familiar with him when you look at it a
mammoth of a human being right in marcus
and for me you know six foot six 340
pounds uh
long long arms i look at this felder for
me and think he's going to be a guard in
the giant system and
dry blocking is what i think of right
away with mckeithan now i look at the
new york giants ago evan neal right
tackle uh obviously all the beefy picks
they made on the the defense as well
they're just trying to get bigger yes
bigger stronger when you look at
mckeithen right here i think of run
blocking this is a team that not has not
been able to
give saquon barkley a chance right and
this is the
second unc offensive lineman they have
taken in this draft i believe now so
what do you think of marcus mckeithen
this is a guy listen uh he's worked in
zone he's worked in man on he works but
the big key for him is push as long as
he keeps his hands inside as long as he
keeps those but that butt low those hips
low he's got the ability to move just
about anybody off the point there's good
strength there there's functional
strength there and that's going to be
the key here for the giants is they're
going to have to make sure that they
work on basic technique things to make
sure that he's not just relying on that
size that six six three forty body he
has to work on technique so that he can
get the job done but if he relies on
technique as we saw two seasons ago with
their running game as we saw a season
ago with some with with flashes in the
run game he's one of those guys that can
help open things up for for the new york
giants yeah so him in the zoo right now
uh guys that know what it's like playing
next to each other guys that know what
it's like to develop a run game together
and the giants are trying to get bigger
and stronger tori ho what are you seeing
with this giant's draft new regime what
are you seeing them trying to build
yeah i'm with you i mean you got two
teammates that are now playing with each
other and there's an emphasis for the
new york giants and i said it earlier
there's an emphasis on running the
football
and they want to make things a lot more
comfortable for daniel jones make the
passing lanes a little more clear for
daniel jones the wide receivers want to
see more favorable coverages because
they're focused on
uh protecting the box because the run
game is going well they've added more
offensive lineman the giants to this
roster because they want to control the
line of scrimmage you guys mentioned
evan neal will help them in the run game
as well as in the passing game but the
giants are saying nmces we're going to
be very very physical with big guys that
can move which gives confidence to
saquon barkley and it gives a ton of
confidence for daniel jones i like it
let's take a look at the big board right
now to see where we're at plenty of good
players left on the board um out of the
top 300 that i've written up and you see
right there we've talked about jamari
sawyer speaking of guards that can help
you develop the run game malcolm
rodriguez a guy that could be waiting a
little bit but a really really good
player on film you see dane belton there
making it onto the big board graphic
we're waiting on paul mellon carson's
strong probably the next quarterback to
be drafted a big armed quarterback
listen we have the bears on the clock
and the bears have taken dominique
robinson who is on the big board right
now coming in there
uh very successful pass rusher from
miami ohio and somebody that i'm a
little surprised he's still on the board
here so i think we could dive into
dominique robinson edge passer rusher
from miami ohio and you see him high on
the board there i mean this is somebody
that um
you know pass rush has gone really quick
117 remind me of josh sweat that's the
player comp for me i like that i dig
that yeah
he's got the skills he's got the ability
it's just about one you want to make
sure that he uses his leverage you got
to make sure that he runs the hump
that's what you want him to do you want
him running that hump to get to the
quarterback this isn't a guy and he's
going to have to run the hump early
early early early that's how he's going
to have to set up that inside move he's
gonna have to set up the inside move by
running the hump beating somebody to the
edge and that's the next step is for him
is gonna be developing more than that
pass rush move and developing some some
more strength some core strength and
some functional strength to transition
some of that speed that he brings to the
table to power yeah fastlane player
converted wide receiver to edge password
that's that's rare that's something that
you will not hear on this show you
probably won't hear on next year's show
it just doesn't happen and he succeeded
he's done it used as both a stand-up
rusher hand in the dirt he could do both
the josh sweat comparison that
explosiveness the ability to get off the
ball and dictate the rush that's what i
love about him production came from
stunts and unblock rushes that's just as
simple as exactly and that's okay he's
going to work on a two-hand swipe to me
on the outside speed that's what he does
he gets off the ball and he swipes hands
off you and turn the corner and we're
going to run the film right now on
dominique robinson and here you go
what'd i say production came off of
stunts and twists so that's the ability
to use his athleticism when you have a
guy that converted from wide receiver
you're trying to simplify things for him
to make plays on the football so
dominique robinson i am going to give
this one a great this is an a plus for
me i love the value i think he's
somebody that can come in and you can
really capitalize off that athleticism
and say hey we're going to find ways to
put you in positions where you just need
to be explosive to the football you
don't need to overthink you don't need
to read and react i think this is a
great pick for chicago yeah i think this
is i'm going to for me look at this
bears fans are going to love dominique
robinson from lancaster i think he's
going to turn out to be one of the
steals of this draft i think the key is
going to be muscling him up
and i i don't say that with any
disrespect to what he's been able to do
at miami of ohio or anywhere else but
the key is going to be
getting comfortable with being touched
all the time getting comfortable with
somebody putting hands on you and then
finding a way to get their hands off of
you being comfortable with getting to
the quarterback and being explosive
recognizing that you can make your own
hay without it having to come on stunts
as you see right here so he has to get
comfortable with all those things i
think the reality here is you see in
there lined up hand down i want to see
more of that more of this more of taking
on a block and engaging which means he
has to get stronger in those haunches
right he's got to get stronger in that
bottom part of his body but i think the
key for him is going to be muscling up
and getting use listen when you play and
i'm going to give this one a b when you
play along the front there's a humongous
difference and a lot of folks don't
think about football this way but i do
because i played safety which meant
there are a lot of plays that nobody
touched me and i'm okay with that
because i don't want to be touched but
when you play on the line and where you
play on the line it is completely
different than playing wide receiver
because on the line every play somebody
is going to be touching you and i think
for him he's got to get comfortable with
that comfortable with the lack of space
and he's going to he's he's evolving
into that and that's going to be the
point to the point where you start to
crave the contact and that's where you
can really start to operate in a phone
booth and create your setup moves all
right tori hall this is a franchise that
traded khalil mack in the off season
they are looking for a show we've heard
some rumors around about robert quinn
recently which is insane considering the
season he just had what do you think of
this selection with theirs
no i like it it's a developmental player
obviously you guys have talked about you
know transitioning from from from uh
from receiver to now playing defensive
end so he's certainly an athlete
certainly has plenty of speed six five
253 he'll have to put on some muscle for
sure and then as michael mentioned too
dealing in tight quarter spaces that's a
lot different than than being a receiver
when you're out wide and you have a lot
of space so that'll be something that
he'll continue to have to adjust and and
adapt to but when he puts on the weight
and gets stronger maybe you can kick him
inside a little bit and rush over guard
and he can use his athletic skills and
his speed and being slippery to get to
get to the quarterback but i think this
is a developmental pick certainly for
sure with dominique roberson who's a
really good athlete had a tremendous
tremendous amount of speed and it looks
like he has a really high motor
all right let's take a look at what the
bears have done in the off season so far
obviously there is hope for justin
fields in year number two and as we look
at it uh they're building through the
draft on defense for matt eberflute's
new coach new gm ryan pohl's offensive
line background you see the giraffe
right here go get yourself a corner and
kyla gordon we love the jaquan brisker
pick you've got speed at wide receiver
and special teams of bayless jones a
developmental offensive lineman braxton
jones then the developmental edge and
dominique robinson felder what do you
like on this board uh
i mean brisker obviously yeah what do
you mean you're asking me i mean i love
kyla gordon but i really love jaquan
bruce
one of my favorite uh one of my favorite
safeties on the board bayless jones is
another one a little bit earlier than we
thought he was gonna go but the reality
of it is he's someone that can help you
on special teams and then he's also
gonna give you some real actual help in
the wide receiver as a wide receiver
fields needs that feels needs protection
and he needs weapons he needs guys that
he can get the ball to that are going to
be reliable phyllis jones had a low drop
rate which is a big part of why they
picked him and again gonna help you on
special teams we talked about hidden
yardages before he's going to be able to
give you to provide a little bit in the
way of that hidden yardage in the return
game all right so we're waiting for the
raiders who are on the clock pick 175.
the last five picks are on the board
here and matthew butler the big
defensive lineman from tennessee comes
off the board this is uh key value here
for me michael felder player 149 remind
me of jeron reed and that's a compliment
in all the way i think he's strong i
think he can really control the run
this is a good pick for a raiders team
that did not have a lot of selections
and you see matthew butler right here
he's gonna be playing a lot of three
tech in college and he's gonna carry
that over to the next level a near 300
pounder that he can be explosive and get
to the quarterback and that's a bonus
for him because i think he's a very
responsible run defender as well you see
the length there with matthew butler
once again you're playing him all over
the place you see him on the outside
there kenny cut inside so matthew butler
getting the raiders the raiders needed
interior defensive line help they made
the big trade for davonte adams and it
kind of forced their hand where they
didn't have a lot of picks so they find
a way to capitalize on a guy and get
some value here a player that was a
shrine guy a five-year player in college
and a good athlete as well for mage is a
hard-working versatile defensive lineman
is he coming into being a pass-through
specialist no is he coming in and being
an only early down guy no you can rotate
him now situational it's not
situationally based and that's what i
like about math it's about giving your
other guys a break give your other guys
a break and trust the guy you're putting
on the field and with matthew butler at
tennessee you could always trust him on
the field so this is a rock solid b for
the raiders i like the value i like
addressing the need and he's one of
those guys quietly he'll be in the
league for eight years a lot of people
don't notice but he does his job yeah no
i i agree with you on that the big thing
for me coming out immediately people
start to compare them to shy tuttle
should i tell another guy from tennessee
he's a different player you watch the
tape right there shy tuttle is built
like a tank like he's he's kind of round
and he's big you look at this guy he's a
little bit more stretched out even
though he's only six three and a half
he's a little more lean carries that
weight a little differently and i love
the fact that he's got the ability to
kind of slip it and make a play you see
him there stay blocked but he condenses
the hole so that you can go make
somebody else can go make a play and
that's what i love about him he never
loses ground he always he always
condenses the hole so that he does his
job and i think that's the key to him
playing as a rotational player early is
he's going to do the job he does his job
and then you see him there in pursuit
he's going to give you effort as well i
look at what he does and you look at
what they what the what the raiders
office's off season plan was they they
lose yanukong they add devonte adams
they add chandler jones they they add
rocky sin they add guys that are going
to help them out you lose a guy like
casey hayward they've addressed a lot of
these things in the draft as well some
of those losses they've gone out they've
not got another guy that's going to be a
rotational player so for me i got to go
b-plus here i think that he is someone
matthew butler
fifth year player he's someone that
comes in he understands listen i was
never the star at tennessee i'm not
going to be the star for the raiders yep
and he's going okay with that and i'm
fine with it you know what i am going to
be i'm going to be a guy that never gets
yelled at and i listen listen can we
bring tori in because there's a lot of
value to being the guy that never gets
yelled at especially from a new england
coaching staff yeah
so yeah i would love to hear tori tori's
thoughts uh we'll get him in here in a
second you look at the raiders draft
editions here dylan parham a guy that's
probably going to play center at the
next level zamir white a power back and
neil farrell goes back to that theme of
getting a little thicker on the interior
defensive line and they followed up and
get a rotational piece of matthew butler
so the raiders looking to strike value
on the interior defensive line this was
a good time to do it i like it here and
the dallas cowboys are back on the clock
here at pick 176
and then it will be the detroit lions
the cowboys again and the packers close
out yeah let's get torrey holton here i
want to hear his thoughts on felder
saying it's great to have guys that
don't get yelled at tory holt matthew
butler goes the raiders a new england
coaching staff they like guys that are
responsible and the classic do your job
but you're mature guys you you want
mature players that can that can come in
and can adjust themselves to the way
that you do things just just themselves
to the culture immediately and guys that
are mature typically can do that so if
you are a guy that you're not getting
yelled at a lot
that means that you're doing your job
you understand what your role is you
understand your job and you're taking a
tremendous amount of pride in going out
there every single day to get it done
those are the kind of players that bill
belichick and his staff like i had an
opportunity to spend a few
months in new england before
before retiring and it is an environment
that competes you've got to know your
assignment it's about respecting your
teammates and it's respect it's about
respecting the game of football that's
what's been created there in new england
i think these guys can come in and and
fit right in right away being that they
are mature players i like it yeah it
makes a lot of sense for the raiders and
you're going to see that be a theme of
that new regime and that new coaching
staff so we had the cowboys make a pick
and it's a very classic cowboys fake
taking a linebacker taking an lsu
linebacker in demon clark one of the
more fascinating players here on day
three guys for a lot of reasons and
we're going to grade this pick
so demo clark linebacker from lsu
listen excellent speed uh he can run and
chase he's explosive he can come
downhill and make plays he was the dude
on this lsu defense besides derek
stingley and derek stanley did not play
a lot this year so a lot of it was damon
clark now he's somebody that throughout
after the testing process
it sounds like he will not be available
for the 2022 season due to surgery so
this is a classic medical draft and
stash kind of player uh for me when i
watched him on clark on tape i see third
round second round talent at times
somebody a three down linebacker that
could do it all now the medicals for
some teams he was not on every team's
board because of the the uncertainty
that he might not be able to play
football again obviously the cowboys are
okay with this in the fifth round that's
a great sign for him rooting for him and
this is one of those things where you've
moved michael parsons as he's more of a
natural pass rusher maybe after 2022 you
do have some holes at linebacker i know
you have leighton van resh on a one-year
deal you're looking for this guy can
come in and be a three-down player it's
just all about health i like taking the
gamble on the fifth round i'm rooting
for him to get right this is an a for me
yeah i like them on clark i love a
couple things that we saw in the clip we
just showed he tackles people and they
go backwards yes he listen he he does
have tremendous speed but the reality of
it is he tackles people and they go
backwards and i like to see that this is
a guy patient in coverage he's willing
willing to run and then he'll chase you
down sling it down get you down on the
ground he understands where run fits
work how run fits work and then you see
him there that's reading a play and
going to make a tackle across the field
this is against alabama him in the hole
and he's chasing down brian robinson he
gets the job done i like that about him
and by the way those of you that don't
know he's wearing number 18 at lsu
that's a big deal mean something that
means something that's that's a that's a
meaningful number for lsu fans for lsu
as a program if you get to wear number
18 guys that have worn 18 jacob hester
obviously um trey davies white those
guys when you get to wear 18 that means
you're an important part of that
football team that means you're a
captain that means you're somebody that
these guys are looking up to i'm going
to give it i'm going to give it a b plus
because of the medical yep but if he's
healthy he's someone that i really think
has an amazing amazing nfl career ahead
of him yeah so to clarify that situation
for everybody um after his mri at the
combine revealed herniated disc
underwent spinal fusion surgery at the
end of march he is expected to miss his
rookie season right but is expected to
make a full recovery he should miss his
rookie season yeah and they can afford
that at the linebacker position that's
okay for dallas as we see dallas draft
additions here it's a long list and they
are back on the clock at 178 we are
waiting for the lions to make their pick
at 177 and it is a pick and it's
somebody that the man sitting next to me
likes very much it is john ridgeway
the cowboys pick john ridgeway i believe
so we need to get the lions pick as well
james mitchell okay so virginia tech
tight end okay so james mitchell the
tight end from virginia tech are you
talking about injured guys yes mitchell
is somebody that has had to deal with
this as well so let's dive into mitchell
and then we're going to go longer on
ridgeway um it's always interesting to
me felder when a guy
in his last year of college has the
unfortunate injury obviously he the long
story short as he tours acl in september
it cost him a season and it cost him the
all-star games and this was a senior
that would have been at the senior bowl
we're talking about that kind of
catch-and-run talent uh with a big
season and a big senior bowl he would
have he could have potentially been up
there with the greg dolcich's of the
years i want to make that extremely
clear this is a top-end receiving talent
everybody comes back from acls that's no
surprise uh he's got a good catch radius
he's got a good build and as we're
seeing we got ridgeway flying we're
talking james mitchell we'll get into
ridgeway in a second felder when you
look at james mitchell take away the
tourney acl yeah what kind of player was
he i mean this is a guy that had 47
catches i believe in the the previous
two years 19 and 20. he had 47 combined
catches those years only five catches in
two games or really one and a half games
in in 2021 because of the injury lose
that season elected not to go back to
school decided this is i mean this is it
for me i'm gonna go take i'm gonna shoot
my shot and see what i can do at the
next level i'm looking forward to
watching him get healthy but you watch
him play look at him here this is a guy
runs away from people catches the jump
ball a badly a poorly thrown pass even
though he had the guy stacked poorly
thrown pass can go back and get it you
see him there big target he's got the
ability to get the job done guys about
what six three six four yeah he can run
you see that he'll miss shiftiness right
there stop on a dime and he can get the
job done so i think this is a good pick
he's someone that if you
give him an opportunity
he's going to make you pay and i think
he's a mismatch guy so for me i look at
this and obviously because of the injury
i'm going to give it the b
uh but i think
ultimately as you mentioned if he's
healthy through this year he probably
has over 30 catches he's probably more
productive they're def maybe virginia
tech's a little better as a football
team and then the reality of it is he
does get to participate in the in that
that post season pre-draft uh that
pre-drive industrial complex so
fascinating process here we have another
tight end come off the board it's been
the day of tight ends tight end tight
end tight end
felder to me i think what sticks out is
no jaylen wadimer off the board yeah
that's yes bombed the testing but this
is somebody we've been excited about
watching in college football level as a
pass catcher and a blocker for a couple
of years now
so i think that's what jumps out to me
and you see the draft recap here
a lot of tight ends here guys we had
trey mcbride jelani woods dulcetch
rucker k dotten all these guys could
block daniel bellinger charlie kohler a
little more pass catcher ferguson isaiah
likely called turner so
10 tight ends
no watermeyer yet i do think he'll come
off the board um but yeah
for for me
my favorite tight end in this group was
trey mcbride i know it's easy to take
the first guy but that's just where the
rankings stack my sl my sleeper in all
of this though in my opinion is what
jake ferguson is walking into franchise
tag dalton schultz it's a one-year deal
jake ferguson is that lighter version of
dalton schultz where he can be trusted
in line he's got surefire hands
i really really like what he can do
coming into dallas where that's an
offense that's tailor made for his skill
set in line tori hall it's been a big
day for the tight ends we've seen a
couple a ton come off the board is there
anybody you particularly like because of
the fit or just the player
yeah i can't even get through it quick
enough insane
but no but no but i was going to say
about james mitchell i like james
mitchell the kid from virginia tech he
did suffer an acl but he's 6'4 250
pounds he's a big target he can run he
can catch catch
balls on the real routes um he's a he
can set over the middle of the football
field in zone coverage i just think he's
a really really good talent i'm hoping
that he can nurse himself back healthy
because if he does he gives that that
that detroit lions offense another tight
end to go along with uh
with the guy that they have there now
i'm having a i'm having a brain for t.j
hockerson yeah so now you got a double
you know you could potentially have a
double tight end set with hopkinson and
now james mitchell that gives jared goff
plenty more weapons and then i like uh
mcbride the tight end that you mentioned
i like mcbride had a chance to see him
down at the at the combine tremendous
talent and then i also liked the kid out
of ucla to tighten out of ucla i was
looking for him greg dolces yes i had a
chance to see him at the combine and i
was
very very impressed with his physical he
is such a physical specimen specimen he
is huge great size tremendous work ethic
he's an energy guy
uh tempo you know just high tempo type
of a player so those are the two tight
ends for me that come to mind
there we go i dig it all right good
stuff from tory holt felder we got the
final two picks of the round and i think
we're to grade both of them here we got
to start with your guy john ridgway
going to dallas
talked about it earlier in the draft
needed interior defensive line help need
a true nose need a true guy uh that can
take up a lot of space and control the
point of the attack so we look at the
dallas cowboys i know we got the john
ridgway footage
let's get right into it a true nose
tackle a true zero a big guy a tough guy
something you and i have always talked
about always wants to be involved in the
play when you look at ridgeway what is
he bringing to dallas dallas getting uh
john ridgway this is a big pickup that's
why he's one of my favorite players he
he's the heart he was the heart and soul
at arkansas defense everything went
through him we talked about playing
through the middle you look at him here
playing as one of those true noses right
there look at him moving side to side
disengage go make a play he's not just
gonna eat space he's gonna eat your face
off this guy plays hard football get up
field get back downfield to go make a
tackle he is
a true true i think he's got an
opportunity to have a true impact on
this football team this season he is a
playmaker a guy that wants to disengage
to go make a tackle but also a guy that
understands his role in the defense if
you need me to occupy too i can occupy
too if you're going to let me
slip and go get the quarterback or go
get that running back i will chase that
some bee down so i love that out of him
this is an eight plus for me i gotta
give him the plus because i think one
you're getting the guy that i had ranked
a little bit earlier two you're getting
a guy that i love the way that he became
the heart and soul of that team it was a
team that had found their identity
understand pittman he's a pittman guy
and not not in the sense of the
recruiting but in a sense of this is the
type of guy that pittman wants on his
football team and he's going to be
looking for more rich john ridgeways as
the as they progress as he progresses
his career as a coach at arkansas but a
plus for me the guy can flat out play i
like it a tough guy in the middle of the
field reminded me of daquan jones
somebody that you can trust in the
middle of the field can control that
point of attack and like felder said
when they let him go a little bit he can
go make plays this is a b plus for me
for dallas player 151 on the big board
and in the sense right here they're
picking all the way down at the end of
the draft in right around 180 so a solid
solid pick for the dallas cowboys that
needed interior defensive line help and
the defensive line run
continues the final pick of the fifth
round the green bay packers finally take
kingsley and igvare and this was the top
player left on my board here at player
the 75th overall player reminds me of
chauncey gulstan from last year he wins
with length felder and he's never going
to be a bendy flexible rusher you see
him on block there coming downhill with
the big stride he's somebody that he
plays hard he knows how to use his
length to swim he knows how to use his
length to stack and shed and that's what
i like i think guys like that because
they can hang around the league for a
long time because you can trust them
against the run to set a hard edge and
you could trust them to give high effort
against it as a pass rusher so annie
barre really productive player in the
sec for a long time i think he's had an
interesting process you see him come out
of
out of south carolina and get to the
senior bowl long arms not the most
dynamic athlete but i think he's
explosive enough violent stand-up rusher
it's just he doesn't possess the change
of direction doesn't possess the bend
where you get excited about you know the
lack of twitch as a rusher is he
creative as a rusher no but he's strong
enough he's nfl strong that'll carry
over in a roll for green bay so for me
this is a value pick for me this is an a
this guy's ready to go he's done it at a
high level he's been really productive
in his role yeah i think the big thing
for me is what else can he do because
you mentioned the change of direction
i'm going to give it i'm going to give
it a b because i i i want to know what
else he can do i see him there unblocked
yeah he's great on block fantastic set
the edge against the run sure i like
that too disengage and make a play i do
like that but what else can you do for
me what else can you do can you get to
the quarterback when they when they put
somebody on you no okay
what can you is are you going to be
twitchy enough to help me on my special
teams i don't know and that's the big
reason i throw a bee on there because i
wonder what it looks like when he had
gets asked to do other things once once
teams understand oh this guy's going to
set the edge and if we don't block him
he might get to our quarterback then i
wonder what's next for him i want to see
him develop more and that's the big key
for me is the the the the future
development and what i wonder how much
more he can take on or is he maxed out
that's the biggest question for me
felder okay a already violent player
that
is sec violent i want to make sure he's
not on the fcs just beating everyone in
front of him he's done it against nfl
caliber players is there creativity
there that can be unlocked that he's not
just an average starter i think about
dante fowler
and i think about he was an incredibly
violent player yep i think he's a little
more athletic but still has had a rough
time figuring out what he actually is in
the nfl because once the power got
stopped it's almost not losing interest
but it's also what can i do what how can
i be created how do you how do you
counter how do you counter that i love
fowler coming out you know that i did
too i absolutely love it i thought it
was going to be a revolution a
revelation excuse me and then
once the power was stopped the next step
was oh no wait what do i do what now and
that's the question mark i have within
igbari
it is for me as well but obviously we're
a fan of the pick the value is
incredible top 100 player we are almost
uh through the top 200 of the nfl draft
and
we have to tell them who the first the
first pick of the sixth round was the
punk god matt ariza i don't think he
expected to be the fourth
specialist taken off the board but the
good punter the bills had a legit
punting problem last year this is
actually an a plus pick i'm not going to
do the grade we're not doing the video
we're not showing you the punk god
footage although that would be pretty
sick uh when you you know what i lied we
do have the punt god footage there is no
better way to go out than show matt
arises you see the uh the perfectly
timed kick right there inside the five
yard line hats hat tip though to the
gunners that went down and got the ball
on that one and yes folks he kicks he
kicks he's got a punt at the next level
monster monster leg
tori what do we think of the punk god
i just i love the name think about that
first round name
first round name for sure all right guys
we are going to recap what we saw in the
fifth round a lot of talent was on the
board a lot of teams capitalized off of
it it has been a fun day we saw the run
on tight ends we saw the run on running
backs um you know i'll throw it to you
like this and i'll start with you felder
and then i'll go to tori
what stood out to you today whether it
was a theme of the day at a certain
position whether it's somebody that
his name is not called or whether it was
somebody that waited too long to be
called so here's the thing and this is
these are notes so i did these notes
connor you can look at them i did these
notes these are these are my these are
the notes that i do at one o'clock in
the morning one o'clock in the morning
when i get back to my hotel room after
last night and the big thing i wrote was
what's the big what's what's the big
news that we're gonna see one running
backs we saw spiller we saw pierce we
saw algier we saw uh zamir white we saw
ford we saw um kyron williams so we saw
so running backs that's on the list yeah
i'll show you guys you you won't be able
to read the handwriting but it's all
there and then when you get to you get
to the tes why to meyer i had him first
didn't go but then we did see likely odd
and bellinger we saw kohler we saw
ferguson i also had i had safeties
mckinley and smoke versus neil tyson
anderson did go we didn't see any of
these other guys go so that's an
interesting part for me when we get to
six and seven um the other part that i
found really interesting was the tie it
was it was the quarterbacks we see zappy
go off before sam howe insane and we
still have carson strong on the board so
that's what i was thinking those were my
big takeaways all the things i thought
were going to happen they happened and
they just didn't play out the way we
thought we were going to go especially
with guys like mckinley or weidermeyer
i'm with you feller it was an
interesting day especially the
quarterbacks especially jaylen wadameyer
still on the board i want to talk to
tory ho it's been awesome having torian
tori welcome to day three of the draft
by the way
obviously a legendary wide receiver what
stood out to you today on the board
i think for me i got i got a few
highlighted here the green bay packers
taking romeo dobbs 62204 long strider
real deep speed yeah you know i know
there's been a lot of talk about devonta
adams going over to the raiders they
bring in christian watson they bring in
romeo dobbs these dudes can run aaron
rodgers can get the football to any of
these receivers anywhere on the football
field we know green bay wants to stretch
it and they got two guys legitimate guys
that can do that also the cornerbacks
man the cornerbacks to me are getting
taller six three six four and six five
these corners are getting longer and
longer you think about joshua williams
fayetteville state 63 195 goes to kansas
city again kansas city getting longer on
the edges getting more physical more
competitive on the edges i like that
receiver calvin austin iii i i went to
my buddy uh isaac bruce hall of famer to
get some more clearance to get some more
clarity on this guy and he was certainly
uh a calvin austin iii fan
4-3-2 speed these wide receivers fellas
in this year's draft can flat out run
when you think about the entire draft
though
all of these players can run from the
running backs to the defensive linemen
the linebackers plenty of speed in this
year's draft and then one more corner
for the baltimore ravens damien williams
six four and a half
uh as well i mean just again just the
length that these cornerbacks are
providing to the position now it's
totally different when i first came when
i came out into the national football
league corners were six foot five eleven
five eight five ten guys that could move
can mirror you had good transition these
guys now are longer physical put their
hands on you and are willing tacklers
but those are the things that stood out
to me today love it i love it i
absolutely love it let's take a look at
the big board one more we'll look at
felder's faves first we got something in
there look at that
the names are starting to evaporate we
got half the names off the board felder
uh one more time for jamari salyer yeah
man i love the kid i love the way that
he plays football i think he's awesome
hopefully he gets picked in the draft if
not i'll tell you what if this guy's a
udfa
somebody's gonna have to pay
did that somebody gonna have to pay when
he gets the mini camp and it's somebody
got to pay real big when he gets to
training camp mckinley i'm very curious
to see where he ends up mccormick is a
good player and lucita smith and uh two
two developmental guys that are gonna be
really good for somebody that has the
ability to kind of stash them and grow
their abilities all right we'll take a
look at the big board one more time we
still have carson strong on there beau
melton my guy malcolm rodriguez is still
on the board as well you see jamari
sawyer of course castro field three
castro fields not selected in jojo dom's
another one of those money backers not
selecting the first five rounds a lot of
power backs taken today no abram smith
former linebacker converted to running
back i'm a little surprised by that i
like what i saw on tape from abram smith
there you like abram smith more than
tristan ebner oh yes okay yeah i think
abrams i like that linebacker mentality
out of the running back i didn't have
the tread on the tires i think you're
getting a fresh leg so
these these to me are incredible value
picks sawyer to me long-term starters
samuel malcolm rodriguez carson strong a
developmental quarterback bo melton a
starter in the slot for ron mckinley a
third safety instinctual uh rasheed
walker is definitely a guy you want to
develop as a swing tackle jeffrey gunter
an athletic edge rush still trying to
figure it out but the tools are all
there abram smith the power back jojo
doman a nickel linebacker that can cover
and to recastro fields who i think has
cb2 upside so i think he should come off
the board in the sixth round this has
been a lot of fun and it always is all
three days of the nfl draft it was
amazing that felder back before we sign
off i want to bring tory holt on one
more time torrey was incredible he knew
every player we threw out today he knew
the team needs
tory this was great man it was great to
have you a part of the day three of the
draft and wanted to say goodbye
absolutely thank you guys for having me
it was a pleasure working with you mike
and connor you guys do an absolutely
fantastic job covering the draft it's a
pleasure thank you tori all right for
michael felder felder you got any
sign-off notes yo anything is possible
baby
oh man he's michael felder i'm connor
rogers thanks so much for rocking with
bleacher report for the nfl draft this
is the place you want to be days one two
and three we'll catch you next year
[Music]
you
[Music]
you